I DID A LOT DARKER SIDE.
HEY SO I SEE OUR MYSTERIOUS
YEARS I'D LIKE TO CALL THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF
JUDGMENT AND THE ARTS.
TODAY MAY SIXTEENTH TO ORDER.
AND I WANT TO.
WELCOME EVERYONE HERE AND WISH
THE VERY GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US I I FIRST
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE. OUR TODAY
SPEAKERS I WANT TO THANK THEM
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO TESTIFY.
BEFORE OUR COMMITTEE WE WE VERY
MUCH THANK THEM FOR THE REMARKS
THEY WILL BE PROVIDING.
WE APPRECIATE MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC WERE JOINING US BOTH HERE
IN OUR HEARING ROOM AND ALSO ON
LIVE STREAM.
BUT TODAY'S INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. THE TOPIC IS
CALIFORNIAN HUMAN COMPANY
HUMANITIES BUILDING BRIDGES. IN
AMPLIFYING VOICES AND IT'S GOING
TO EXPLORE THE HUMANITIES WHAT
THEY ARE THE WAYS IN WHICH THEY
INTERSECT WITH THE ARTS HOW THEY
ARE A CHANGING IN THE DIGITAL
AGE.
WE'RE GONNA BE ASKING SUCH
QUESTIONS AS WHAT VALUES DO THE
ARTS AND HUMANITIES HAVE IN OUR
DIVERSE STATE WITH THEIR ROLE.
IN A DEMOCRATIC SOCIETY.
DURING A VISIT TO STANFORD
AUTHOR PHILOSOPHER AND UNIVERSE
CHICAGO PROFESSOR MARTHA
NUSSBAUM ANSWERED THIS QUESTION
SHE NOTED THAT.
HUMANITIES AND ARTS PROGRAMS ARE
BEING CUT AT ALL LEVELS OF
EDUCATION NOT ONLY IN THE U. S.
BUT UNFORTUNATE ALSO AROUND THE
WORLD THIS. TREND HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO CREATE A GENERATION
OF. CITIZENS WHO ARE ILL
EQUIPPED TO PARTICIPATE IN A
DEMOCRATIC SOCIETY FOR THE MORE.
SHE NOTED THAT ARTS SPARKS
CURIOSITY FOR THE UNFAMILIAR. BY
LEARNING TO SING MUSIC FROM
ANOTHER TIME AND PLACE THE
CHILDREN LEARN ABOUT THEIR ROLE
IN THE COMMUNITY AND THE WORLD.
THE ARTS AND HUMANITIES SEE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ABLE TO SEE OTHER
HUMAN BEINGS IS FULL OF PEOPLE
WITH THOUGHTS AND. AND FEELINGS
AND ALSO BUILD NATIONS THAT ARE
ABLE TO OVERCOME FEAR AND
SUSPICION. IN FAVOR OF
SYMPATHETIC AND WELL REASONED
DEBATE.
THESE THOUGHTS WERE SHARED WITH
STUDENTS AT STANFORD IN TWENTY
TWELVE BUT THEY CERTAINLY RING
TRUE TODAY.
OUR SELECTION OF CURRENT TIMES
AND AND CURRENT EVENTS.
SO TODAY WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING
FROM KATRINA WOOLWORTH WILL
SHARE HER* ARE A REPORT ON
THE CURRENT STATE. OF THE
HUMANITIES AND EDUCATION ALSO I
WILL BE LOOKING AT AND THE TREND
LINE THAT PROFESSOR NUSSBAUM
EXPRESSED CONCERN ABOUT SIX
YEARS AGO.
WERE CERTAINLY VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE STATE OF FUNDING OF
THE NE A SUPPORT FOR THE ARTS
AND HUMANITIES AT THE NATIONAL
LEVEL.
I WAS VERY DISAPPOINTING TO SEE.
THAT WHEN THE THE TWENTY
NINETEEN WHITE HOUSE.
A BUDGET PROPOSAL PRESENTED IN
FEBRUARY INCLUDED AGAIN THE
WINDING DOWN OF THE NATIONAL
DOWN FOR THE AMENITIES AND THEN
ASK THEM FOR THE ARTS.
BLUE.
FORTUNATELY A BIPARTISAN EFFORT
OF MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS COMING
TOGETHER. AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL
TO REJECT THIS PROPOSAL.
THEY SUSTAIN AND THEN EVEN RAISE
THOSE BUDGETS INCLUDED A THREE
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE FOR EACH
AGENCY THAT SCORES A MINUSCULE
AMOUNT FOR ARTS AGENCIES THAT
HAVE.
YOU KNOW IT DECIDED IMPACT IN
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE NATION AT
LEVERAGE CLOSE TO TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS OVER FIVE
DECADES.
SO YOU KNOW THIS IS A THIS IS A
COMMON EFFORT THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO PUSH BACK ON I I
CERTAINLY HOPE YOU'RE GONNA.
I ENJOY SOME OF THE
CONVERSATIONS ARE GONNA BE
HAVING TODAY. PROJECTS THAT WILL
BE SHOWCASING.
PROJECTS FROM ALL OVER THE
STATE THAT SPEAK TO THE MANY
POWERFUL AND CREATIVE WAYS IN
WHICH HUMANITIES ARE BEING
UTILIZED TO SUPPORT. AND CONNECT
WITH ALL SORTS OF DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ONE AREA THAT WILL
BE SPENDING SOME TIME LOOKING
LOOKING AT I SEE WE HAVE OUR
MUSEUMS STAY FOCUSED HERE
POLITICIZED THERE YOU GO. ARE AA
EITHER AS I SAY DOWN OKAY.
YEAH GOD SO BUSY AND CERTAINLY
DO PLAY A VERY IMPORTANT ROLE IN
THIS IN THIS WORLD AND I I'M
PROUD TO BE A CONVERTIBLE CAR
AUTHORS ON AMBER AND WHAT OCCURS
USE MUSEUMS FOR ALL BILL THAT'S.
MAYBE NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR A
VERY AUSPICIOUS.
NUMBER.
AID REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL AND HISTORICAL
ENDOWMENT TO ESTABLISH. THE
CALIFORNIA MINUTE MUSEUMS FOR
ALL GRANT PROGRAM TO INCREASE
ACROSS. ACCESS TO MUSEUMS.
FOR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES IN
PARTICULAR.
SO ANYWAY WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
GREAT TURMOIL IN THE WORLD OF
PERVASIVE A PERVASIVELY DIVISIVE
MOOD ACROSS OUR COUNTRY. I JUST
THIS WEEK A MAN SCREAMED
ISLAMOPHOBIC COMMENTS AT A WOMAN
PERSON COFFEE AT A COFFEE SHOP A
COFFEE BEAN AND RIVERSIDE. SHE
WAS DRESSED IN TRADITIONAL
MUSLIM ATTIRE YOU KNOW IN THIS
CASE THE ESTABLISHMENT DID THE
RIGHT THING AND REFUSE SERVICE
TO THE MAN KICKED HIM OUT. FOR
HEARING TOO MANY. TOO MANY
INCIDENCES LIKE THIS.
I BELIEVE THIS HEARING IS VERY
TIMELY I HOPE WILL SPUR
NECESSARY DISCUSSION ON WAYS IN
WHICH WE CAN FOR THE SUPPORT THE
ARTS AND HUMANITIES IN OUR
STATE.
WHICH IN TURN WILL SUPPORT HIM A
MORSE OF CIVIL SOCIETY OUR WILL
WE'RE LOOKING TO EACH OTHER
BETTER UNDERSTAND EACH OTHER
STORIES WHERE WE COME FROM WE'RE
GOING. IN UNDERSTAND OUR COMMON
HUMANITY. SO BEFORE I TURN OF
THE DICE OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES I
JUST WANT TO QUOTE ANOTHER GREAT
ARTS AND HUMANITIES ADVOCATE ARE
FORMER FIRST LADY MICHELLE
OBAMA.
WHO NOTED THAT THE ARTS AND
HUMANITIES DEFINE WHO WE ARE AS
A PEOPLE?
THAT IS THEIR POWER TO REMIND US
OF WHAT WE HAVE.
TO OFFER WHAT WE EACH HAVE TO
OFFER AND AND WHAT WE ALL HAVE
IN COMMON.
TO HELP US UNDERSTAND OUR
HISTORY. AND TO IMAGINE OUR
FUTURE TO GIVE US HOPE IN THE
MOMENTS OF STRUGGLING TO BRING
US TOGETHER. WHEN NOTHING ELSE
WILL.
WHEN NOTHING ELSE WELL THAT'S A
TRULY THE POWER OF THE ARTS AND
HUMANITIES AND. I LOOK FORWARD
TO OUR HEARING TODAY AND I WOULD
LOVE TO GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MY MY VICE CHAIR CANCER JUNE THE
CELL NUMBER. TO SAY A FEW WORDS
AND AND ANY OF OUR OTHER
COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES YOU'D LIKE
TO SPEAK.
WELL GOOD AND GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS CATHERINE SHU
I'M IN. THE CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY ARTS ENTERTAINMENT
SPORTS TOURISTS AND AND THE
INTERNET MEDIA COMMITTEES WHILE
IT IS NOT IN MY COMPANY NAMED.
THE HUMANITY ON COMPASSES ALL OF
THE ELEMENTS OF COULD COME HERE
OF MY COMEDY PLUS US SO MUCH
MORE. AND TODAY WE'RE HERE TO
TALK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
HUMANITY. AND I WOULD
DEFINITELY.
WOULD UNDERSTAND THE COMMAND HE
HELP US UNDERSTAND OUR SELF AND
OTHERS. IN HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE
ARE KNOWN FOR OUR CREATIVITY'S
DIVERSITY. AND CULTURALLY RICH
COMMUNITIES OR STAY UNDERSTAND
THE IMPORTANCE OF HUMANITY. AT
HOUSE PARTNER WAS THE NATIONAL
ADULT MEN FOR HUMANITIES TO
SUPPORT THEM SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE. THROUGH TO
CALIFORNIA HUMANITY AND DALTON.
AND TODATE THERE IS SOME LITTLE
GOOD LITTLE GOOD NEWS THE US
HOUSE APPROPRIATIONS
SUBCOMMITTEE ALLOCATED TO
MARYLAND INCREASE. TO THE
NATIONAL ENDOWMENT FOR THE
HUMANITIES SO BRINGING THEIR
BUDGET TO ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY
FIVE MILLION. FOR THE YEAR OFF
TWENTY NINETEEN. AS WE DISCUSSED
WAYS TO BRIDGE ARE DIVERSE
CULTURES. AND EXPERIENCE THROUGH
THE KILL HUMANITY I'M INTERESTED
IN LEARNING HOW CALIFORNIA CAN
PASS USE ALL RESOURCES.
INCLUDING THE FUNDING FOR THE
NATIONAL INVOLVEMENT AND TO USE
THEM OTHER. SOURCES OF SUPPORT.
I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
THE ASHFORD AND LEARNING MORE
ABOUT HOW WE CAN. ROLL
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE
AGENCIES AND LOCAL CULTURAL
PROGRAMS AND HELP TO HUMANITY TO
DRIVE ALONE AGAIN THANK THE
CHAIRMAN. WILL PUTTING THOSE WHO
ARE HERE IN TOGETHER AND I HAVE
REALLY ENJOYED OUR PEACE AND AND
A COVERED STREETS HERE THIS.
OF
FOUGHT.
FAR BE ARMED RODRIGUEZ AND THE.
ON IN THE AUDIENCE NO BUT WITH A
YEAR. LISA SEMI COMPLIMENT TO
THIS BEAUTIFUL OUR PEOPLE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
WELL THANK YOU. CAROLINE AND.
VICE CHAIR AT YOU IT'S. A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE ACTUALLY I
THINK IT'S KIND OF INTERESTING.
.
SO THERE ARE YOU I. WAS ABOUT
PHYSICS MAJOR SO WE TALK ABOUT
THE HARD SCIENCES I KNOW THAT.
.
TO THE ENGINEER. I GUESS WE'LL
PUT UP WITH THE TOURNEY HERE
AMONG US AS.
BUT. IT REALLY THINK IT'S GREAT
WE'RE HERE TOGETHER TALK ABOUT
THE HUMANITIES.
YOU KNOW OFTENTIMES PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF.
INTERNET SUPPORT SPORES OF
SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY AND YOU KNOW
MATH.
BUT WITHOUT THE HUMANITIES
WHICH PROVIDES INSPIRATION AND
PROVIDES GUIDANCE.
THEN I THINK THAT WE AS A
COMMUNITY AND THE SOCIETY.
OR OF WORK ARE MUCH POORER AT
FOR THAT AND CERTAINLY IS A
PHYSICIAN UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO
BRING THOSE. PARTS TOGETHER SO.
DOES NOT GLAD THAT WE'RE HAVING
THIS DISCUSSION HERE.
AND.
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
PRESENTATIONS.
WELL IT'S TRUE I DO HAVE A
DISMAL LAW DEGREE I I ACTUALLY
MY UNDERGRADUATE DEGREES IN
HISTORY MY MASTER'S DEGREES IN
LATIN AMERICAN STUDIES MY. MOM
WAS A SPANISH TEACHER MY FATHER
WITH A.
ENGLISH PROFESSOR AT UCLA SO.
YES WE'RE YES SHE'S AN ARTIST AS
WELL SO WE'VE GOT A LOT OF FUN.
I LET IT LET HUMANITY IS IN MY
BLOOD AND STARTS A LIST NOW NOW
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH A BOW
BEFORE YOU.
NO NO I I WE BATTLE FOR THE
SCIENCES OR THE HUMANITIES ARE
JUST YOU KNOW FIGHTING TO.
YOU KNOW TO TO TO TO TO ASSERT
THEIR THEIR THEIR RIGHTFUL PLACE
AT THE TABLE OKAY SO. I'M OKAY
WHAT WE'LL HEAR FROM SEVERAL
PANELS THEN WE'LL OPEN IT
HEARING TO PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END I'M.
THE.
CERTAINLY YEAH WE'RE TAKING A
LIST OF FOLKS WANT A PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL WE'LL HEAR FROM
FOLKS. IF YOU ARE FOLLOWING THE
HEARING ON LINE EVERYONE IS
WELCOME TO YOU.
SEND INPUT TO US AT SENATOR DOT
ALLEN AT SENATE DOT CA DOT GOV
OR ANY OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE ALL
LISTED ON THE WW DOT SENATE DOT
CA DOT GOV ARTS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND WITHOUT FURTHER ADO
I'D LIKE TO CALL IT OUR FIRST
PANEL WILLIAM DEVEREAUX WHO SAID
PHD AND DIRECTOR. OF THE HUNTING
USC INSTITUTE ON CALIFORNIA THE
WEST AND HE'S GOING TO GIVE US.
AN INTRODUCTION DEFINITIONS AN
OVERVIEW OF THE HUMANITIES.
PROFESSOR DEBORAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS WILLIAM
DEVER L..
CHAIRMAN ALLEN VICE CHAIR CHEW
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY THANKS
FOR THE INVITATION TO BE HERE
WITH YOU TODAY. I'M AN
HISTORIAN.
ODDLY ALLEGIANT TO THE
HUMANITIES AND PRACTICE AND
PASSION.
I TEACH HISTORY USC IN MY
POSITION ALLOWS ME TO BE IN
RESIDENCE AT THE HUNTINGTON
LIBRARY FOR RESEARCH AND
TEACHING.
TWO HUMANNESS THIS IS THE
INTELLECTUAL VERSION OF OFFERING
A KID THE KEYS TO THE CANDY
STORE.
I'VE SERVED ON THE BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA AMENITIES TWICE THAT
SERVICE HAS BEEN THE MOST
REWARDING PUBLIC WRK OF MY
CAREER.
IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO WORK AT THE
SCENE BETWEEN THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC IN THE SCHOLARLY WORLD.
OF IN MY CASE AMERICAN HISTORY
SPECIFICALLY THE HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE AMERICAN WEST.
MY PROMPT THIS AFTERNOON IS TO
DEFINE THE HUMANITIES.
IT'S NOT AN EASY QUESTION.
ONE ANSWER MOST OF THE ONE THAT
I MOSTLY GOOD WITH. IS THAT THE
HUMANITIES OCCUPY THAT SECTOR OF
KNOWLEDGE PRODUCTION CARVED OUT
BY A SET OF DISCIPLINARY
INTERESTS HISTORY LITERATURE
PHILOSOPHY AND CLASSICS AMONG
THEM.
AS WELL AS COGNATE FIELDS
INTERPRETING TEXTS OR ART EVENTS
IN LIVES MOMENTS AND ERAS.
WITHIN THE UNIVERSITY WHERE THE
FIELD SANDWICHED IN BETWEEN THE
SOCIAL SCIENCES AND THE ARTS.
WE ARE THE LETTERS IN COLLEGES
OF LETTERS ARTS AND SCIENCES WE
ARE THE BOOK PEOPLE.
WE READ THEM AND WE WRITE THEM
AND WE MAKE OUR STUDENTS READ
THEM AND THINK ABOUT THEM.
THAT'S ONE WAY TO DEFINE THE
HUMANITIES AND IT'S USEFUL.
A SET OF FIELDS EXPLORING IDEAS
ABOUT THE HUMAN CONDITION AND
ABOUT HUMANITY.
ON OUR BEST DAYS WE THINK OF OUR
WORK AS A CALLING. AND WE REVEL
IN THE CIVIL EXCHANGE OF IDEAS
ABOUT JUST WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
HUMAN.
WE ACKNOWLEDGE AND DRAW
SUSTENANCE FROM THAT ROOT OF THE
WORD ITSELF.
THE HUMAN IN THE HUMANITIES.
BUT ALLOW ME TO BRING ACADEMIC
AND POINTY HEADED DISTINCTIONS
TO THE GROUND AND A REAL
EXPERIENCE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE HUMANITIES ARE BRIDGE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE BRIDGE BETWEEN
SCHOLARSHIP AND THE PUBLIC WHICH
ALL OF US SERVE.
THE HUMANITIES OBLIGATE US TO
SPEAK TO BIG AUDIENCES AND BIG
PUBLIC'S.
OF COURSE THERE'S ROOM FOR
ARCANE ACADEMIC ARGUMENT AND
LANGUAGE.
THERE IS TECHNICAL PROVISIONS IN
THE POSITION IN THE HUMANITIES
ARGUMENTS STEEPED IN ARCHAIC
TEXTS LANGUAGES EXPERIENCES.
BUT AT HEART DOING HUMANITIES AS
AN ACT OF TRANSLATION.
FOSTERING THE TRANSMISSION OF
IDEAS AND INSIGHTS FROM THE
ACADEMY TO BROADER PUBLIC'S.
BUT THIS IS A BRIDGE OPEN THE
TWO WAY TRAFFIC.
BECAUSE OUR MEDIUM IS USUALLY
WORDS SPOKEN WRITTEN SONG OR
OTHERWISE. WE CAN AND DO BRING
THE PUBLIC'S WORDED LIVES AND
CONCERNS IN ACADEMIC SETTINGS.
SO AS TO MAKE THE PUBLIC'S YOUR
EARNINGS LEGITIMIZED FOR
ACADEMIC RESEARCH.
SO AS TO MAKE THE PUBLIC HEARD.
THE HUMANITIES COMMUNICATE.
ME TO MY CLASSROOM YES BUT SO
TOO FROM THE WORLD OF
CALIFORNIANS TO THAT CLASSROOM.
CALIFORNIANS YOUNG AND OLD
CALIFORNIANS FROM EVERY WALK OF
LIFE AND EVERY CORNER OF THE
STATE.
WE ARE CALIFORNIANS ALL.
THINK OF WHAT WE ASK THE
HUMANITIES TO TEACH US.
THINK OF THE BONDS OF COMMUNITY
AND PURPOSE WE ASK THE
HUMANITIES TO FORGE.
THINK BACK.
THE HUMANITIES TELL US WHERE WE
WHO WE ARE. MYSTERIOUS PUZZLING
OPEN TO DEBATE WHO CAME FIRST TO
CALIFORNIA WHO POPULATED THIS
PLACE AND WHEN.
THE HUMANITIES PACKAGE DATA.
DENVER CHRONOLOGY ARCHAEOLOGY
PALEONTOLOGY FORENSIC
ANTHROPOLOGY. AND HELP TELL
HUMAN STORY OF MIGRATION FROM
FAR TO THE NORTH. FROM THE STEPS
FROM ASIA OR MAYBE FROM
POLYNESIA BY OUTRIGGER CANOES
ALL THOUSANDS OF YEARS AGO
LIKELY MORE. THE HUMANITIES POSE
ORIGIN STORIES FOR CALIFORNIA
JUST THAT THEY INTERPRET AND
ANALYZE THEM.
THE HUMANITIES IN THIS WAY
REMIND US OF OUR PATRIMONY OF
ANCIENT DIVERSITY. PRE DATING
ANY MODERN JUST ASSUMPTIONS OF
DIFFERENCE IN MULTI CULTURALISM.
THEY MAKE OF CHAIN A CHAIN OF
HUMANITY THAT STOPS FOR THE
MOMENT WITH US.
THE AMENITIES CAUTION US AND
THEN NOBLE US.
OF COURSE WE FIND PAIN AND
HEARTACHE IN THE PAST.
THE HUMANITIES TEACHERS FOR
INSTANCE ABOUT GENOCIDAL
VIOLENCE INTO CALIFORNIA'S
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES. A MURDEROUS
KNOWS THAT WE MUST PLACE AGAINST
ANY QUITE VISION OF HAPPY GO
LUCKY GOLD RUSH MINERS SPLASHING
IN SIERRA STREAMS. AS THEY
ILLUMINED THE GOLD STATE GOLDEN
STATE IN NICKNAME AND HOPE.
THEY DID SPLASH
BUT THEY KILLED TWO.
THE HUMANITIES DOESN'T EXPECT
THEM TO BE WITHOUT SIN. NOR DOES
IT LET THESE YOUNG MEN OFF
HISTORIES HOOK OF JUDGMENT.
SIMULTANEOUSLY THE HUMANITIES
RAISES UP THE BEST OF US AND OF
THEM.
THE POETS IN THE LYRICAL WHO
MADE OF CALIFORNIA DREAM. THE
MUSICAL THIS DRIVERS.
AND ALL THOSE WHOSE LIVES THEY
TOUCHED AND WHO YET ARE TOUCHED
BY THEM.
I TEACH BRET HART I TEACH
RICHARD HENRY DANA I TEACH
DESIRE ROYCE AND DAME SHIRLEY.
AND THE STORIES OF CHILEAN GOLD
MINERS I TEACH ISHI AND FATHER
SERRA. I TEACH THE LIES OF
MISSION INDIANS WHO LEARN
SPANISH AND CATHOLIC SACRAMENTS
BUT WHO MADE CERTAIN THAT THEIR
GRAVES HAD INDIAN BEADS AND
SHELLS ALONG SIDE. INQUISITION
ERA CATHOLIC PRAYERS AS THEIR
FINAL SEND OFF BECAUSE. WELL
BECAUSE THIS LIFE IN THE
AFTERLIFE FOR COMPLICATED.
THE HUMANITIES HELP US SEE AND
SOMETIMES UNLOCK THAT VERY
COMPLEXITY.
THE HAND HUMANITIES GUIDE MY
STUDENTS FORWARD PAST THE GOLD
RUSH. UNDER THE WAYS WHICH
CALIFORNIA PLAYED A CRITICAL
ROLE IN THE COMING OF THE
AMERICAN CIVIL WAR.
UNDER RECONSTRUCTION AND
URBANIZATION. THE RISE OF LOS
ANGELES WAR AND DEPRESSION AND
MORE WAR.
WE HANG OUT WITH WOODY GUTHRIE
IN LOS ANGELES WE WALK WITH
CHAVEZ AND WHERE TO AND JOHN
STEINBECK.
WE EXPLORE THE RISE OF NIXON AND
REAGAN OF EDMUND BROWN SENIOR
AND JUNIOR OF STANFORD AND SALLY
RIDE OF JOAN DIDION. AND
BREITBART ANGELA DAVIS MARIO
SAVIOLA. AND WE THINK HARD ABOUT
FILMS AND FREEWAYS NATIONAL
PARKS EARTHQUAKES AND FIRES
CRIME AND PUNISHMENTJAILS ND
REDEMPTION. JUSTICE AND
OPPRESSION.
CALIFORNIA IS A BIG AND OFTEN
BEAUTIFUL CAMPUS UPON WHICH TO
PAINT AND UP TO PICTURE LIVES
PAST AND PRESENT. AND HUMANITIES
ARE THE MEDIUM THAT BRINGS IT
ALL TO LIFE.
THEY ECHO ACROSS TIME AND SPACE
THEY TAKE US FROM THE CLASSROOM
TO THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
BRIDGING EXPERIENCE AND
KNOWLEDGE AN AUDIENCE. THE
HUMANITIES CAPTIVATE FOURTH
GRADERS MAKING SENSE OF THEIR
STATE. AND THE HUMANITIES LISTEN
TO THOSE SAME TEN YEAR OLD WHEN
THEY SPEAK ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS
TO BE A CALIFORNIA.
THE HUMANITIES TAKE US FROM
TEXTBOOK LEARNING.
TWO SOURCES TUCKED AWAY IN
ARCHIVES TO THOSE UNDER THE BED.
IN THE ATTIC OUT IN THE GARAGE
EVEN IN THE GARBAGE.
I'VE KNOWN MANY A DUMPSTER
DIVING LIBRARIAN AND ARCHIVIST
OF MY TIME. THESE HEROES RESCUE
THE DNA BUILDING BLOCKS OF OUR
SHARED HUMANITIES CULTURE IN THE
THANKS WE GIVE THEM. IS NOTHING
TO WHAT GRATITUDE THE FUTURE
WILL BESTOW ON THEM.
THE HUMANITIES THE
INTERPRETATION OF WORDS
HISTORIES AND EXPERIENCES OF
BEING HUMAN. OF BEING
CALIFORNIA.
CARRY WEIGHT FOR ALL OF US.
THEY DRAW US TOGETHER EVEN AS
THEY HONOR OUR DIFFERENCES.
THEY HELP SOLDER AND SUSTAINED.
THE GREAT CHAIN OF BEING WE'VE
BEEN PERFECTLY CONSTRUCTED OUT
HERE ON THE FAR WEST COAST OF
NORTH AMERICA.
CALIFORNIA IS A NECKLACE OF
EXPERIENCES AND HISTORIES
MEMORIES AND DREAMS THAT WE HAVE
ALL CONCOCTED. BOTH INDIVIDUALLY
AND COLLECTIVELY.
THE HUMANITIES ADD VALUE TO ALL
THAT. HUMANITIES ARE I THINK OUR
ACTUAL VALUES.
THAT THE HUMANITIES ARE ABOUT
THE VERY POOR ASSUME THAT
DEFINES US SUGGESTS TO ME THAT
THE PRACTICE OF THE HUMANITIES.
OUGHT TO DRAW SUSTENANCE FROM
THE VERY PUBLIC THAT THEY IN
TURN INEVITABLY MOLD AND
SUSTAIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELL I I WOULD I SIGN UP FOR
YOUR CLASS RIGHT HERE IS THAT WE
HAVE MILITARY AND.
THANK YOU YEAH YEAH YEAH YEAH
YEAH I KNOW THAT JUST FANTASTIC
APPRECIATE THAT THAT FRAMING.
.
WITH CERTAINLY YOU KNOW I WOULD
LOVE TO THAT I'M I'M READING
YOUR BIO AND I WANT TO CHECK OUT
THESE BLACKWELL COMPANIONS AS.
THAT YOU'VE WORKED ON I GUESS
THAT THOSE ARE.
YEAH I WILL COME BACK FOR ONE
SECOND.
AND.
WHAT'S YOUR TO TELL ME WHAT TELL
ME MORE ABOUT THE BUCKLE
COMPANIONS AND TELL ME WHAT YOUR
LATEST WORK IS WITH WHAT WITH
WITH YOUR WITH YOUR WHAT WERE
YOU WRITING ABOUT RIGHT NOW
YOU'RE VERY KIND CENTER THE
BLACKWELL COMPANIONS ARE
COMPILATIONS OF.
CUTTING EDGE SCHOLARLY WORK
THE THREE I'VE WORKED ON.
OR THE AMERICAN WEST CALLIE
ANALOGIES ARE THEY THEY'RE
ANTHOLOGIES OF ORIGINAL
SCHOLARLY ESSAYS SO ROUTE TWENTY
FIVE S. IS A PIECE BY THE BEST.
I THINK THE BEST TIME.
CONTEMPORARY ESSAYS AHA TAKING
APART IN THIS CASE THE WEST
CALIFORNIA LOS ANGELES IN
SEQUENCE.
TRY THE NEXT ONE I GUESS IS
PROBABLY THE HISTORY OF PASADENA
OR SOMETHING TICKET. O'CONNOR.
AND THEN.
.
I SPENT.
THE FIRST HALF OF TODAY IN THE
STATE ARCHIVES.
RESEARCHING A NEW BOOK ABOUT A
TRAGIC EVENT IN.
THE LATE NINETEEN FORTIES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WERE A LITTLE GIRL TUMBLED INTO
AN ABANDONED WELL AND.
THE EVENT INVENTED LIVE
TELEVISION.
INVENTED REALITY TELEVISION AND
I'M WRITING A BOOK ABOUT THAT
COMING OUT WHILE.
FASCINATING OKAY.
WELL VERY COOL VERY VERY COOL
ALRIGHT. A QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE HERE.
IS THERE IS THERE ANYTHING THAT
YOU WANTED TO COMMENT ON THE
GRASS TO.
.
TIM STATEWIDE EFFORTS WHEN THE
HUMANITIES OR OR.
WE REACH ONCE OUR FRAME DAY
RIGHT EFFORTS COMING FROM STATE
GOVERNMENT WAS CALIFORNIA EITHER
FROM CALIFORNIA MANAGER FROM
STATE GOVERNMENT WELL ONLY TO
REITERATE THAT MY SERVICE ON THE
BOARD THE CALIFORNIA AMENITIES.
WHICH.
I'VE DONE TWICE IN MY CAREER.
HAS BEEN.
.
SO FUNDAMENTAL TO THE WAYS IN
WHICH I THINK ABOUT THE PUBLIC.
AND HOW I'D CATCH MY CLASSES
AND HOW I COACH MY RESEARCH AND
ITS REACH.
SO THAT KIND OF PARTNERSHIP FROM
THE ACADEMY INTO PUBLIC ROUNDS.
HAS BEEN NOT JUST INVIGORATING
BUT IT'S BEEN FEEL CHANGING FOR
ME PROFESSION CHANGING THEM SO
INTERACTING WITH.
THE INCREDIBLE DIVERSITY OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC FROM SCHOOL
KIDS ON UP TO. FOLKS IN SENIOR
CARE FACILITIES AND BRINGING THE
HUMANITIES TO THEM AND ALSO
HAVING THEM INFORM US ABOUT
THEIR OWN PERCEPTION OF THE
AMENITIES IN THEIR OWN HUMAN.
LIVES AND CONDITIONS IT'S.
IT'S CONSTANTLY.
ENERGIZING INVIGORATING STARTS
IT'S POWERFUL IS MOSTLY POWERFUL
AN ELECTION OUR FULL WE GET A
LITTLE WINDOW THAT TOO I MEAN
JUST BEING ABLE TO INTERACT WITH
SOME PEOPLE FROM DIFFERENT CROSS
SECTIONS OF OUR SCIETY COMING
UP HERE AND AND THAT.
I I GUESS I CAN VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT WELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR FRAMING
OUR DISCUSSION SO.
SO POIGNANTLY.
OKAY SO THE NEXT PANEL WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO SPLIT THE TWO
BECAUSE WE ONLY HAVE SO MUCH
SPACE HERE. OB SO WE'RE GONNA
START WITH THE THE FOLLOWING
GONNA START WITH THE JAMES CHAN
WHOSE PROJECT PREDICT PRODUCER
AND DIRECTOR FOR THE GOOD
MEDICINE PICTURE COMPANY AND
AND.
DID FOREVER CHINATOWN BY THE WAY
ALL THE BIOS IN. YOUR PACKET AND
THEY'RE WONDERFUL WITH YOU SO I
DO ENCOURAGE YOU TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THEM. I JAMES WILL BE JOINED
BY DANTE.
CLARK WHO'S SPOKEN WORD ARTISTS
CAN BE ACTIVE AS AN ACTOR HE WAS
INVOLVED ROMEO IS BLEEDING.
AND THEN CHRIS BROWN AND NOT
THE SINGER.
BUT.
DEBBIE COUNTY LIBRARIAN OF THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY LABOR
DISTRICT WHO WAS INVOLVED IN THE
PRODUCTION OF WAR IN CAMPBELL
HERE BUT ABOUT THAT AS WELL SO
LET'S START WITH YOU JAMES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CHAIRMAN ALAN AND AND VICE
CHAIRMAN XU AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS.
IT'S.
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE ONE TO
PULL FOCUS ON.
.
THE BY PRODUCT OF MY FILM AND.
CALIFORNIA HUMANITIES WHO GAVE
US FUNDING. AND.
LAUREN ARE WE GOING TO PLAY THE
CLIP FIRST OKAY SURE OKAY THIS
IS TRYING TO SAN FRANCISCO OF
THIS IS THAT THIS GUY THOUGHT
YES AND FANTASTIC.
YEAH THERE'S SOME.
IN THE LAST YEAR OR YEAR AND A
HALF I HAVE TROUBLE REMEMBERING
THINGS.
I'M GETTING VERY FORGETFUL AND
TIME. SO THAT'S WHAT MY PROBLEM
IS.
I WANT TO CAPTURE MY MEMORIES.
AND THE ONLY WAY FOR ME TO
CAPTURE MY MEMORIES IS TO MAKE
THEM.
IN THREE DIMENSIONS
.
ALL MY MINIATURES A COMPOSITE.
IT'S HALF WISHING. THEM
.
MEMORIES.
BEFORE.
THANK YOU.
I HAD AN INCREDIBLE SCENE.
SO THE FILM IS CALLED FOREVER
CHINATOWN AND IT IS ABOUT AN
EIGHTY TWO YEAR OLD CHINESE
AMERICAN ARTISTS WHO MAKES
MINIATURE MODELS OF SAN
FRANCISCO CHINATOWN. OF OF HIS
GRANDMOTHER'S KITCHEN HIS AUNT'S
DINING ROOM. IS.
FOUND OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS
LIVING ROOM HIS FRIEND'S STORE
FRONTS AND SO.
I WANTED TO MAKE A FILM.
THAT. HIGHLIGHTED A ON THE AT AS
YOUR MEMORY CHANGES AS YOU AGE
YOUR YOUR MEMORIES FADE AND YOUR
MEMORIES CHANGE AND MAP IT TO. A
NEIGHBORHOOD THAT IS ALSO
EXPERIENCING CHANGE AND CHANGE
IS AN INEVITABLE.
THROUGH LIKE A.
BUT THE. SO SO THIS FILM TOUCHES
ON THREE POINTS IT'S ABOUT AS
THE ARTIST HIS MEMORY HIS
ARTWORK.
.
THE COMMUNITY OF SERVICES GO
CHINATOWN AND ALSO IT SPEAKS
ABOUT THE ENCROACHING
REDEVELOPMENT THAT'S COMING I
THAT'S THAT'S GOING TO CHANGE
THIS THIS NEIGHBORHOOD. AND. AS
I MENTIONED.
CHANGE IS INEVITABLE BUT. WHEN
WHEN A COMMUNITY GETS.
WHEN REDEVELOPMENT HAPPENS AND
YOU DISPLACED FAMILIES THAT'S
WHEN A LINE NEEDS TO BE DRAWN.
SO THIS FILM ULTIMATELY.
I WANTED TO TOUCH UPON THAT
SOME GONNA READ A LITTLE BIT
FROM MY DIRECTOR STATEMENT SO A
LITTLE BACKGROUND OUT AT LEAST
HALF OF. THE FILM. I'M NOT SOME
CISCO BAY AREA FILMMAKER.
WITH ROOTS IN CHINA VIETNAM A
REFUGEE CAMP IN INDONESIA AND WE
GOT SPONSORED OVER TO THE
MIDWEST.
WHEN I WAS. AROUND FOUR FIVE
HUNDRED WEST ONE OF ENGL
MINNESOTA ACROSS.
SIMILAR TO VIETNAM YEAH YEAH
VERY SIMILAR YOU TAKE IT WAS THE
DEAD OF WINTER WHEN WE ARRIVE
FROM FROM THE TROPICS YOU MIGHT
WANT TO SPEAK. TO THE MICHAEL
OKAY.
OR DO YOU GOT IT. HOUSES.
IT'S ALRIGHT ARE HERE RIGHT OKAY
GREAT GREAT GREAT.
SO MY SENSIBILITIES ARE SHAPED
BY MY LIVED EXPERIENCES OF THESE
TRANSITORY IDEAS OF HOME.
UP THROUGH FRANK WANTS TO SEVEN
CHINATOWN DEAR RAMA'S FROM THE
RECENT FILMS FOREVER CHINATOWN.
THE UNREFINED SINGLE ROOM
OCCUPANCY TRANSPORTED. THIS
RELATE BACK TO MY CHILDHOOD AT
HOME. IN THE FIRST STUDIO
APARTMENT IN SAN FRANCISCO IT'S
A WORKING CLASS DISTRICT OF THE
TENDERLOIN. AND.
.
IT'S AN UNREFINED AT SINGLE ROOM
OCCUPANCY AND.
THE SUM OF MY FAMILY'S
BELONGINGS FIT INSIDE THIS
MINIATURE APARTMENT AND MY
IMAGINATION CONTRACTED AN
EXPANDED WITHIN THE BOUNDARIES
OF MY TWIN MATTRESS SIZE ROOM.
IT WAS A HALL CLOSET IN THE IT
WAS A MAKESHIFT HALL CLOSET
ROOM.
THROUGH THE DETAILED WORLD OF
FRANK ONES DO AROUND AS WE
EXPLORE THE EVOLUTION OF A
CHINESE AMERICAN COMMUNITY THAT
IS INTIMATELY INTERWOVEN WITH
THE HISTORY OF THAT CITY.
FOREVER CHINATOWN IS A FRIEND
STATE OF MIND IT IS A COMMENTARY
ON THE ENCROACHING CHANGES TO
THE NEIGHBORHOOD. AND IT IS MY
LOVE LETTER TO A BELOVED
COMMUNITY THAT HELP MY FAMILY
AND MY DAD IN PARTICULAR.
FRANK BECOMES OUR GUIDE AS WE
JOURNEY BACK WITH HIM THROUGH
HIS IN ASTROLOGY NOSTALGIC
VISIONS OF HIS YOUTH. VIS A VIS
HIS ARTWORK AND PRESENT A
CHINATOWN.
EXQUISITE AS THEY ARE FRANK'S
LAVISH STORIES AND THE AROMAS
ARE COMPOSITES OF ONE PERSON'S
ROMANTICIZE EXPERIENCES OF
PLACES. BECAUSE HE IS HUMAN AND
HUMAN MEMORIES ARE FALLIBLE HIS
IS JUST ONE ENTRY POINT INTO THE
WORLD OF CHINATOWN.
AND IN AN EFFORT TO SHOW THE
LARGER PERSPECTIVE A CHINATOWN
WE END THE FILM AND PORTRAITS OF
THE COMMUNITY.
THE FILM NEEDED TO SEAMLESSLY
WEAVE TOGETHER THREE EQUAL PARTS
THE CONTOURS OF THE ARTIST'S
LIFE THE INTIMACY OF THE
INTIMACY OF HIS ART WORK. AND
THE HEART AND SOUL OF THE FILM
CHINATOWN.
I WANTED TO PULL FOCUS ON THE
ENCROACHING CHANGE TO THIS
HISTORIC NEIGHBORHOOD. BUT ALSO
I WANTED TO.
.
FOCUS ON A FEW OF THE CHINATOWN
COMMUNITY MEMBERS BECAUSE HE IS
ONLY ONE.
STORY AND SO IN THE END OF THE
FILM WE WE GET TO MEET DOROTHY
WHO.
SHE'S EIGHTY THREE YEARS OLD
SHE'S BORN AND RAISED IN THIS
THIS ALLEYWAY AND CHINATOWN
SHE'S STANDING IN FRONT. OF I
PULLED PORK FOCUS ON JOSHUA
CHUCK WHO WAS RECENTLY DISPLACED
IN A HOME THAT HE WAS.
RAISED IN A BORN AND RAISED IN
IN CHINATOWN. AND THE MAIN
REASON FOR PULLING FOCUS ON ALL
THESE IS. THAT.
I WANT TO FOCUS ON THE STRENGTH
OF. THE THREATENED COMMUNITY
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THEY ARE. THE
HUMAN PILLARS. OF THIS OF
SOCIETY.
AND SO.
FOR ME TO BE HERE IT'S IT'S A
IT'S A INCREDIBLE INCREDIBLE
HONOR ONE BECAUSE. CALIFORNIA
HUMANITIES WAS ONE OF OUR EARLY
EARLY THIS.
FOUNDATIONS THAT GAVE US FUNDING
AND WITH THAT WE WERE ABLE TO GO
INTO PRODUCTION I WAS ABLE TO
ASSEMBLE A TEAM GO INTO
PRODUCTION. AND.
.
WE FROM FROM THAT FOUND OF
FUNDING WE WERE ABLE TO ATTRACT
OTHER FOUNDATIONS LIKE CENTER
FOR ASIAN AMERICAN MEDIA AROUND
WE WERE ABLE TO SUPPORT GET
FUNDING FROM. SOME CISCO
FOUNDATION. THEM.
AND THIS FILM WENT ON IN THE
INTO THE WORLD AND.
WE CAME FULL CIRCLE BACK A YEAR
LATER WE ARE HERE AND WE JUST
RECEIVED OUR EMMY NOMINATION
FOR.
AWESOME AND IT'S NOT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND IT'S AN INCREDIBLE
LIKE IT'S INCREDIBLE HONOR
MAINLY BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST FOR
MYSELF IT IS FOR. A VALIDATION
TO. THE COMMUNITY OF CHINATOWN
TO SAY THAT YES YOUR YOUR
STORIES MATTER IN YOUR STORIES.
WE NEED TO BE PRESERVED AND SO
FOR MYSELF AS A FILMMAKER MY
TOOL IS THROUGH STORYTELLING
THROUGH PULLING FOCUS AND AND.
ON TO THE COMMUNITY AND.
THAT'S HOW I SERVE MY COMMUNITY.
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY COOL VERY CALM.
OKAY NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
DAUNTED BYTHE WAY I SHOULD
MENTION.
ENGINE THAT MARIAH REMY. HAD TO
CANCEL LAST MINUTE SO WERE ON.
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE HEARING FROM
HER BUT WE WE DO HAVE.
I FANTASTIC GROUP OBVIOUSLY AND
I WILL NOT HEAR FROM YOU MR
CLARK.
OF THE MEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD EVENING.
DANTE CORPORATION CALIFORNIA
AND WE'RE GOING TO WATCH. LEAVE
A SHORT CLIP TRAILER OF THE
DOCUMENTARY ROMEO IS BLEEDING.
I MEAN YOU THINK.
TWO HOW.
BOTH ALIKE IN DIGNITY.
AND EVERYONE WILL WE LAY OUR
SCENE.
FIRST TIME I.
AND I WAS LIKE THIS LEANING ON
IT AND AS I GOT INTO MY LIFE.
NOW WHEN I READ IT IS LIKE THIS
IT WAS GOING ON IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD RIGHT NOW. RACE
CALIFORNIA.
WELCOME LESS.
LAST WEEKEND WE HAD A SHOOTING
EVERY NIGHT.
ONE NIGHT WE HAD TO SHOOT. THE
GANG PROBLEM IS ABOUT.
THE REASON WHY WE ARE FIGHTING.
ARE PAIRED WAS FIGHTING.
HELLO BROTHER IS REALLY EASY. TO
BE AT THE.
ALWAYS ENVISIONED MYSELF BAND
SOMEBODY POURED.
I WANT TO BE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
DRUG DEALERS AND RACE. NOT
FAIRY.
BASICALLY THE BAD AGAIN OKAY
CELEBI INDICATES ROBBIE REALLY
GET LAST LAUGH.
A LOT.
DANTE WAS AT THAT INTERESTING
LIKE CROSSROADS WHERE HE HAD
JUST DISCOVERED SPOKEN WORD AT.
INTERESTED IN TEACHING INCIDENT
AT A STREET SO I I CHANGE MY
PROFESSION.
WE FEEL IT TAKES ROMEO AND
JULIET RE WRITE IT AND MAKE IT
FIT RACE ME. ROMEO IS FROM NORTH
RAISING JULIET FROM CENTRAL. YES
MAKE YOU LIVE.
BLACK.
I REALLY START LOOKING AT
PERSONAGES KILLING YOUR OWN.
KILLING YOUR OWN PEOPLE.
STEP FORWARD IF YOU HAVE LOST
SOMEONE TO GUN VIOLENCE. I GOT A
COMMUNITY THE PANEL OKAY LET
FEAR STOP ME AND ALL I GOT.
BROTHERS GOT KILLED COUPLE DAYS
AGO.
.
THIS.
WELL.
IT'S.
OUR IMITATION ALIVE.
I HAVE CONTROL OVER HOW TO PLAY
IN.
LIFE.
YOU HAVE VERY LITTLE.
ON.
TWO DAYS THAT I JUST WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT.
BUILDING BRIDGES.
AND AMPLIFY VOICES.
SO THAT THE PLANET IS
DOCUMENTARY WAS. BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE WITH OUR
ORGANIZATION THAT I HELPED CO
FOUND CALL RAW TALENT WHICH THE
FOUR RECENT ARTISTS WITH TALENT.
WAS PUT ON A LOT OF SPOKEN WORD
SHOWS FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE AT
RISK FOR NOW WE WILL SURVIVE.
BECAUSE THE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO IS
COMING TO ME FEEL COMFORTABLE
TALKING TO ME ABOUT THEIR DAILY
PROBLEMS BUT THEY FEEL LIKE
THEIR VOICES WILL BE HEARD IN
THE SCHOOL OR A PARENT'S DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND THEM. OR THE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM THEY DON'T HAVE
PEOPLE THAT REFLECTED THEM
TEACHING THEM THE CURRICULUM
THAT THE SCHOOL WAS IN FORCING
UPON THEM. SO THEY FEEL
COMFORTABLE COMING TO ME TO TALK
ABOUT THINGS THAT THEY WOULD
EXPERIENCE IN DAY TO DAY OUTSIDE
IN THE STREETS OF RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA. SO WE HAD. SET ASIDE
WEEKLY WORKSHOPS FOR THEM TO
COME TALK ABOUT A PROCESS TO THE
PROCESS OF WRITING IN A
PERFORMANCE SO WANTED TO MINCE
WORDS WIL BE MORGAN OF MINES
HAS SUGGESTED THAT WE DO ROMEO
AND JULIET. BUT HE WAS A ON.
A LOVE OF THEATER HE HAS ELEVEN
THEATER SO HE WANTED TO DO THE
ACTUAL PLAY ROMEO JULIET NOT
TOLD HIM WHY IT HAS TO MAKE
SENSE TO OUR COMMUNITY. IN ORDER
FOR PEOPLE TO REALLY RELATE TO
IT BECAUSE I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD. I WAS
INTRODUCED TO ROMEO JULIET BUT I
DON'T UNDERSTAND THE LANGUAGE
BECAUSE IT WAS OUT OF CONTEXT
FOR ME UNTIL I SAW THE VIDEO.
UNTIL I SAW LEONARDO DI CAPRIO
IN THESE WEIRD LITTLE A NINETIES
MOVIE PLANNED WITH THESE GUNS
INSTEAD OF FORCE AND I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT HE WAS SAYING.
BUT THE CONTEXT OF THE VISUALS
HELP ME RELATE TO THAT PART
BECAUSE THE GUNS IN THE FEUDING
AND SO I SAY I WANTED TO TAKE
THIS PLAY TO TALK ABOUT THE
VIOLENCE IS GOING ON IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD BECAUSE. IF THE
TEACHERS WOULD ALLOWED US TO
AMPLIFY OUR VOICES IN THE
CLASSROOM IMAGINES FORCE US TO
READ ABOUT VERONA IF THEY WANT
TO SHOW IN THE CURRICULUM HOW
MORONIC KENEXA RACE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THIS WAS GOING
ON BETWEEN MONTAGUE AND CAPULET
AS NOR VERSUS CENTRAL HOW CAN
YOU BE A PART OF SOLVING THIS
PROBLEM A SOLUTION BECAUSE ROMEO
AND JULIET DIE. AND I KNOW TOO
MANY PEOPLE THAT DIED IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD AT THAT TIME I WAS
GOING TO SCHOOL WITH A TEAM IS
ALL THESE YOUNG PEOPLE SORT OF
POINTED AT DOCUMENTARY WAS TO
TALK ABOUT. WHAT IF WE CAN'T
INTRODUCE THIS CURRICULUM FOR
THE YOUNG FOLKS NOW AND AT THE
END OF OUR PLAY OUR ROMEO JULIET
DIDN'T DIE AND THAT'S WHAT MADE
OUR CURRICULUM IN OUR PLAY? THAT
MUCH POWERFUL AS A SAY LIKE
TONIGHT WE CHOOSE LIFE. NO MORE
OF US IS GOING TO DIE AND THIS
IS HOW WE ENVISION OUR FUTURE TO
BE BUT IF WE HAD THE RESOURCES
TO DO THAT. ALL THE TIME THEN IT
WOULD TAKE JUST ONE DOCUMENTARY
AND I WAS THANKFUL THAT. CAL
HUMANITIES HAD THE THE RESOURCES
TO HELP US NOT ONLY BUILD THAT
BRIDGE WITH OTHER COMMUNITIES
OUTSIDE OF RICHMOND BUT
AMPLIFIED VOICE AND WE WERE ABLE
TO GO TO INDONESIA. ON THIS
PAST.
DECEMBER WHAT TO DECEMBER'S AGO
AND I WAS ABLE TO GO TO AND
DON'T NEED IT TO FOUR DIFFERENT
CITIES AND TALK TO THEM AND I
WAS ABLE TO CONNECT TO MY STORY
ALL THE WAY OVER THERE. I WOULD
HAVE NEVER THOUGHT THAT. ANYBODY
OUTSIDE OF RICHMOND CARED ABOUT
WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH ME BUT TO
BE ABLE TO GO TO INDONESIA FOR
TWELVE DAYS. AND THEY SHOW ME SO
MUCH LOVE AND THEY WAS IMPACTED
BY OUR STORY SHOW ME THE POWER
OF THE HUMANITIES AND THE ARTS
WE ALLOWED A SPACE TO BE
CULTIVATED. NASSAU WANTED TO
SHARE.
IF THEY'RE MAKING.
WHAT WITH THE STATUS OF THE FILM
IT'S PRODUCED IS OUT OF FILM IS
ALREADY PRODUCES ALREADY BEEN
RELEASED THIS PAST JULY ON THIS
ON I TUNES A NET FLAKES ON
GOOGLE PLAY ALL THEM A LITTLE
VISUALS? BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE
FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE WITH
NETFLIX SO. IS OUT THERE GREAT
GREAT GREAT GREAT.
I'M GOING TO GO WATCH IT.
ALRIGHT MISTER BROWN LIVED HERE
FOR YOU.
YEAH. QUICKER THANK YOU.
GETTING GOOD AFTERNOON.
SENATOR ALLEN COMMITTEE I'M
CHRIS BROWNE I'M THE DEPUTY
COUNTY LIBRARIAN FOR THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY LIBRARY DISTRICT.
I'M ONE OF THOSE LIBRARIANS AS
MENTIONED PRIOR WHO DUMPSTER
DIVES FOR BOOKS AND AND.
STANDS UP FOR THE HUMANITIES
AND I APPRECIATE BEING ABLE TO
COME OUT HERE TODAY AND TO.
SHARE.
MY TEAMS PROJECT WITH YOU
WARRING.
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE PROJECT
DOWN THANKFULLY. MOST OF US
DON'T HAVE TO GO TO WAR BUT FOR
THOSE WHO. SERVED IN COMBAT IT'S
IT'S AN EXPERIENCE THAT CAN
ISOLATE AND SEPARATE THEM FROM
THOSE WHO HAVEN'T.
NOW MANY OF MANY OF OUR VETERANS
HAVE A DIFFICULT TIME COMING
HOME. AND RE COMMITTING AN
INTEGRATING INTO CIVILIAN LIFE.
AND IT CAN BE AN OVERWHELMING
PROCESS FOR VETERANS STRUGGLING
TO BOTH PROCESS THEIR WARTIME
EXPERIENCE AND RECOVER FROM
PROFOUND LOSSES.
MANY VETERANS REPORT. DEEP
FEELINGS OF ALIENATION AND
ISOLATION AS WELL AS LOSS OF
PURPOSE. AND CLARITY FOR THEIR
FUTURE.
VETERANS CAN FEEL AS OTHER
FAMILY FRIENDS AND COMMUNITY.
DON'T UNDERSTAND THEM THEY'RE
CALLING TO MILITARY SERVICE WAR
WHY THEY WOULD GO TO WAR.
OUR PROJECTS OUGHT TO ADDRESS
OUR VETERANS FEELINGS IN THEIR
WORDS USING THEIR TATTOOS AS A
GATEWAY TO MEANINGFUL
CONVERSATION BETWEEN VETERANS.
AND CIVILIANS.
I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE THE
PROJECT DIRECTOR IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN FOR THIS EXHIBIT.
THAT'S A A PICTURE OF ALL TWENTY
FOUR VETERANS FROM THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
WE WERE ABLE TO COVER EIGHTEEN
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA.
.
IN TERMS OF WHO PARTICIPATED AND
AGAIN THE PURPOSE WAS TO BRING
BEGIN A DIALOGUE. BETWEEN
CIVILIANS AND RETURNING THAT'S.
AND EACH HAD TO SERVE AS A
CATALYST FOR THIS DIALOGUE SINCE
THE ARTISTIC CHOICES BY THE
VETERANS DIRECTLY. REPRESENT
THEIR MILITARY EXPERIENCES
CAPTURING.
EMOTIONS THAT ARE DIFFICULT TO
TALK ABOUT ESPECIALLY IN A
CULTURE THAT PRIZES TO WAS AS
AN.
HOW WE LAUNCH THE EXHIBIT IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN ON VETERANS
DAY AND AND IMMEDIATELY
ATTRACTED COVERAGE FROM?
PBS THE ATLANTIC NEWSWEEK. THE
WASHINGTON POST TO NAME A FEW.
OTHER POSTS FEATURED WARRING IN
A PIECE THAT.
DISCUSSED.
THE SITE AS A HIGHLY VISIBLE
PART OF A NATIONAL DIALOGUE THAT
ULTIMATELY LED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE.
CHANGING THEIR TATTOO POLICY. SO
IN OTHER WORDS IT'S AN EXHIBIT
THAT. ACTUALLY IMPACTED PUBLIC
POLICY.
HE THE HUMANITIES IMPACTING
IT WAS HUMBLING TO BE PART OF
SOMETHING THAT PLAYED AN
IMPORTANT.
IMPACT IN THAT COMMUNITY AND
HELP BRING ABOUT.
RECOGNITION AND SUPPORT FOR
VETERANS.
I'D LIKE TO ACTUALLY.
SHARE WITH YOU AN AUDIO CLIP
FROM THE EXHIBIT. THIS IS FROM
JOBS SLATER JEFF SERVED IN THE
ARMY.
HE DIDN'T VOLUNTEER HE
VOLUNTEERED FOR ROUTE CLEARANCE
WORK. WHICH IS AN EXTREMELY
EXTREMELY DANGEROUS DUTY THAT
PURPOSEFULLY CAUSES IED
DETONATION WHICH SHE
VOLUNTEERED.
SO THAT OTHER VETERANS WOULDN'T
BE INJURED.
AND THIS IS JEFF SLATER LIKE HER
LOCKER OVER.
AND. THEN WHEN I CAME HOME I WAS
PART YOU ACTUALLY TURN OUT.
AND.
WHAT IS THERE ON THE TOP TOP OF
EACH OTHER?
SERENITY YES YEAH.
SO IT'S UP.
OKAY GREAT
.
WHEN I CAME HOME I WAS PRAISED
AS A HERO.
SOMEONE WHO.
I PRESENTED OUR COUNTRY.
AT THE FINEST LEVELS.
I DIDN'T FEEL LIKE THAT AT ALL.
AND I GET PATS ON THE BACKS AND
PEOPLE ALMOST CRYING TELL ME HOW
PROUD THEY ARE OF ME.
THEY HAD NO TRUE UNDERSTANDING
OF HOW I FELT.
I WAS UNABLE TO LOVE I WAS
UNABLE EXPRESS EMOTIONS I WAS
VIOLENT VICIOUS.
I JUST I I LOST IT ALL I LOST MY
FIANCE I LOST MOST ALL MY
FRIENDS HIGH.
I CAN RELATE THERE WAS KNOWN
INTERACTION TO ME IN THEM THAT
WAS ON THE SAME LEVEL ANYMORE.
I ALWAYS KNEW I WANTED A HAND
GRENADE WITH WINGS TO ME THAT
DESCRIBES WHO I AM IN THIS WORLD
AS FAR AS.
I I FEEL LIKE THAT GRENADE WITH
THE PIN PULLED YOU NEVER KNOW
WHEN IT'S GOING TO GO OFF BUT
YOU KNOW EVENTUALLY IT DOES.
IN THE WINGS WERE SUPPOSED TO
MEAN.
MY JOURNEY THROUGH THIS WORLD.
AND. I DON'T KNOW WHO SAID IT
BUT SOMEONE SAID.
SERENITY IS NOT FREEDOM FROM THE
STORM.
YET IT IS PEACE AMID THE STORM.
AND THAT'S HOW I FEEL MY LIFE IS
THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO EVER BE
PERFECT AND IT'S GOING TO BE A
BATTLE AFTER BATTLE AFTER
BATTLE.
AND.
MY JOB ISN'T TO.
FIX EVERYTHING.
AND MAKE EVERYTHING PERFECT MY
JOB IS TO MAINTAIN. MY CALMNESS.
AND MY EMOTIONS. THROUGH THIS
BATTLE.
THAT HAD TO.
IS ALMOST A WAY TO KEEP MYSELF
IN CHECK WHEN I SEE IT.
IT REMINDS ME THAT.
I'M STRUGGLING TO GET TO A
HIGHER LEVEL OF ENLIGHTENMENT.
IT'S LIKE CARRYING AN ADDICTION
WITH YOU IT ALWAYS IS THERE SAT
SHADOW BEHIND YOU AND.
YOU NEVER LOSE THE ADDICTION YOU
JUS HOPE THAT YOU CAN STAY AWAY
FROM AS HIGH AS YOU CAN.
WHEN I SAT IN LIFE AND I'M
TRYING TO REACH IS TO.
CREATE A NEW ME.
WE HAD QUITE A BIT OF FEEDBACK
AND.
OUTPOURING OF SUPPORT FOR THE
EXHIBIT.
IMPORT INTO THE WEBSITE AND
BACK TO THE CREATIVE TEAM
SELVES.
ONE ONE PARTICIPANTWHO WAS NOT
PART OF THE PROJECT COME TO THAT
AFTER VIEWING THE SITE.
WORDS CANNOT DESCRIBE THIS IS
HIS QUOTE WORDS CAN'T DESCRIBE
THE FEELING OF NORMALCY IN MY
HEART HAS. RIGHT NOW.
AFTER DESCRIBING HIS OWN TATTOO
AND SERVICE HE ADDED. THANK OU
FOR MAKING ME FEEL NORMAL AGAIN.
SO.
THAT'S WHAT THE MAN IS CAN DO.
.
I WANT ID CAN NOT TIME TO GO
THROUGH ALL THE EXHIBIT BUT JUST
SOME OF THE.
DIVERSITY OF PARTICIPANTS AND
DIFFERENT PEOPLE THAT WERE
INVOLVED JUST WANT TO SHOW YOU A
COUPLE OF THEM
.
I REALLY LOVE THIS LAST PHOTO.
THAT'S MY CARGO HE FOUGHT IN
THE BATTLE OF PHANTOM FURY WHICH
IS ONE OF THE.
MOST.
UGH CASUALLY CASUALTY WRITTEN
BATTLES IN IRAQ.
WHICH HAPPEN IN THE. MONTH OF
NOVEMBER AND THAT'S HIS BABY
DAUGHTER WHO WAS BORN IN
NOVEMBER SO HE'S HAD A COMPLETE
CHANGE OF HEART ABOUT WHAT
NOVEMBER MEANS TO HIM.
.
SO I SPENT FOUR YEARS ON THIS
PROJECT WORKING WITH THESE WITH
THESE VETERANS.
WHICH WILL WE ENDED UP BECOMING
MORE THAN OUR ORIGINAL GOAL FOR
AN ONLINE EXHIBIT.
AND THEY REALLY BECAME A
COMMUNITY FOR THESE VETERANS AND
CIVILIANS TO.
BUILD FRIENDSHIPS AND
RELATIONSHIPS THAT LAST TO THIS
DAY.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE
INITIAL GRANT WE GOT FROM CAL
HUMANITY IS. REALLY.
ALLOWED US TO PORN RESOURCES
FROM ALL THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WHAT STARTED AS A TEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR GRANT?
DUE TO DUE TO STATE LIBRARY
FUNDING AND IN KIND SUPPORT
TURNED INTO A HALF A MILLION
DOLLAR PROJECT.
AND I THINK HUMANITY IS A TRACT
RESOURCES AND PEOPLE THAT WANT
TO HELP BECAUSE THEY'RE ABOUT
STORIES THAT.
IN CAPSULE A WHAT WHAT OUR LIVES
MEAN.
AND SO ON BEHALF OF THE PROJECT
TEAM IN THE PARTICIPATING
VETERANS. AND OTHER GRAND
PROVIDERS I JUST WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR DEEPEST THANKSFOR. THIS
COMMITTEE LOOKING AT THE MEANING
OF HUMANITY'S PROGRAMMING AND.
PUTTING A SPOTLIGHT ON THANK
YOU.
YOU THANK YOU WHAT CHRIS BROWN
MAY. HAVE THE SAME I MAY HAVE
THE GLASSES BUT HE'S NOT YOUR
TYPICAL LIBRARIAN.
LARGE I SHOULD MENTION THAT.
THIS SPEAKS VOLUMES BUT CHRIS
WAS.
.
GIVEN THE.
A LIBRARY JOURNAL MOVER AND
SHAKER AWARD IN HONOR INTENDED
TO RECOGNIZE INDIVIDUALS
REPRESENT THE OUTSIZE IMPACT
THAT LIBRARIANS CAN HAVE AND AND
THIS CERTAINLY.
SPEAK TO THAT SO THANK YOU THIS
IS FANTASTIC SO I'VE GOT A
COUPLE QUICK QUESTIONS THAT.
DANTE FOR YOU FIRST OF ALL DID
DID YOU GUYS ACTUALLY.
PERFORM.
ROMEO AND JULIET.
IN THE ORIGINAL SHAKESPEAREAN
ENGLISH OR OR OR WHETHER IT WAS
WE WAS LIKE A VERSION OF IT THAT
I MEAN WHAT CAN YOU CAN GIVE US
A LITTLE BIT MORE A BREAKDOWN OF
WHAT. THE PERFORMANCE WAS SORT
OF PERFORMANCE WAS. IN THE
SUMMER OF TWO THOUSAND TWELVE I
HAD READ THE PLAY I BROKE DOWN
TO THE THEMES OF THE PLAY AND
THEN I RE WROTE IT BASED OFF OF
HOW THIS PLAY OUT IN RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA. OF SOILS LIKE THE
FIRST SCENE MONSIGNOR KAVLI FIND
AT THE SUPERMARKET OURS WAS AT
THE RICHMOND. HOSPITAL KAISER
DURING THE TIME THAT A CHEVRON
CAUGHT ON FIRE KNOWING THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE BE ATTRACTED TO
THAT HOSPITAL IN NORFOLK
SCHEDULE RUN INTO EACH OTHER SO
WE USE THAT. AS A WAY TO GROUND
ERASE FROM CALIFORNIA WITH THE
HEALTH CRISIS THAT WE WERE
FACING BUT HOW MOST PEOPLE
WASN'T FOCUSING ON. THE CHEVRON
ON FIRE IT WAS FOCUSING ON
SHOOTING THEIR ENEMY AT THE
HOSPITAL SO I WROTE A PLAY BASED
OFF OF WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN
ROMEO JULIET HOW CAN WE MEASURE
THIS. IN OUR CITY SO WE RE WROTE
THE DIALOGUE AND THE YOUNG
PEOPLE WROTE THEIR OWN
MONOLOGUES IS SPOKEN WORD
FORMAT.
AND IN THE PLAY WAS CALL ROOM IS
BLEEDING NOSE CAUGHT TASTES
HARMONY. IS HARMING YOUR TAKE
RED BEAM ME BEING A ROMEO AND
HARMONY BEING A JULIA AND IT WAS
PRETTY MUCH A JOURNEY OF ROMEO
LOOKING FOR LOVE. AND MINDLESS
TAKES CHARGE OF HARMONY IN
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA AND HARMONY
PLAY.
AS A WOMAN CHARACTER BUT
HARMONY WITH IN RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA AND BASICALLY TRACKS
THAT THE PLOT OF ROAMING JULIET
ALL THE WAY THROUGH FOR THE MOST
PART IN ROMEO AND JULIET THEY
DON'T REALLY TALK ABOUT WHY THE
MIGHT TO YOUR CATHOLICS ARE
FEUDING. IN A RACE WITH A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHY OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD A FEW THERE SO WE
DID A BACKSTORY WHAT ARE PRO LAW
IT TALKED ABOUT OUR PARENTS
BEING FRIENDS. AND THEN AT SOME
POINT THEY SEPARATED BUT THAT
MISCOMMUNICATION LED TO A DIVIDE
BETWEEN THE CITIES AND AT THE
END OF THE PLAY. OUR PARENTS
CONFRONT EACH OTHER AND BEING ME
IN HARMONY STEP UP AND SAY YABE
IS LEFT TODAY WE ARE MOVING
FORWARD WITH OR WITHOUT YOU. AND
I WAS LIKE A CALL TO ACTION TO
THE COMMUNITY SO THERE'S A HAPPY
ENDING. IT WAS A BEAUTIFUL IN
IRAQ OKAY ALL RIGHT AND THEN.
.
DID YOU DID YOU END UP GETTING A
LOT OF FOLKS FROM.
FROM NORTH AND CENTRAL.
I'D SHOW UP TO SEE THE PLAY AND
I WAS WITH ERNIE. WE INTERACTION
WITH THEM ON THE STUFF. OF A LOT
OF MY FAMILY MEMBERS FROM THEIR
FACES A LOT OF THEM CAME IN A
LOT OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE I WORK
WITH WAS FROM CENTRAL SOUTH
RICHMOND SO THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
CAME. SO.
THE FEW INTERACTIONS THAT I HAD
WAS IN DURING THAT NIGHT BECAUSE
AT NIGHT WAS CRAZY WITH RUNNING
AROUND. PICTURES AND ALL THAT
BUT WHEN A DOCUMENTARY CAME OUT
AND IT WAS PREMIERED IN. ELSE
READ ALL THE SAME SCHOOL THAT WE
STAYED TO PLAY A LOT OF PEOPLE
FROM NORTH AND CENTRAL SOUTHSIDE
WAS THERE AND THEY CAME TO ME AT
ONE TIME. AND WAS TALKING TO ME
IT WAS TALKING ABOUT HOW THE
WHOLE CITY NEED TO SEE THIS FILM
AND IT WAS SOMEBODY WHO I MET
FROM US INTERESTS ME WAS TALKING
TO ME WHILE MY COUSINS FROM NOR
FRICTION WAS SAYING. I NEVER
THOUGHT THAT I'LL BE COOL OR
LOOK UP TO SOMEBODY FROM THE
OUTSIDE I WAS TRYING TO SHOOT
CHAILLOT SITE BUT I GOT SO MUCH
LOVE AND RESPECT FOR YOU. SAW
THIS SOMEBODY FROM CENTRAL
SAYING THAT TO ME IN FRONT OF MY
COUSINS FROM NORTH AND PEOPLE
FROM SOUTH SIDE STANDING THERE
WITNESSING SALE I BELIEVE AND I
AGREE SO THAT WAS A BEAUTIFUL
MOMENT AND IT WAS THE FILM CAME
OUT ON NETFLIX I BEGIN A LOT OF
SOCIAL. MEDIA LOVING FEEDBACK
ABOUT HOW THIS IS NEEDED THEY
APPRECIATE IT AND A LOT OF
SCREENS IN. CLASSROOM VISITS AND
IT'S BEEN BEAUTIFUL EXPERIENCE
AND THE FILMS ARE THE MAKING OF
THE PLAY YET OF THE FILM JUST
FOLLOW US RIGHT INTO PLAY. A
MORE THAN JUST A PLACE TO TALK
ABOUT THE HISTORY OF RACE IN
CALIFORNIA.
CAN YOU GUYS ALL TELL US WHAT
YOUR NEXT PROJECTS ARE GONNA BE.
WITH WITH NEXT ON THE PLATE.
THERE IS THE.
THERE IS A CONSENSUS CHINATOWN
THERE IS A.
SCIVATION PROJECT THAT IS BASED
ON THIS SO THIS IS A STANDALONE
FILM AND THE NEXT IS GOING TO BE
EPISODIC IT'S.
.
SEASONS EVERY SERIES HAS EIGHT
EPISODES AND EVERY EFFORT PAID
EPISODES IS OPPOSE FOCUS ON AN
INDIVIDUAL IN CHINATOWN.
SO THAT'S ONE.
I ALSO SERVED LIFE STORIES AND
YEAH AND FOR INSTANCE. WANT ONE
STORIES PENNY WONG SHE'S NINETY
THREE YEARS OLD SHE WAS MISS
SENSES GO CHINATOWN NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN A CALL.
DURING THAT TIME WORD SHE WAS
IT WAS RISQUE TO BE IN A BATHING
SUIT FOR HER SHE WAS LIKE I'LL
I'LL DO IT BECAUSE I'M GOING TO
CHALLENGE THIS STATUS QUO. AND
SO ERA HEARD SWIMSUIT GOES INTO.
AND AND AND.
THE MUSEUM WITH NEXT TO ETHEL
MERMAN MERMAN IS THAT THE. ONE
OF THE ANYHOW. SO BUT HER STORY
DOESN'T TAKE. DOESN'T GO AND
THERE HER WHEN WE WERE
INTERVIEWING HEARD SHE.
SAID THAT SHE HER MOM DIED WHEN
SHE WAS YOUNG WHAT ROUND FIVE
HER DAD CAN TAKE CARE OF HER AND
HER TWIN SISTERS AND UP THREE
BLOCKS AWAY FROM WHERE SHE
LIVED.
THERE WAS AN.
THE ASIAN WOMEN'S SHELTER AND SO
HE TOOK HER THERE WITH HER
SISTER AND SO WE MADE A PHONE
CALL TO THE ASIAN WOMEN'S
SHELTER THAT STILL OPERATING
IT'S A HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS.
THIS YEAR AND THEY SAID WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING FOR HER MONEY AND.
WE SAID WELL SHE'S FOUR BLOCKS
AWAY. AND THEY SAID COULD YOU
PUT US IN CONTACT AND I SAID
ABSOLUTELY AND.
LET ME ASK HER AND SHE SAID YES
AND I SAID COULD WE FILM THIS
AND THEY SAID ABSOLUTELY YOU CAN
FILM THIS. SO I'M CAMERA WE
CAUGHT HER CAUGHT HER REUNION
WITH THE STAFF THEY HAD IT'S
SAFE THERE IN THE SAFE WERE HER
A BOX OF RECORDS AND IN THAT BOX
OF RECORDS. WAS THAT BIG FOLDER
AND IT WAS HER FOLDER AT ALL HER
RECORDS IN THERE IN THAT FOLDER
WERE LETTERS THAT HER COUSINS
HAD WRITTEN HER. THAT WERE NEVER
DELIVERED TO HER BECAUSE SHE HAD
MOVED AWAY AND SO EIGHTY YEARS
LATER SHE'S READING THESE
LETTERS. FROM OUR COUSINS AND
INSIDE THE FOLDER THERE WAS A
LETTER THAT HER DAD HAD HAND
WRITTEN TO THE STAFF MEMBERS
WHILE DROPPING THEM OFF AT THIS
ASIAN WOMEN'S SHELTER AND SHE'S
READING THIS LETTER FROM HER
DAD.
BY SAYING THAT PLEASE TAKE CARE
OF THESE GIRLS THESE ARE TWO
WONDERFUL.
WONDERFUL OF TWIN GIRLS I CAN'T
TAKE CARE OF THEM THEIR MOM HAD
RECENTLY DIED HERE'S FIVE
DOLLARS EVERY MONTH THAT I CAN
BRING AND FOR YOU. AND SO SHE
NEVER HAD THAT CLOSURES NEVER
HAD THAT CONNECTION WITH THEIR
DAD SO THAT'S ONE OF THE STORES.
YEAH ABOVE AVERAGE YOU CHRIS
BECAUSE NOTHING. I. WON'T RIGHT
NOW I'M I'M I'M WORKING WITH THE
COMMUNITY THAT HAS. A BIT OF A
GANG ISSUE THERE. DOWN IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY SO IT'S IN ON YOUR
WAY. ACTUALLY HAS ONE THE
LARGEST.
CONCENTRATION IDENTIFIED GANG
MEMBERS IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
SORT LOOKING AT DOING SOME
PROGRAMMING WITH THOSE YOU.
I KNOW.
TAGGING AND GRAFFITI IS A BIG.
PERCEIVED PROBLEM THERE. I
REALLY LOVE THE IDEA OF DOING
SOME SORT OF HUMANITIES PROJECT
WHERE. WE GET A CHANCE TO. LOOK
AT THAT THING THAT'S PERCEIVED
AS A BLIGHT OR PROBLEM AND. FIND
OUT WHAT IS A MEAN WHAT IS A.
WHAT IS THAT GRAFFITI MEAN TO
THE PEOPLE DOING IT HIM AND WHAT
ARE THEY TRYING TO SAY EITHER
THE FOR THEMSELVES OR? TO OTHERS
AND WHAT WE NOT UNDERSTAND ABOUT
IT. ART WAS SORT OF HER BY THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE HAVING HEARING I
THINK NEXT WEEK THIS COMMITTEE
ON.
ON TUESDAY RELATING TO VETERANS
IN ARTS AND HEALING PROP
PROPERTIES AND PRINCIPLES. AND
IT WAS SORT OF.
I HAVE YOU SEEN. SOME
INTERESTING PARALLELS IN TERMS
OF PTSD AT CENTER BETWEEN.
GANG MEMBERS IN GO AWRY AND THE
VETERANS COME BACK FROM IRAQ
INTO THE SOME INTERESTING
PARALLELS A. LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD
THINK OF THEM IN VERY DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES BUT I CAN ONLY SPEAK
AS A AS A I THINK AN AUDIENCE
MEMBER I'VE I'VE DEFINITELY.
I'VE HEARD A COUPLE NPR PIECES
ABOUT.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE GROWN UP IN IN
GANG AREAS THAT. THEY EXHIBIT
THE SAME SYMPTOMS OF PTSD TO WAR
WHICH IS HEARTBREAKING.
YEAH I'M.
MMHM.
THAT'S A WITH YOUR NEXT PROJECT.
.
I'M A PART OF SO MANY OTHER
PEOPLE'S PROJECTS SO I DON'T
WANT TO NAME THOSE BUT MIND I'VE
BEEN WORKING ON A COLLECTION OF
POEMS THAT WOULD DOCUMENT A
STORY. AM OF GROWING UP IN
RICHMOND AND WITH THOSE POEMS I
PLAN TO WRITE A SMALL PLACE SO
EACH POEM AND INTO A VISUAL TO
EACH POLE. EACH VIDEO ON TELLING
THE SAME STORY BUT FROM A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE OF THE
WHOLE. HOWEVER YOU HAVE TO KEEP.
ON THINKING ABOUT SO MANY
DIFFERENT A SHAKESPEARE PLAY
LAND YOU CAN RIP OFF OF. HAMLET
AND. YOU KNOW. I WAS SUGGESTED
TO DO ALL FELLOW YEAH. THAT'S
NOT A BAD IDEA BUT I DON'T
REALLY KNOW MUCH ABOUT THEIR
LOVE BUT FROM WHAT PEOPLE TELL
ME SO.
WELL. THERE'S A GREAT FILM. THAT
WAS MADE OF IT NOT TOO LONG AGO.
HAVE YOU KNOW HAS HAS YOUR WORK
BEEN ON FETID OR EXAMINE BY ANY
OF THE SHAKESPEARE FESTIVALS OR.
.
THERE'S A THERE'S A NUMBER THAT
IS IF I SEE THAT THE CLUB DOWN
IN SAN DIEGO THERE'S NUMBER SIX
VESSELS IN LA THIS TO ACTUALLY
FESTIVAL IN IT.
IS THERE BEEN ANY.
INTERACTION BETWEEN A THOSE
FESTIVALS AND.
AND YOUR WORK NOT NECESSARILY
THE FESTIVALS BUT I KNOW A LOT
OF FOLKS WHO. PARTICIPATE IN
ARRANGED A COW SHAKES.
SOME ACTORS THERE WAS LIGHT WE
SHOULD PROBABLY DO THIS OR.
STAGES HERE BUT YOU KNOW WHAT I
WAS TAUGHT THE AND SO I HAVEN'T
REALLY PURSUED IT AND SOMEONE TO
THINK ABOUT I I YOU KNOW I I.
WELL LET'S LET'S GET SOME VISIT
PEOPLE IN THE ROOM IN MY FIELD
AFTER THAT SO. I WILL GREAT
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY GUYS FANTASTIC
WORK AND AND REALLY DOES SPEAK
TO THE THE POWER OF THIS. THIS
THIS.
OF HUMANITY SO. IS THAT A YES
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT SO WE'RE NOT GOING TO
HEAR. THE SECOND PART OF PANEL
TWO OF OUR WONDERFUL STORY
TELLERS I WE'VE GOT DOCTOR BE
DONE CHANDRA ROY HE WAS
ASSOCIATE CHAIR OF ENGLISH AT.
AND ALSO THE FACT THE DIRECTOR
THE PRISON PROGRAM AT CAL STATE
LA. AND.
AND.
DOCTOR ROY WILL WILL SPEAK A BIT
ABOUT.
WORDS AND CAGED AND WE'VE ALSO
GOT MARIAN POWELL WHO'S HERE I
SHE'S AN AUTHOR AND A FORMER
JOURNALIST WITH LA TIMES IN
NEWSDAY AND ACTUALLY TALKING
ABOUT. DEMOCRACY IN THE FIELDS.
SO WE'RE REAL EXCITED TO HAVE.
THE TWO HERE.
SO WE'LL START WITH YOU DOCTOR
RIGHT.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING US AND IT'S
BEEN. VERY INSPIRING AND
ENJOYABLE TO LISTEN TO THOSE.
RESPONSE FAMILIES BEFORE US.
I AM SO AS YOU MENTION ON THAT
ENGLISH PROFESSOR AT CAL STATE
LA BUT MOST OF THE WORK I DO NOW
IS IN.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY PRISON AT
LANCASTER WE HAVE A BE A PROGRAM
THAT RIGHT NOW THE ONLY BE I
PROGRAMMED. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT STOOL IN A
PRISON. AND WE HAVE A
HUMANITIES.
PROGRAM AND ALL ITS PROGRAM
CALLED WOOD DUNG CAGED WHICH ARE
ALL ALONG WITH THE MEN OF THE
ORDER THAT THE FOUNDERS OF AND
WE GOT OUR INITIAL FUNDING FROM
CAROL HUMANITIES THAT GOT THE
WHOLE THING OFF THE GROUND.
AND WHAT WE DO IN THE PROGRAM
WAS ON CAGED IS. IT REAL WAS
REALLY BORN FROM THE IDEA THAT.
ONCE YOU SPEND SOME TIME IN
PRISON ON.
BEEN TEACHING IN THERE FOR ABOUT
FIVE OR SIX YEARS NOW. YOU
REALIZE THAT THERE ARE SO MANY
ON TOLD STORIES AND POWERFUL
VOICES IN IN PRISON AND SO
WHAT'S UNCAGED AS A PLATFORM FOR
THOSE. VOICES TO BE HEARD BY THE
PUBLIC AND TO INTERACT WITH THE
WITH THE PUBLIC.
AND IT'S FOUNDED UPON THE
BELIEF THAT STORIES HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HEAL INDIVIDUAL LIVES
AND IMAGINE NEW COLLECTIVE
FUTURE. SO WE TRIED TO HAVE
STORYTELLING EXPERIENCES THE ALL
BASED IN THE PRISON BUT ALSO
BASED IN THE COMMUNITIES FROM
THE MAN FROM WHERE THE MEN. CAME
TO PRESENT AND THE IDEA HERE IS
THAT WE CAN.
DO SOME KIND OF COLLECTIVE
HEALING TOGETHER AND AND AND
HELP KIDS IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT MAY BE ON THE PART OF THE
ENDED UP IN PRISON. OR INVOLVED
IN GANGS IN SOUTH LA IN THAT
KIND OF STUFF TO IMAGINE
ALTERNATIVES TO THAT AND SO THE
STORYTELLING PROCESS BECOMES. A
WAY OF DOING IT MUCH LIKE IT WAS
HERE IN. THE ANTI TALK ABOUT
EARLY ON.
SO IN THAT SENSE AND I'M I'M
KINDA TALKING ABOUT LITERATURE
IN ITS MOST EXPENSIVE SENTENCE
SAYS THAT AS A. AS A AS A WAVE
INCLUDING PEOPLE AND COMMUNITIES
SPELLING TELLING STORIES OF
PUBLIC HUMANITIES PROJECT RATHER
THAN GOING INTO PLACES AND.
NECESSARY TO JIM CANONICAL WORKS
OF THAT KIND OF THING.
AND BECAUSE THE GOAL OF OUR WORK
WITH WHAT'S ON CAGED IS TO
COLLAPSE THE DISTANCE BETWEEN
THE PRISON AND THE OUTSIDE
WORLD.
AND TO STRESS WHAT WE HAVE IN
COMMON AS HUMAN BEINGS OUR OUR
APPROACHES IS COLLABORATIVE AND
DIALOGICAL AS AS POSSIBLE. SO
FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE.
MY STUDENTS AT CAL STATE LA.
ONE OF WHOM IS HERE ACTUALLY TO
TO BE POP THE HEARING.
EDIT AND GIVE FEEDBACK AND
ENGAGE WITH THE PRISON RIGHTS IN
WHO. OFTEN YOU KNOW MANY OF
THESE MEN GO TO PRISON THE DEAN
DOWN TWENTY THIRTY FORTY YEARS
AND HAVE NEVER HAD ANYONE WRITE
TO THEM THEY'VE BECOME
DISENGAGED FROM THEIR FAMILY SO
THIS IS A WAY OF INTERACTING
ABOUT SOMETHING MEANINGFUL IN.
THE HUMANITIES IS THAT BRIDGE
THAT ENABLES THESE VERY
DISPARATE LIVES TO BE CONNECTED
THROUGH THESE DIALOGUES.
WE'VE HAD ACTORS PERFORM
DRAMATIC READINGS OF WRITINGS.
IN PUBLIC SETTINGS WE'VE HAD.
WOMAN PHOTOGRAPHERS THERE OR ON
THE WEBSITE COME IN AND TAKE
PULL TRAITS OF THE MEN AND WE
HAVE A.
EVENT COMING UP AN EXHIBIT
COMING UP IN JUNE AT CAL STATE
LA. WE HAVE A LETTER WRITING
PROGRAM.
THAT'S THE GOVERNOR I GET A
COPY OF A BOOK THEIR LINE NO
YEAH. YEAH.
IN CASE YOU DIDN'T KNOW WHO YOUR
BOSS WAS.
.
AND AND THE WHOLE IDEA OF THIS
IS A SIZE TO USE THE HUMANITIES
THESE ARE SOME OF THE PORTRAITS
THAT GOING TO BE EXHIBITED.
OUR UPCOMING EVENT THE WHOLE
IDEA OF THE SEAS TO.
.
HUMANOIDS TO GIVE A VOICE TO
PRISONERS WHO REALLY ARE KIND OF
MARGINALIZED FROM ALSO SOUGHT TO
IN SO MANY WAYS PHYSICALLY
PRISONS ARE VERY ISOLATED
LOCATIONS IN THE HIGH DESERT AND
PLACES LIKE THAT. AND. OBVIOUSLY
THE NATURE OF A PRISON IS IS ONE
OF NOT ALLOWING COMMUNICATION
AND SO FOR MANY OF THE MEN IN
THESE PHOTOS THAT YOU SEE HERE
THIS IS THE FIRST MEANINGFUL WAY
THEY'VE BEEN I WOULD SAY
INTERACT WITH THE OUTSIDE WORLD.
FOR YEARS.
I'M.
AND I JUST KIND OF ENUMERATE
WHAT WE FOUND THE HUMANITIES IN
PARTICULAR TO BE VALUABLE FOR IN
IN IN THIS DIALOGUE. I THINK THE
FIRST ONE IS.
HUMANITIES ALLOW US TO SEE WHY
THE STATIC BY MENTION OF VOICE
MASSES NOT JUST WHAT YOU SAY BUT
HOW YOU SAY IT.
THE THERE'S DIGNITY THAT COMES
FROM CLAIM IN ONE'S INDIVIDUAL
VOICE WHEN YOU HAVEN'T BEEN
ALLOWED TO SPEAK THAT IT IT'S
IT'S AFFIRMATIVE AND. GIVES A
SENSE OF DIGNITY.
THE EMPATHY COMES FROM LISTENING
IN OR READING OTHER PEOPLE'S
STORIES.
WITH CASH.
AND THE POSITIVE SOCIAL CHANGE
CAN BEGIN WITH THE STORY
STORYTELLING PROCESS EVERYTHING
WE SEE IN THIS ROOM EVERYTHING
WITH POLITICS AT SOME POINT IS
AN IMAGINED POSSIBILITY. SO THE
HUMANITIES.
GIVE US THAT FRAMEWORK TO
IMAGINE ALL THE POSSIBILITIES
THAN BEING A GANG MEMBER WILL GO
TO PRISON LIKE YOUR YOUR FAMILY
MAY HAVE THOUGHT.
I'M AM WITHOUT THE HUMANITIES I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE TO THINK
THROUGH A LOT THE DECISIONS WE
HAVE TO MAKE IN WORDS ON
OCCASIONAL THE PRODUCTION. SO TO
GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF THIS.
.
BEAUTY AND DIGNITY A KIND OF
IMPORTANT WORDS TO OUR PROJECT
AND AND THIS GOES ALL THE WY
DOWN TO THE KIND OF MICRO
DECISIONS WE MAKE IN ALL
PROJECTS SO IN THE BOOK. WE
ENDED UP SPENDING MORE OF THE
CAST HUMANITIES GRANT THEN WE
THOUGHT WE WOULD ON ON PRINTING
BECAUSE WE WANTED TO USE REALLY
HIGH QUALITY PIPE. ONCE I TOOK
THE PAPER SAMPLES INTO THE
PRISON WHERE WE WOULD PRODUCE IN
THE BOOK.
.
YOU KNOW. MANY OF THE LAW FOR
THAT PROGRAM AS IT NEVER TOUCHED
A PIECE OF PAPER LIKE THAT
BEFORE. AND SO LIKE FOR ALLAH IS
THEY JUST YOU KNOW TOUCHING THE
PAPER AND IT AND IT SIGNALLED
SOMETHING TO THEM THAT THIS
STORY IS THE WORST THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE PRINTED ON THIS. ARE
OF WORTH AND AND SO THAT WAS
KIND OF HUMAN VALUE THAT CAME
FROM THAT DECISION SO THERE WERE
NUMEROUS KIND OF THE. DECISIONS
WE MAKE THROUGH THE PROJECT.
SUCH AS THAT.
ENDS UP JUST THE KIND OF.
WE SAW BROUGHT THEIR FACES INTO
THE ROOM BUT I ALWAYS FEEL AT A
LATE TO.
UNEASY SPEAK IN BEHALF OF THE
PROJECT BECAUSE IT'S A
COLLECTIVE AND THE MEN IN PRISON
REALLY CO CREATED WITH ME AS
MUCH AS AS MUCH AS ME OBVIOUSLY.
THEY CAN'T PHYSICALLY BE HERE TO
SPEAK SO I WANTED TO READ A FEW
OF THE WORDS OF THE IMPACT. THAT
THE PROGRAM HAS HAD ON THEM.
AND.
I AUSTIN TO WRITE SOMETHING
ABOUT WHAT THE HUMANITIES. MEANT
TO THEM IN IN IN.
IN RESPONSE TO THIS HEARING. SO
THIS IS FROM ANDREW KICKING
HORSE WHO'S ONE OF OUR. NATIVE
AMERICAN PRISON IS AT LANCASTER.
I WOULD LIKE TO OFFER MY INSIGHT
AS TO WHY THE HUMANITIES MATTER.
TWO OF THEM PRISON IS A SIMPLY
DISREGARDED IN WAREHOUSE WITHOUT
REFLECTION. WHEN GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD AND TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN OUR LIVES
AND THE LIVES OF OTHERS. THESE
OPPORTUNITIES FEED THE SPIRIT IN
A WAY THAT NO WORDS CAN
DESCRIBE.
THEM REALIZE THAT THEY ARE
SOMEONE AND NOT JUST THE
CONVICTED FELON.
NO LONGER DEFINED BY MISTAKES WE
CAN REGAIN AND AND DIGNIFY
THOUGHT FOREVER LOST BECAUSE OF
OUR CONVICTIONS. THE HUMANITIES
REBIRTH THE SPIRIT AND ENABLE
ONE TO GROW SPIRITUALLY
INTELLECTUALLY AND MORE
HUMANELY.
ANDREW KICKING HORSE TRUCK TOLL.
LIFE WITHOUT PRISON THAT LIFE
WITHOUT PAROLE PRISON THE
LANCASTER.
.
JUST READ A COUPLE MORE TESTS
OKAY.
THIS IS FROM A FAMILY MEMBER
HAS SOME AND SHE'S FROM
STOCKTON.
AND.
HER SON IS INCARCERATED WITH
LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE IN A
PROGRAM.
SO SHE DROVE DOWN TO LA FOR THE
FOR THE EXHIBIT.
MY HUSBAND AND I DRIVE DOWN TO
LA ON SATURDAY TO SEE YOUR
EXHIBIT. I WAS SO I WANTED TO BE
THERE FOR THE GRAND OPENING BUT
I HAD TO WORK ON SUNDAY MORNING
AND I LIVE IN STOCKTON SO I
COULDN'T STUDY. HOWEVER I HAD TO
SEE IT.
IN A WAY I WAS GLAD TO BE ALONE.
EXHIBIT WAS EXTREMELY EMOTIONAL
FOR ME. MY SON'S POST CODES WERE
ON THE WALL AND I KNOW MANY OF
THE MEN YOU REPRESENTED.
THE ROOM'S ATMOSPHERE BEGAN TO
CHANGE WHEN I ENTERED TO A
CONFLICT IN AN OVERWHELMING
FEELING OF MELANCHOLY PASSION
DESPAIR HIDING REMORSE SADNESS
AND SORROW. AND MOST OF ALL
HOPE.
THE PHOTOGRAPH OF THE MEN WAS
MET MAJESTIC HONEST THEM RULE
BEAUTIFUL. THE ARTWORK FROM THE
MAN WAS LIKEWISE BEAUTIFUL. YOU
CAN LITERALLY SEE THE PAIN IN
EVERY STROKE OF PIE.
BETWEEN THE SLAVES OF THE
EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS AND TODAY
SLAVES MAKING FIVE CENTS AN HOUR
WORKING FOR FREE IS SURREAL AND
SCREAMS FOR HELP. ACCOUNT SEND
OFF DOCTOR ROY THANK YOU FOR
DOING THIS FOR PRESENTED OUR
LOVE ONES AS FELLOW HUMAN
BEINGS.
AND JUST ONE LOSS ONE FROM JOHN
MANNING WHO IS IT.
FEATURED IN A KNOT AND ALL
BOOKING OFFICE BOOK.
BEEN PUBLISHED IN THIS EXHIBIT
IS A HIGHLIGHT OF THE YEAR FOR
ME. I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD HAVE
ANYTHING TO SAY THAT WOULD BE
WORTHY OF PRINTED.
BUT IT IS NICE THAT THIS IS
HAPPENED.
MY HOPE IS THAT THE PUBLIC WILL
HEAR THE WORDS IS INTENDED THAT
WE ARE HUMAN. WE'VE MADE BAD
DECISIONS AND HOPE FOR A CHANCE
TO RETURN TO THE PUBLIC SOME
TIGHT.
I AM OPTIMISTIC THAT THE PUBLIC
WHO READS AND SEES THE CHANGES.
IN ONE'S WHO'VE PARTICIPATED IN
WORDS ON THE PAGE WILL REALIZE
THAT WE HAVE DEFINITELY CHANGED.
WE ARE WORTHY OF A SECOND LOOK
AS MANY OF US HAVE SPENT TWENTY
YEARS OR MORE CONSTANTLY SEEKING
SELF REHABILITATION. NOT BECAUSE
OF OUR SURROUNDINGS INSPIRED TO
THEM.
LIFE WITHOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
PAROLE CAUSES PEOPLE TO BECOME
EXTREMELY HOPELESS AND
DESPONDENCY BECOMES A NORMAL
LIVING CONDITIONS. HOWEVER MANY
OF US CONSTANTLY RISES ABOVE THE
MARK SEEKING SELF IMPROVEMENT
AND UPON OURSELVES TO EXHIBITS
LIKE THIS ONE ONLY SERVES TO
KEEP HOPE ALIVE.
I'M SO GRATEFUL TO THE PEOPLE
WHO WORK SO HARD TO ALLOW SO
VOICE IMPRINTS AND ALL.
WITHOUT THESE PEOPLE WE'VE MET
NEVER BEEN HURT YOU WOULD NEVER
KNOW THOUGH I'M RECOVERING MY
HUMANITY. DAY BY DAY.
THANK YOU FOR READING GERMANY.
THANK YOU DOCTOR.
THIS PROBLEM.
SO I'M A I'M A CLASSICS MAJOR
AND I ACTUALLY WAS A TOOK A
CLASS WITH MARTHA NUSSBAUM SO MY
HUMANITIES ROOTS GO GO BACK TO
TO YOUR START. ON AND I'M A
DISCIPLE OF BILL DEVERELL FROM
WHOM I HAVE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT
THE ART OF BEING A HISTORIAN.
SO.
AND AND THE PROJECT THAT I'M
GONNA TALK ABOUT I THINK IS MORE
HISTORY BASED AND THEN SOME. HOW
DO I DO THIS OKAY?
ARE WE THERE.
I SPENT. THE BETTER PART OF A
DECADE RESEARCHING WRITING ABOUT
CAESAR COVERS IN THE UNITED
FARMWORKERS INTO THE BIOGRAPHY
OF CESAR CHAVEZ AND WAS
CONTACTED BY A PHOTOGRAPHER.
WAIT CAN WE GO BACK. IT DOESN'T
MATTER.
BUT YET JUST ABOUT PERFECT.
COVETED BY PHOTOGRAPHER WHO
WEIGHS HAS RETIRED AND WAS GOING
THROUGH. BOXES OF NEGATIVES THAT
SHE HAD SHOT IN THE SUMMER OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE WHEN SHE
WAS A STUDENT AT SAN FRANCISCO
ART INSTITUTE.
AND CALLED ME AND SAID YOU
MIGHT WANT TO LOOK AT THESE
PHOTOS.
AND DESPITE HAVING SEEN MANY
MANY PHOTOS OF THAT ERROR IN
THAT PERIOD I NEVER SEEN
PICTURES LIKE THE ONES THAT
MAYBE PALM TUCK BECAUSE. SHE WAS
INTERESTED ALTHOUGH THIS PICTURE
IS OBVIOUSLY OF OF CHAVEZ.
SHE WAS REALLY INTERESTED IN
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE PART OF THE
MOVEMENT. AND I'M GOING TO JUST
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN THE SUMMER OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE WHICH LED
TO TO TO THIS PROJECT. ON THE
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS ACT
WAS PASSED IN AND SIGNED BY
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN IN JUNE OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE ONE OF HIS
MAJOR ACCOMPLISHMENTS MAKING
CALIFORNIA THE ONLY STATE IN THE
COUNTRY. IN WHICH FARM WORKERS
HAVE THE RIGHT TO ORGANIZE AND
JOIN UNIONS FROM WORKERS ARE NOT
COVERED BY THE NATIONAL LABOR
RELATIONS ACT SO THIS UNLEASHED.
A SORT OF SUMMER OF FRENETIC
pPREPARED FOR THESE ELECTIONS
WHICH WE'RE GONNA HAPPEN SHOULD
NEVER. NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE AND
MIMI SPENT THE SUMMER IN SALINAS
FOLLOWING THE WORKERS AS THEY
GOT READY. FOR SHE'S THE
PHOTOGRAPHER YES SORRY MIMI
PALM.
.
THAT'S NOT RIGHT HARROWING.
SORRY. CAN YOU FIX IT.
RIGHT YOU DISADVANTAGE OF SO
THESE ARE JUST SOME OF THE SHOTS
THAT WE ARE ON OUR WEBSITE.
WHICH WE PUT TOGETHER AS PART
OF THIS PROJECT THAT WAS FUNDED
BY CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES BUT
CESAR CHAVEZ WALKED FROM SAN
DIEGO.
ACROSS OR UP AND DOWN THE COAST
UP UP THE COAST BASICALLY.
ENDING IN SALINAS AND THEN LATER
ON IN SACRAMENTO THROUGH THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN ORDER TO
PUBLICIZE THESE ELECTIONS THAT
WERE GOING TO TAKE PLACE. SO SHE
SHOT THOUSANDS OF PICTURES AND
WE BEGAN TO GO THROUGH THEM AND
PUT TOGETHER THE STORY OF WHAT
HAPPENED SHE DIDN'T HAVE NAMES
OF PEOPLE SHE DIDN'T KNOW WHO
THEY WERE FOR THE MOST PART.
OTHER THAN THE ONES WHO ARE
OBVIOUSLY RECOGNIZABLE LIKE
TRAVIS AND WORK AND SO ON.
WHAT SHE CAPTURED IN A WAY THAT
I THINK?
NO ONE ELSE I'VE SEEN DEED IS
WHAT THIS MEANT TO THE PEOPLE
WHO WERE LEARNING HOW TO
ORGANIZE AND AND AND BEING ABLE
TO. EXERCISE THEIR RIGHTS
STOPPED THERE FOR SUCK ON THEIR
RIGHTS TO. TO US TO PARTICIPATE
IN A DEMOCRATIC PROCESS THAT
MOST OF THEM HAD NEVER.
DONE BEFORE REMOTE MOST MANY OF
THE FARM WORKERS AND NEVER VOTED
IN THEIR LIVES IN ANY KIND OF
ELECTION MUCH LESS A UNION
ELECTION THE TEATRO CAMPESINO
LUIS VALDEZ. WAS A PART OF THIS
THEY PERFORMED AND IN SORT OF
LITTLE FARM TOWNS UP AND DOWN
THE COAST AND IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
WHEN SHE CAPTURED THIS WHOLE
RECORD. SO WE BEGAN TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT WAS THE WAY TO PUT
THIS TOGETHER IN A WAY INTO THAT
WOULD CAPTURE THIS HISTORY AND
MAKE IT MEANINGFUL TO PEOPLE
TODAY. AND BE ABLE TO SORT OF
TELL THE STORY OF PEOPLE WHO
WERE STILL AROUND MANY OF THEM.
AND BUT BUT HAD NO SENSE OF
THEIR OWN HISTORY IN SOME LEVEL
BECAUSE THEY HAD NOT CAPTURED
THIS IN IMAGES.
AHEAD SO. THE.
THERE'S A SECTION ON THE WEBSITE
THAT TALKS ABOUT HOW TO BUILD
THE UNION AND THE ACTIVITIES
THAT THEY WERE DOING WHICH WERE
LIKE THIS. BUILDING. UP ON FLAGS
HAVING RALLIES.
KEEP GOING.
MEETINGS ORGANIZING AND REALLY
GETTING A SENSE OF THEIR OWN
POWER. ON AND WHAT IT MEANT TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE SOME CONTROL
OVER THEIR OWN DESTINY.
AND-THEIR FUTURE. ON.
THIS IS A PICTURE OF THE VERY
FIRST ELECTION THAT WAS EVER
HELD IN THE FIELDS.
AND THERE WERE HUNDREDS OF
ELECTIONS IN THE FIRST JUST EVEN
IN THE FIRST WEEKS. AND THIS MAN
HERE IS ON HIS NAME IS.
A SELF ESTEEM THOUGH. ARM
REVERSE AND HE WAS ONE OF THE
ORGANIZED A FEW SHE FOLLOWED
AROUND HE WAS A LETTUCE CUTTER.
GO TO THE NEXT ONE AND THAT'S
MARGOT BUSTAMANTE ON THE RIGHT
SIDE HE'S HAVING HOUSE MEETING
THESE WERE LETTERS CUTTERS WHO.
JOINED THE UNION AND THEN FOUND
THEMSELVES HAVING A TALENT FOR
LEADERSHIP IN BEING ABLE TO
ORGANIZE. A CAN GO TO THE NEXT
ONE CURLERS. YEAH YEAH ON THIS
IS NOT AS BAD THAT SO THAT'S
THAT'S A LISTING OF TODAY IN THE
AT. AND THE OTHER GUYS MARIELS
BROTHER MARIO AND SHOVE A GO
BACK. STAY THERE FOR A SEC.
THEY HAD NO PICTURES OF THEIR
FATHER THEY HAD TO FOLLOW THEIR
FATHER INTO THE UNION THEY HAD
NO PHOTOS OF HIM AND WE WENT
AROUND AS PART OF THE PROCESS OF
THIS PROJECT AND SHOW THESE
PICTURES TO PEOPLE TO TRY TO
IDENTIFY THE FOLKS IN THE
PICTURES. AND THIS IS ACTUALLY
SORT OF THE MOMENT WHEN THEY
WERE LOOKING FOR THERE FOR TO
SEE WHETHER THEY COULD SEE THEIR
FATHER IN ANY OF THESE PHOTOS.
AND THEN THE NEXT PHOTO IS FITS
HIM IN THE HOT OVER IN THE
MIDDLE SIDE SO WE. AS IN DOING
THIS SORT OF SAID THIS IS SO
MEANINGFUL TO PEOPLE TO BE ABLE
TO CAPTURE THEIR OWN HISTORY IN
A WAY THAT THEY NEVER HAD IT
BEFORE. THAT WE NEED TO FIND A
WAY TO PRESENT THIS. AND.
BECAUSE OF GETTING THE GRAPHIC
HOW HUMANITIES WHICH ALLOWED US%
TO SET UP A WEBSITE THAT REALLY
TELL THE STORY AND BE ABLE TO
SPREAD THE WORD. SO THAT'S
RATHER SELL SAITO IN THE MIDDLE
ON SHE'S ANOTHER ORGANIZER WHO
IS THE LATEST CUTTER AND LEARN
HOW TO ORGANIZE AND WENT ON TO
HAVE ANOTHER LIFE AND WE WENT
AND TRACK THESE PEOPLE DOWN WE
FOUND ROSE. IN FAMILIES IN.
ARIZONA NEXT. FIND THIS WAR
MORE-ROWS IN THE FIELDS THAT'S
WAS IT
THEN.
AND.
ONE MORE.
THAT'S ROSA FILING PAPERS FOR
ELECTION CONFRONTING YOU KNOW
REALLY LEARNING AND THIS IS WHEN
WE FOUND ROSA WITH MARIO AND
SHOWING HER THE PHOTOS THESE
PEOPLE HAVE FAMILIES WHO DIDN'T
KNOW ANY OF THEIR HISTORY HER
CHILDREN REALLY DID KNOW ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE IT WAS REALLY SORT
OF ANCIENT HISTORY.
JOSE RENTERIA AND SO WE WERE
ABLE TO SORT OF TAKE THESE
PEOPLE RECORD ORAL HISTORIES
WITH THEM FIND IN SOME CASES
RECORDS OF. TAPES THAT THEY HAD
MADE ON THE THE GUY IN THE BACK
IS NAMED SUBPOENA LOPEZ AND THEN
WE BROUGHT THEM ALL TO SALINAS
FOR AN EVENT THAT WAS JOINTLY
SPONSORED WITH THE NATIONAL
STEINBECK CENTER. ON THAT ALLOW
THEM TO TELL THEIR STORIES FOR
THE FIRST TIME REALLY IT WAS
THERE WERE SEVERAL HUNDRED
PEOPLE THERE IS A SORT OF A
MULTI GENERATIONAL CROWD AND
THEY WERE STUDENTS THERE IT WAS
A REALLY. A WAY OF PASSING ON
THE HISTORY TO FUTURE
GENERATIONS AND IN A WAY THAT IS
BEING USED NOW IN THE SCHOOLS SO
IS IT WAS AN EFFORT TO SORT OF.
BOTH CAPTURE SOME OF THE HISTORY
AND AND TIE IT TO THE PRESIDENT.
IN A SENSE OF. THE ORAL
HISTORIES ON THE SITE PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT THE WAYS IN WHICH
THEIR LIVES WERE CHANGED BY THIS
EXPERIENCE. AND.
AND HOW WE. EAT EAT EAT ENABLED
THEM TO ALSO MOVE OUT OF THE
FIELDS IN MOST CASES AND TO
LEARN WHAT SORT OF ORGANIZING
AND POWER WAS ABOUT. SO WE SORT
OF WE WERE THREE THE THREE OF US
WHO PUT THIS TOGETHER MIMI PUMP
THE PHOTOGRAPHER ME AND THE WAY
OUR WEB DESIGNER.
WE WERE ALL INDEPENDENT.
.
ARTISTS AND AND WRITERS SO WE
SORT OF HAD NO RESOURCES TO DO
THIS WITHOUT.
WITHOUT THE KIND OF GRANT THAT
WE GOT AND IT'S NOW. A RESOURCE
THAT'S OUT THERE FOR PEOPLE TO
USE FOR FOR MANY YEARS.
I LOVE IT I LOVE IT VERY VERY
COOL. I'M.
YOU KNOW I I WISH WE COULD ALL
OVER THIS RECENT LIST A.
DOCUMENTARY BECAUSE IT'S NOT OK
OCCUR.
HOW MUCH DO YOU END UP
COORDINATING A BIT WITH THE THE
NATIONAL PARK SERVICE HAD NO
SUCH OBVIOUS NATIONAL STARK SIDE
A LITTLE BIT I MEAN I WAS
INVOLVED IN SOME OF THE IT
ACTUALLY THEY WERE WORKING ON
THAT WHEN I WAS DOING THE BOOK
AND I WENT? AROUND TO SOME OF
THE HEARINGS IN THE SITES AND SO
ON AND.
I MEAN I'M NOT A FATHER SOME
THERE ARE A COUPLE HISTORIAN TO
BE INVOLVED WITH. THE PARK
SERVICE IN TRYING IT'S A LITTLE
BIT THE PARK SERVICE IS DOING IT
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE TRAVIS
FOUNDATION HOW IT'S SET UP. SO
THEY'RE SORT OF SOME NAVIGATION
OF.
HOW THAT PROCESS IS GOING
THEY'RE STILL IN THE MIDDLE OF
IT?
HE'S BEEN MINUTES THE SITE'S
BEEN.
IN THE WORKS FOR QUITE SOME WHAT
A QUESTION TIME AND HE'S YEAH I
MEAN THEY TOOK OVER THE SITE WAS
THERE BEFORE IT WAS RUN BY THE
TIME HIS FOUNDATION AND IT'S
STILL SORT OF RUN BY THEM BUT
THE PARK SERVICE OWNS THE
PROPERTY NOW AND SO THEY'RE
SORT.
OF GRADUALLY. PUTTING UP MORE
INFORMATIONAL. MATERIAL AND SO
ON AND THEY'RE A LOT THEY DID
THE NATIONAL PARK SERVICE DID A
WHOLE SURVEY OF HISTORIC SITES
AROUND THE STATE FORTY ACRES IN
DELANO AND NATIONAL TOWN HALL
AND ALL THAT. BUT THAT'S SORT OF
DIED WITH THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION.
AHA.
OKAY.
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE YEAH I MEAN I
I KEEP YOU KNOW I I I LOOK I GOT
TO WATCH MAN'S IN OUR GROUP I
WENT THERE. WHEN IT WAS FIRST.
REQUIRED BY THE NATIONAL PARK
SERVICE AND IT WAS THERE'S VERY
LITTLE THERE. AND THEN THE LAST
TIME I WENT IT WAS SO IMPRESSED
WITH THIS. EXTRAORDINARY MUSEUM
OF A CRAVING TALKING ABOUT ALL
SORTS OF DIFFICULT ISSUES OF.
FREE SPEECH AND.
YEAH CIVIL RIGHTS AND ALL THE
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED BY THE
STORY OF.
.
OF OF.
OF THE INTERNMENT.
A SYSTEM I JUST I KEEP I KEEP
HOPING THAT THAT.
THEY'LL PULL SOMETHING SIMILAR
TOGETHER HE YEAH I MEAN I THINK
IT'S A LITTLE BIT MORE
COMPLICATED BECAUSE THE TERMS OF
THE DEAL ARE THAT THEY ARE SORT
OF HAVE TO DO IT IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE FAMILY SO THERE'S BEEN.
SOME.
PROCESS OF NEGOTIATION ON ON
THAT BECAUSE THE FAMILY IS A LOT
OF CONTROL OVER HOW THE STORIES
TOLD YEAH YEAH INTERESTING. ALL
RIGHT.
BY THE WAY YOU KNOW THE DOCTOR
ROY ADD CHRISTOPHER ISHERWOOD IS
THAT.
IMPORT I I SEE YOU'RE YOU'RE
YOU SPENT SOME TIME WORKING ON
IT YOU KNOW HE'S FROM MY
DISTRICT ADD.
AND.
.
HIS LONG TIME PARTNER DON CARTY
COURSE PAINTED THE GOVERNORS A
PORTRAIT WHICH YOU MUST GO SEE
BUYER HERE IN THE BUILDING. HE'S
HE ALSO SUBMITTED SO HE'S.
GOT A PORTRAIT OF GUS VAN SANT
OF MY OWN PRIVATE IDAHO AND
OTHER FILMS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
ON DISPLAY AS PART OF OUR
SENATE.
ART. COLLECTION.
SO DID THEIR THEIR X. DIRTY
SURRENDERING STORY THAT DON AND
AND AND CHRISTOPHER AND.
AND SO IT'S IT'S FANTASTIC WHAT
WHAT GOT YOU SO INTERESTED IN IN
PRISON ISSUES HOW DID YOU END
UP.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE THE
OTHER.
IS ANOTHER WONDERFUL BRIT WHO'S
WORKING ON THESE ISSUES THAT.
.
YOU KNOW A GOOD FRIEND WHO IS
NOW WORKING WITH A CYBER AT WHAT
WILL YEAH I KNOW. WE WORK
TOGETHER. SO SHE JUST GOT MEMBER
THE BRITISH EMPIRE YEAH QUEEN
HERSELF AND AND. WHEN I WAS JUST
AT THE CEREMONY AT THE BRITISH
CONSUL THOUSAND AND YET SHE'S ON
THIS EXTRAORDINARY WORK ON ON
HEARING ARTS AND.
FEAR INTO THE PRISONS AND.
AND SO LET ME HEAR YOUR STORY OF
HOW YOU ENDED UP IN ON THIS PATH
AM WELL I THINK.
.
SEVERN I PROBABLY WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THIS A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO I THINK BE IN BROWN
AND BRITISH HAS A LOT TO DO WITH
IT I AM YOU KNOW I'M SURE PRINCE
HARRY'S GOT DIFFERENT VIEWS
ABOUT PRISONS IN CALIFORNIA.
TO GIVE YOU A SENSE IT GIVES YOU
AN EXPERIENCE OF BEING
MARGINALIZED WHEN YOU'RE GROWING
UP IN A AND DIFFERENT
RELATIONSHIPS TO THE STRUCTURE
OF POWER IN THAT KIND OF THING.
SO I THINK THEORETICALLY MY PHD
IN POST COLONIAL STUDIES SO I'D
KIND OF UNDERSTOOD THAT PRISON
SYSTEM FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE.
I'M AND THEN BY GROWTH BY
GRAPHICALLY HOW I GOT INVOLVED
IN THIS AND. WE STARTED A DOG
PROGRAM AND THE PRESIDENT.
DOGS THAT WERE GONNA BE KILLED.
INVOLVED IN DOG RESCUING PEOPLE
RESCUED DOGS THAT WOULD GONNA BE
KILLED WE. ESSENTIALLY STARTED
AT A TRAIN IN A SHELTER IN THE
PRISON AND SO FROM NOW I START
TO TEACH IN CLASSES ABOUT THE
HEALING POWER OF HAVING THE
ANIMALS IN THAT. AND THEN YOU
KNOW ONE THING LED TO ANOTHER
AND THEN.
.
EACH TIME I WENT IN I ALSO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT AND WE KEPT
BUILDING WE.
SO NOW WE HAVE A DEGREE IN THERE
IN A BOOK AND.
WHAT KINDS OF STUFF? SO YEAH
IT'S VERY COLD HOW MANY HOW MANY
OF THE OTHER PRISONERS ARE.
AVAILING THEMSELVES OF THE
OPPORTUNITY. WE.
SO IN THE FORMAL EDUCATION PAUL
AND WE OBVIOUSLY THAT'S THE
NUMBERS ARE A LOT SMALLER WE
HAVE TWENTY FIVE IN EACH CO HOLE
AND WE'VE. GOT TWO COHORTS RIGHT
NOW SO FIFTEEN THE DEGREE
PROGRAM RIGHT UP IN THE WOODS ON
CAGE PROGRAM WE HAVE. PROBABLY
OF A THOUSAND PEOPLE
PARTICIPATED IN NOW AND ALL
AROUND THE SITE SO I GET LETTERS
NOW FROM ALL AROUND PRISONS
AROUND THE STATES AND THAT I
WILL RUN HE STATE SORT OF HEARD.
ABOUT THE PROGRAM SEND IN THEIR
RIGHTS IN AND EVEN IF WE CAN'T
PUBLISH THE STUFF WE PUT IT UP
ON THE WEBSITE AND STUDENTS
RIGHT BACK TO THEM. GIVEN
RESPONSES TO THAT WORKS THAT
THEY FEEL INCLUDED IN WHATEVER
WAY WE CAN.
RIGHT MISTER WHAT WELL WE WE
NEED TO TELL THAT STORY MORE
OMINOUS THERE'S SO MUCH MORE
INTEREST NOW. IN TAKING A
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO.
TO OUR PRISON SYSTEM AND AND.
AND AND THERE'S A LOT MORE
INTEREST I THINK ON THE PART OF
LEGISLATION THE GOVERNMENT
GENERAL TO.
TO GET MORE OF THESE KINDS OF
TRULY.
ANTI RECIDIVIST.
AT PROGRAMS IN PLACE THAT WILL
MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND AND IN
TREATING PEOPLE BETTER AND AND
MAKING IT MUCH LESS LIKELY THAN
END UP BACK IN THE SYSTEM AND.
SO I BUY VERY MUCH APPLAUD YOU
I'D. FINALLY I'D LOVE TO HEAR.
YOUR UPCOMING BOOK ABOUT THE
BROWNS. HAVE YOU BEEN
INTERVIEWING THE GOVERNOR AND
YEAH I HAVE SOME IT'S CALLED
UPON TO CALIFORNIA. THIS FAMILY
DYNASTY THAT TRANSFORMED THE
STATE AND SHAPE THE NATION'S SO
IT GOES BACK AND STARTS WITH THE
SHOCK MEANS TO THE GOVERNORS
TALKS ABOUT TALKS ABOUT RIGHT
AND THAT WAS WHAT GOT ME
INTERESTED IN IT SO I. DID A LOT
OF RESEARCH ON HIS GREAT
GRANDFATHER WAS A SHOP AROUND.
HE'SVERY INTERESTED IN. THE
HOUSE WHAT HE THINKS OF THE REST
OF IT BUT YEAH. AND THEN YOU
KNOW A LOT ABOUT PAT AND INJURED
SO MANY ANY.
SNEAK PEEKS FIRST YOU KNOW THAT
WITH A GAL IS ACTUALLY THE GALS
WENT OUT THIS WEEK SO PEOPLE ARE
STARTING TO READ IT OKAY YOU
TELL US WHEN IT WHEN IT WHEN IT
WAS HIT WITH YOUR ARGUMENT.
I'M.
THE ARGUMENT THAT IT'S A FAMILY
WHOSE HISTORIES HERE I MEAN THAT
THAT THEY'RE PROFOUNDLY
IMPORTANT SHAPING THE STATED AND
AND ALSO COULD ONLY E IN
CALIFORNIA I MEAN IT IS A REALLY
A CALIFORNIA STORY AND. AND AND
I TRY THROUGH THEM TO TELL.
I AM A NEW YORKER SO I MOVED
HERE TWO THOUSAND SO I YOU KNOW
I CONFESS THAT I I HAD THE NEW
YORKERS VIEW OF CALIFORNIA AND
THEREFORE I KNOW WHAT PEOPLE IN
THE EAST COAST AND YOU KNOW
THINK OF CALIFORNIA AND HOW
LITTLE IS REALLY UNDERSTOOD
ABOUT IT. AND AND WHEN I MOVED
HERE I SORT OF ASK PEOPLE WHAT
SHOULD I READ AND. THERE ARE NOT
THAT MANY BOOKS THAT SORT OF YU
KNOW CARRY MIKE WILLIAMS IS A
GREAT INTRODUCTION CALIFORNIA
BUT IT ENDS IN NINETEEN FORTY
EIGHT. SO THIS BOOK IS AN EFFORT
TO USE THE FAMILY TO REALLY SORT
OF EXPLAIN A LOT OF THINGS ABOUT
CALIFORNIA WHAT MATTERS HERE
WHAT'S DIFFERENT ABOUT
CALIFORNIA.
SO THERE'S A LOT ABOUT.
EDUCATION IMMIGRATION
DEMOGRAPHICS THE PHYSICAL
ENVIRONMENT PLACES AND AND THE
WAYS IN WHICH THE FAMILY YOU
KNOW FROM THE GOLD RUSH. ON TO
THE PRESENT.
IS IS IS VERY MUCH INTERTWINED
WITH ALL THOSE THINGS MA'AM.
WHAT DID THEY TELL YOU TO READ
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU ASK PEOPLE?
I'M KAREN WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA
THE GREAT EXCEPTION.
MIKE DAVIS COURTS.
PETER* PARADISE LOST. YOU
KNOW WHICH IS GREAT YEAH AND NO
UNION.
I KNOW WELL INTENDED INTERVIEW
BUT YEAH. CALLED YEAH.
GREAT WELL I APPRECIATE IT VERY
VERY INTERESTING VERY
INTERESTING STUFF AND I I AM.
MY FATHER'S A BRICK BY THE WAY
SO IT'S OKAY.
HAVE YOU HERE TO.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU GUYS REALLY
DO APPRECIATE YOU SO MUCH REALLY
FASCINATES. ME OKAY OUR NEXT
PANEL WILL LOOK AT PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAMS WERE LOOKING AT
INSPIRING CULTURAL CONNECTIONS
ORGAN AND INTRODUCE JOHN SHAPE
AS I SAY ABOUT WHO'S. I BRING
ABOUT A PUBLIC LIBRARY.
BOARD MEMBER ALSO OF CALIFORNIA
HUMANITIES WILL HAVE NINA SIMONS
WELL EXACTLY DIRECTOR THAN SANTA
CRUZ MUSEUM. OF ART HISTORY.
AND ALL OF OUR RESULTS AS WELL
WHO'S A PHD AND AND A PROFESSOR
OF HISTORY AND FACULTY
COORDINATOR SOCIAL JUSTICE
INSTITUTE AT BAKERSFIELD COLLEGE
AND ALSO A BOARD MEMBER KELLY
MANDY SO.
WE'LL START WITH YOU AND.
OUR C. LIBRARIAN.
INDEED.
A GOOD AFTERNOON.
IT'S SO WONDERFUL TO BE HERE
GENUINE PLEASURE. TO SPEAK ABOUT
OF THE HUMANITIES.
AND CERTAINLY LIBRARIES AS WELL.
AND. I DO HAVE THE GREAT
PLEASURE OF BEING CITY LIBRARIAN
OF LOS ANGELES AHEAD OF THE LOS
ANGELES PUBLIC LIBRARY AND.
EVERY PLEASURE HEADACHE ALL IT'S
A GREAT PLEASURE NOW ACTUALLY
LOVE IT BEST JOB IN THE WORLD.
BUT EVERY SINGLE THAT WAS THE
RIGHT ANSWER.
SOME DAYS ARE TO. COME BUT
EVERYONE OF THE SEVENTY THREE
LOCATIONS OF THE LOS ANGELES
PUBLIC LIBRARY HAS A SIGN POSTED
PROMINENTLY THAT SAYS WE WELCOME
EVERYONE YEAH.
AND WE MEAN IT.
AND MAKING CERTAIN THAT EVERY
ANGELINO FEELS WELCOME AND AT
HOME IN OUR LIBRARIES IS
CRITICAL. AND REALLY REPRESENTS
WHO WE ARE AS AN INSTITUTION AND
WHO WE ARE AS A PROFESSION.
IN LIBRARIANSHIP.
AND HUMANITIES PROGRAMMING IS AN
ENORMOUS PART OF THIS MISSION.
AND FUNDAMENTALLY IT'S ABOUT
TELLING THE STORIES OF
CALIFORNIANS AND PROVIDING A
PLATFORM TO OUR STATE'S
RESIDENCE TO SHARE THEIR OWN
STORIES. AND A TREMENDOUS
EXAMPLE OF THIS IS VISUALIZING
LANGUAGE OAXACA IN LA. A WHICH
IS ACTUALLY FEATURED.
IN YOUR BOOK TODAY. AS PART OF
THE GETTY'S PACIFIC STANDARD
TIME LA LA SERIES OF EXHIBITIONS
THAT EXPLORE THE INTERSECTION
BETWEEN LOS ANGELES AND LATIN
AMERICA. WE COMMISSIONED AN
ARTIST COLLECTIVE IN OAXACA
MEXICO TO PAINT SIX MONUMENTAL
MURALS THAT WERE INSTALLED IN
OUR CENTRAL LIBRARY'S ROTUNDA
LAST YEAR. THEY CELEBRATE THE
OAXACAN OMMUNITY OF ALLY AND
LOOK AT THE WHOLE HAWK AND
COMMUNITY IN LA. THROUGH THE
LENS OF THESE HAWKEN ARTISTS.
AND THE MURALS. ALSO FEATURED
THIS.
INDIGENOUS OF ZAPOTEC LANGUAGE.
EITHER PERMANENT NOW THEY'RE UP
THEY WERE TO COME DOWN IN LATE
JANUARY WE'VE EXTENDED THE MINT
UNTIL AUGUST BUT THEY'RE THEY'RE
PAINTED ON. CANVAS AND IT'S IT'S
ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE THAT'S
COOL.
THEY'RE INCREDIBLY POPULAR AND
BEAUTIFUL.
BUT JUST HAVING THE MURALS IN
THE ROTUNDA.
THERE TO VIEW WASN'T ENOUGH.
AND WITH THE SUPPORT OF
CALIFORNIA HUMANITIES WE HELD
DOZENS OF PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
LOS ANGELES AT OUR LIBRARIES.
THAT REALLY CELEBRATED OAXACAN
CULTURE.
AND NOTABLY IN COMMUNITIES THAT
DIDN'T NECESSARILY HAVE
SIGNIFICANT MEXICAN AMERICAN
POPULATION SO. SHARING THE STORY
OF OF THE WALKING COMMUNITY
THROUGHOUT THE CITY.
IN THE HUMANITIES ARE AN
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL PART OF ALL
THAT WE DO IN LIBRARIES
CERTAINLY THEY'RE PART OF OUR
PHYSICAL AND VIRTUAL COLLECTIONS
THAT WE OFFER. A BUT AS
IMPORTANTLY THERE IN THE CENTRAL
PART OF THE MAJOR INITIATIVES OF
OUR LIBRARY. AND THIS IS REALLY
PERHAPS MOST EVIDENT IN ONE OF
THE MOST PROMINENT ADDITION IS
THAT WE HAVE AND THAT IS SERVING
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES THROUGH
OUR NEW AMERICANS INITIATIVE.
AND WE STARTED THIS IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE FOCUSING ON
LEGAL PERMANENT RESIDENTS IN LA.
AND HELPING THEM NATURALIZE AND
IN  PROGRAM WE CALLED YOUR PATH
TO CITIZENSHIP BEGINS AT THE LOS
ANGELES PUBLIC LIBRARY.
AND THE INITIATIVE INVOLVED AN
EXPANDED REALLY BEAUTIFULLY.
TO SERVE BOTH DOCUMENTED AN
UNDOCUMENTED RESIDENTS OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND WORKING WITH
COMMUNITY PARTNERS WE NOW
PROVIDE WORKSHOPS. CITIZENSHIP
CLASSES AND ONE ON ONE
ASSISTANCE AND HAVING ONGOING
HUMANITIES PROGRAMS THAT UNDER
THE CULTURAL TRADITIONS. OF OUR
CITY'S RESIDENTS AND TELL THEIR
STORIES CONNECTS ANGELINA'S TO
EACH OTHER IMPROVES CULTURAL
COMPETENCY AND IS ALSO
STRATEGICALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
LIBRARY BECAUSE. PEOPLE WILL
COME INTO OUR LIBRARIES.
BRANCHES IN CENTRAL LIBRARY FOR
THESE PROGRAMS AND THEN LEARN
ABOUT ALL THE OTHER GREAT
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE AND IN
MANY CASES INTRODUCE. THE GREAT
TRADITION OF PUBLIC LIBRARIES IN
THE U. S.. TO NEW AMERICANS.
A AND THIS IS ALSO OF COURSE THE
OBJECTIVE OF CALIFORNIA MANATEES
LIBRARY INNOVATION LAB.
WHICH IS A GRANT PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES TRAINING SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES TO A COURT OF TEN
PROGRAMMING LIBRARIANS FROM
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THEY EACH DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENT A PUBLIC HUMANITIES
PROJECT. AND ALL OF THE PROJECTS
ARE ARE ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE A
FOCUS ON IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES.
AND THEY ENGAGE THESE
COMMUNITIES THROUGH A WIDE RANGE
OF ACTIVITIES AND THE RESULT IS
INCREDIBLY CREATIVE. AND UNIQUE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY STRENGTHEN
TIES TO COMMUNITY PARTNERS. IN
THERE ANOTHER WAY TO WELCOME A
NEW PATIENTS TO THE LIBRARY.
IN A GLANCE AT THE CURRENT
PROGRAM SCHEDULE AT MY LIBRARY
ILLUSTRATES THE DIVERSITY OF OUR
HUMANITIES PROGRAMS AND YOU'LL
SEE THIS IN THE SMALLEST
LIBRARIES IN THE STATE AND THE
LARGEST AS WELL. BUT A LOOK AT
THAT SCHEDULE INCLUDES JAPANESE
TAIKO DRUMMING SOUTH INDIAN
TEMPLE DANCING A VIOLIN CONCERT
FEATURING THE MUSIC OF OF ALL
THE IN BOX A LECTURE ON THE ART
OF FRIDA KAHLO. AN ART EXHIBIT
FEATURING CIVIL RIGHTS ERA
PHOTOGRAPHY FEATURING IMAGES OF
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING DURING
HIS VISITS IN LOS ANGELES. A
MULTIMEDIA EXPLORATION OF
YIDDISH THEATER AND DANCE IN LA.
LGBT HISTORY EXHIBITS AND HIP
HOP AND SPOKEN WORD
PERFORMANCES.
AND I EVEN REMEMBER SENATOR ALAN
WHEN YOU WERE AT OUR WILL AND
ARIEL DURANT BRANCH LIBRARY FOR
AN ANNIVERSARY WE EVEN HAD A
RUSSIAN DANCE THAT'S RIGHT.
THERE SO YEAH EVEN USING IT'S
IT'S THE IT'S THERE ALL THE TIME
I'VE YOU KNOW I'VE USED THOSE
MOVES AT WEDDINGS AND.
AND QUITE A FEW TIMES VERY
HELPFUL.
BUT BOTH LIBRARIES IN THE
HUMANITIES ARE AS YOU KNOW AND
ESSENTIAL ESSENTIAL FOR A
VIBRANT HEALTHY CALIFORNIA AND
WHEN THEY COME TOGETHER AS THEY
DO EVERY DAY AND EVERY LIBRARY
ACROSS THE STATE IT'S IT'S
REALLY ABSOLUTE MAGIC.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SPEAK YOU.
VERY COOL ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON.
I WANT TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY
ABOUT A SECRET SUPER POWER OF
MUSEUMS AND CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS. AND IT'S THE POWER
TO BRIDGE COMMUNITIES AND I'M
USING THIS TERM NOT
EUPHEMISTICALLY BUT SPECIFICALLY
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT HOW WE BUILD
SOCIAL CAPITAL IN COMMUNITIES.
AND WE LIVE IN A VERY DIVIDED
WORLD A VERY DIVIDED COUNTRY AND
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE THEORIZED
THAT ONE OF THE CORE REASONS FOR
OUR DIVISIONS IS WE NOW LIVE IN
A WORLD WHERE THERE ARE A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO BOND WITH
PEOPLE. WHO SHARE YOUR RACE
GENDER CLASS IDENTITY AND VERY
FEW OPPORTUNITIES TO BRIDGE WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRULY DIFFERENT
FROM YOU? MUSEUMS AND CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
GREAT PLACES TO BOND YOU KNOW WE
LOVE SEEING FAMILIES ENJOY OUR
MUSEUM. BUT WE'VE REALLY DECIDED
THAT OUR PRIMARY FOCUS SHOULD BE
NOT ON BONDING BUT I'M BRIDGING
AND I'M BEING A SPACE WHERE
PEOPLE CAN FORM CONNECTIONS WITH
PEOPLE FROM DIFFERENT WALKS OF
LIFE. DIFFERENT AGES DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCES I'M I'M SURE YOU'VE
SEEN THE RESEARCH ON THE
INTERCESSORY OF BRIDGING
COMMUNITIES WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
SOCIAL COHESION WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY. A LOT OF IT
COMES DOWN TO LOOKING AT
STRANGERS ON THE STREET AND
SEEING THEM AS POTENTIAL FRIENDS
INSTEAD OF POTENTIAL THREATS.
AND ONE OF THE MORE SURPRISING
PIECES OF ESEARCH I THINK ABOUT
BRIDGING IS THAT ONE OF THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO BRIDGE PEOPLE
FROM DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS IS
THROUGH CREATIVE EXPRESSION
MAKING SOMETHING TOGETHER. AND
THROUGH SHARING IN CELEBRATING
CULTURAL HERITAGE.
BECAUSE WHEN WE MAKE SOMETHING
TOGETHER WE'RE GETTING
COMFORTABLE WHETHER IT'S JUST
PASSING THE SCISSORS AND GLUE OR
WHETHER IT'S PAINTING THAT MURAL
I'M AND WHEN WE SHARE STORIES
FROM OUR DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS
WE START TO SEE THOSE UNEXPECTED
CONNECTIONS. THAT BRING US
TOGETHER IN EMPATHY AND SHARED
UNDERSTANDING I'M AND SO AT OUR
MUSEUM IN SANTA CRUZ WE REALLY
FOCUS ON HOW WE CAN DESIGN
EXPERIENCES TO BRIDGE
COMMUNITIES I'M MORE PROUD OF
THE HUNDRED THOUSAND PLUS PEOPLE
WHO VISIT EVERY YEAR. BUT WORRY
I'M MORE GRATEFUL TO THE TWO
THOUSAND LOCAL PARTNERS WE WORK
WITH EVERY YEAR HERE JUST FIFTY
OF THEM AND I LOOK AT THIS
PICTURE I SEE A LIBRARIAN I SEE
A COUNTY SUPERVISOR. I SEE A
BIKE MESSENGER I SEE A PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKER I SEE PEOPLE
REFLECTING VERY DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES IN OUR COUNTY WHO
ARE USING THE MUSEUM AS A PLACE
TO BUILD BRIDGES ACROSS
DIFFERENCES.
WE DESIGN INTO THE PROGRAMS WE
CO PRODUCED WITH PARTNERS AND WE
PHYSICALLY DESIGN INTO THE SPACE
CREATING WAYS TO ENCOURAGE AND
INVITE PEOPLE TO MEET A STRANGER
IN THE EXHIBIT. TO SHARE STORIES
AND REFLECTIONS ON ISSUES LIKE
THIS IS AN EXHIBIT THAT STUFF
RIGHT NOW ABOUT FOOD SECURITY
WE'VE DONE PROJECTS ON FOSTER
CARE.
THIS IS AN EXHIBITION WE JUST
OPENED CALLED CBS SCENE VERY
SERVICE STILL. IT FEATURES OVER
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY PORTRAITS
CREATED BY PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. AND THEY REALLY
REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF WHO'S
IN OUR COMMUNITY IN TERMS OF
WHO'S ON THE WALLS. AND ALSO WHO
CREATED THESE PIECES ARE THIS IS
A PICTURE.
FROM THE OPENING OF JUST A FEW
OF THE TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE ARTISTS INVOLVED IN THIS
EXHIBITION. MEETING EACH OTHER
FOR THE FIRST TIME THROUGH THIS
PROJECT SEEING AND BEING SEEN BY
DIFFERENT PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY BECAUSE OF THE POWER
OF THIS EXHIBITION.
AND SO I'M HERE TODAY.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT WHAT WE
LIVE IN A DIVIDED WORLD. IT'S A
WORLD THAT THOSE DIVISIONS
CAUSED ME A LOT OF STRESS BUT I
FIND AND TAKE A LOT OF HOPE IN
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD THESE
BRIDGES AND TO CHANGE AND SHIFT
THAT DIVISION. THROUGH THESE
CULTURAL PROJECTS THROUGH THESE
CREATIVE PROJECTS I'M AND I
REALLY WANT TO INVITE AND ASK
YOU TODAY TO DO TWO THINGS.
FIRST TO SUPPORT THIS BRIDGE
BUILDING WORK AND EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY TO HOLD US TO IT
BECAUSE FRANKLY YOU HAVE A SUPER
POWER THAT WE DON'T HAVE.
MUSEUMS IN PARTICULAR OUR
FRIENDS IN LIBRARIES ARE
PUBLICLY SUPPORTED WHICH IS
AWESOME BUT MUSEUMS THEATERS
OTHER CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS THAT
ARE PRIVATE NON PROFITS. FRANKLY
IT'S OUR CHOICE WHETHER WE
DECIDE TO BE A PLACE THAT
BRIDGES OR WHETHER WE DECIDE TO
BE A BOND A PLACE FOR A CERTAIN
KIND OF PERSON AND A CERTAIN
KIND OF BACKGROUND. AND ONE
PUBLIC MONEY COMES INTO THE
PROGRAM IT CHANGES THE
ACCOUNTABILITY TO THAT SENSE
THAT WE NEED TO NOT JUST BE FOR
PEOPLE OF A CERTAIN CLASS
BACKGROUND A CERTAIN RACIAL
BACKGROUND CERTAIN EDUCATION
BACKGROUND. BUT THAT WE CAN AND
SHOULD BE PLACES THAT ARE OF BY
AND FOR EVERYONE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. I'M SO I REALLY ASK
YOU TODAY AND ALL OF US I YOU
KNOW ENCOURAGE ALL OF US TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE CAN USE
CULTURE AND HUMANITIES. TO BUILD
BRIDGES AND HOW WE CAN USE THE
UNIQUE SUPER POWERS THAT WE HAVE
TO PUSH FOR MORE OF THIS KIND OF
WORK SO THAT WE HAVE MORE
DANTE'S MORE CHRISS MORE JOHNS
MORE OF THESE PROJECTS. NOT JUST
A FEW ACROSS THE STATE BUT THAT
EVERY CULTURAL INSTITUTION FEELS
LIKE THIS IS THE WAY THEY CAN
AND SHOULD BE WORKING TO BUILD A
STRONGER STATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
YEAH PROFESSOR OF SOUTH.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR ALAN AND
FELLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS OLIVER IS
ALSO I'M A PROFESSOR OF HISTORY
AND FACULTY COORDINATOR. OF THE
SOCIAL JUSTICE INSTITUTE OF EGGS
FOR COLLEGE.
HUMANITIES EDUCATION THE
NATIONAL ENDOWMENT FOR THE
HUMANITIES AND CALIFORNIA
HUMANITIES ALL PLAY A VITAL ROLE
THROUGHOUT OUR GREAT STATE BUT
IN PARTICULAR IN RURAL AND
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES OF THE
SOUTHERN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
RECENTLY APPOINTED ANY H.
CHAIRMAN JOHN PARISH PT
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF
EXPANDING ACCESS TO HUMANITIES
PROGRAMS IN RURAL COMMUNITIES.
AS WELL AS THE ROLE OF PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS.
IN EXPANDING ACCESS TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IT'S ON
THESE TWO FRONTS EXPANDING
ACCESS AND PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT I FOCUS MY OWN
WORK AS A HUMANITY SCHOLAR AND
ADVOCATE.
IN KERN COUNTY ANY AGE HAS
INVESTED FUNDS FOR A VARIETY OF
PROGRAMS RECENTLY. AT CSU
BAKERSFIELD ANY H. FUNDED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE UNIVERSITY'S
NEW ETHNIC STUDIES PROGRAM.
AND BIGGEST FOR COLLEGE DELANO
CAMPUS THE ANY AGE FUNDED A
FAMILY HISTORY DIGITAL ARCHIVE
PROJECT THE TITLE OF WHICH
PRESERVING INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY'S HISTORY. CAPTURES
THE CITY'S HISTORICAL LEGACY OF
INTERNATIONAL MIGRATION.
THANKS FOR COLLEGE ALSO RECEIVED
FUNDS FOR A THREE YEAR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
FOCUSED ON INCREASING FACULTY
COMPETENCY IN PLACE BASED
PEDAGOGY AND INTERDISCIPLINARY
HUMANITIES. AT THE STATE LEVEL
CALIFORNIA HUMANITIES HAS MADE
RECENT GRANTS THROUGHOUT THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. INCLUDING
FINDING A DOCUMENTARY FILM
FOCUSED HONEST STUDENTS FROM
MIGRANT LABOR BACKGROUNDS
MATRICULATING THREE UNIVERSITY.
OTHER RECENT GRANTS INCLUDE
CIVIL RIGHTS OR HISTORY PROJECTS
AS WELL AS A FRESNO BASED
PROJECT FOCUSED ON THAT CITY'S
UNIQUE CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
HISTORY OF WEST COAST HIP HOP.
AND DANCE CULTURE.
THIS MAN IS IMPORTANT THE CENTER
VALLEY BECAUSE OF THE REGIONAL
DIVERSITY AND ROLL THAT
MIGRATION HAS PLAYED IN HUMAN
SETTLEMENT.
ONE EARLY TWENTIETH CENTURY
HISTORIAN DESCRIBED THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AS A RACIAL AND ETHNIC
MICROCOSM OF AMERICA.
THE REGION'S DIVERSE MIGRATION
HISTORIES FROM PRE COLONIAL
TIMES THROUGH THE PRESENT ARE
ALL HISTORICALLY SIGNIFICANT YET
DISCONNECTED IN THE MINDS OF
MANY RESIDENTS.
THE REGION IS MARKED BY
DISLOCATED INSULAR AND ISLAND
COMMUNITIES THAT LINE THE VALLEY
FROM NORTH TO SOUTH.
AND IT'S THE HUMANITIES THAT
HELPS TO CONNECT THESE ISLAND
COMMUNITIES WITH A BROADER WORLD
AND TO FIND COMMON GROUND.
CALIFORNIA HUMANITIES AND THE
ANY H. HAVE HELPED CULTIVATE A
LOCAL LEADERSHIP BASE WORKING
WITH COMMUNITY LEADERS
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS TO
INCREASE HUMANITY'S ACCESS IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
PARTNERSHIPS AMONG AND BETWEEN
BIGGER SO COLLEGE CSU
BAKERSFIELD AND FRESNO AND YOU
SEE WERE SAID WORK TO ENSURE
THAT THE CENTRAL VALUES ACCESS
TO HUMANITIES LEARNING
EXPERIENCES IS PROPORTIONAL. TO
THE REST OF THE STATE.
BOTH WITHIN AND OUTSIDE THE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM HUMANITIES
PLAY A VITALROLE IN CULTIVATING
HABITS OF MIND THE PROMOTE
ENGAGE CITIZENSHIP INCLUDING
LIFELONG LEARNING INTELLECTUAL
CURIOSITY MEDIA LITERACY AND
CULTURAL EMPATHY.
DURING MY TENURE AT BIGGER FOR%
COLLEGE AND THROUGH MY ROLE AS
HUMANITIES PROJECT DIRECTOR FOR
SUMMER GRANTS. I WORKED TO
ENSURE THAT COMMUNICATES FACULTY
HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
ENHANCE HUMANITIES TEACHING
COLLABORATION AND PARTNERSHIPS.
IN EFFECT PUTTING THE COMMUNITY
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
ENSURING THAT REAL FAMILIES
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES AND NON
ENGLISH SPEAKING FAMILIES CAN
ACCESS HUMANITIES IS SOMETHING
THAT THE ANY H. VALUES AND IS AN
APPROACH THAT I HAVE ADOPTED AS
PROJECT DIRECTOR.
BOTH ARE CRITICAL TO CLOSING
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS THAT CAN BE
SEEN IN HIGHER EDUCATION AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
PARTICULAR.
PARTNERSHIPS AND IN KIND
CONTRIBUTIONS HAVE ALSO RAISED
HAVE BEEN RAISED LOCALLY. BY THE
INFLUX OF EXTERNAL FUNDING.
THE NORMAN LEVIN CENTER FOR THE
HUMANITIES BIG FROM COLLEGE. THE
VIRGINIA AND OFFERED HAREL
FOUNDATION IN BAKERSFIELD.
CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENTS HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES INITIATIVE NCSU
BIGGER SO LIBRARY HAVE ALL
CONTRIBUTED FINANCIALLY TO
VARIOUS GRANTS THAT I HAVE
MANAGED THROUGH THE ANY AGE OR
OUR STATE HUMANITIES COUNCIL.
AS AN EXAMPLE OF COLLABORATIVE
COMMITTEES COMMITTEES
PROGRAMMING. A CULTIVATED
THROUGH PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS THE BIGGEST FOR
COLLEGE OF SOCIAL JUSTICE
INSTITUTE AS PART OF A
CALIFORNIA HUMANITIES AND THREE
OTHER COMMUNITY COLLEGES ACROSS
THE STATE. TO ENHANCE MEDIA
LITERACY FOR THE PROJECT
CALIFORNIA TWENTY TWENTY
DEMOCRACY IN THE INFORMED
CITIZEN.
AN INITIATIVE FUNDED IN PART
THROUGH THE MELLON FOUNDATION.
BY WORKING WITH THE FOLKS AT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES OF ALFRED
HER FOUNDATION HAS AGREED TO
PROVIDE FUNDING TO EXPAND THIS
WORK IN GREATER BAKERSFIELD AS
HAS THE NORMAN LEVIN CENTER FOR
THE HUMANITIES THE BIGGEST FOR
COLLEGE.
THESE PRIVATE FOUNDATIONS
MOBILIZED BY AN INFLUX OF
EXTERNAL FUNDING. CONTINUE TO
TRACK THE CONTINUE THE TRACK
RECORD OF CALIFORNIA HUMANITIES
AM ANY AGE OF LEVERAGING LOCAL
RESOURCES FOR EVERY DOLLAR
FLOWING INTO VARIOUS LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
IN BAKERSFIELD THE VARIOUS
PARTNERS WILL WORK WITH CHILDREN
PRICING JOURNALISTS AND OTHER
STATE AND NATIONAL MEDIA EXPERTS
TO CULTIVATE REGIONAL YOUTH
VOICES AND MEDIA LITERACY.
BIGGEST.
COLLEGE JOURNALISM AND PUBLIC
HEALTH FACULTY. AS WELL AS
TRADITIONAL HUMANITIES FACULTY
WILL WORK TOGETHER TO DEVELOP
CURRICULAR MODELS THAT HIGHLIGHT
THE LOCAL ENGAGE STUDENTS AND
EXPAND YOUR CAPACITY TO TELL THE
STORIES OF THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES.
ALL OF THIS IS MADE POSSIBLE BY
HUMANITIES FUNDING. AND THROUGH
THE LENS OF THE HUMANITIES
EDUCATION AND APPROACH THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
WELL I'M.
GOD I I'VE I'M LOOKING YOUR BIO
I CAN'T HELP BUT NOTICE THAT ONE
OF THE PROFESSIONALISM PROGRAMS
WAS. NINETY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS NINE HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE
AND I MUST HAVE DONE SOMETHING
TO GET UNDER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
ELEVEN DOLLARS OF THERE. THERE
IS IT IS IT HAS TO DO SOME SORT
OF.
YOU KNOW I DIDN'T DO THE MATH
ARE HISTORIANS ARE DUE BACK VERY
WELL JUST FUNNY THAT'S IN YOUR
BY THIS I MEAN I I'M SURE THERE
ARE SOME WELL I MEAN I I
DISTINCTLY WANTED TO PUT THAT IN
BECAUSE BOTH ANY AGE IN
CALIFORNIA HUMANITIES HAVE MADE.
REALLY TARGETED EFFORT TO ENSURE
THAT THE CENTRAL VALLEY IS
GETTING PROPORTIONAL FUN YEAH
THAT'S A REALLY.
I THINK A BIG ACCOMPLISHMENT
YEAH.
I'M.
CAN YOU SPEAK TO YOU'RE WORKING
ON TO YOU'RE YOU'RE LOOKING AT
AT BAKERSFIELD HISTORY. FROM
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN NINETY
FOUR.
IT'S CALLED MISSISSIPPI WEST CAN
YOU CAN YOU TELL US A BIT MORE
VIRUS SO MERRIAM'S WORK RIGHT
HAS BEEN FOUNDATIONAL AND
NEARING THE FARM WORKER MOVEMENT
HISTORY AS HAS OTHER SCHOLARSHIP
MY WORK CUT TRIES TO GO BEYOND
IT. TO TRIAL TO TELL WHAT KIND
OF URBAN STORY OF. RACIAL
SEGREGATION CIVIL RIGHTS AND
LABOR RIGHTS THAT GO BEYOND THE
ISSUES OF FARM LABOR.
AND IT'S IT'S INCREDIBLE
DIVERSE MULTIRACIAL COALITION
HISTORY ROOTED IT WITH THE
COMMITTEE SERVICE ORGANIZATION
OF THE NWC P. THE WAR ON POVERTY
SCHOOL DESEGREGATION. TO TRY
AGAIN TELL URBAN STORY AND WHAT
A LOT OF THE OUTSIDE WORLD THAT
CONSIDERS A A RURAL COMMUNITY
WRITES I TRY TO GO BEYOND THAT.
AND YOU ASK YOU ALSO ASK
QUESTIONS EARLIER ABOUT THE
NATIONAL PARK SERVICE AND AND
THIS IS HOW THIS NATION WE JUST
POSTED ABOUT TWENTY OF FOLKS WHO
CAME IN FROM ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WITH NPS IN DELANO.
TO IT TO TOUR HISTORIC SITES
AND THEN GO UP TO KEEN BECAUSE
THE IDEA IS TO DOEXACTLY WHAT
YOU TALK ABOUT WITH WITH BANDS
ARE REALLY PUSH THAT HARD. BUT
IT REQUIRES THE PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS REQUIRES
INTEGRATION IN SCHOOL
CURRICULUM.
AND THAT'S THAT'S SOME OF THE
WORK THAT I'M DOING IT AGAIN THE
MORE THAT WE CAN HIGHLIGHT THAT
RICH LEGACY THE FARM WORKER
MOVEMENT.
IT BENEFITS OUR STUDENTS ARE
THEY LOOKING TO POTENTIALLY.
INCLUDE THE DELANO SITES IN THE
BROADER NOT YES I ABSOLUTELY I
THINK.
FORTY ACRES. THE FILIPINO HALL
THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT ARE THE
TWO THAT ARE GETTING THE MOST
ATTENTION.
AND AGAIN OF COURSE THE SITE UP
IN IN THE KEEN BUT AGAIN IT
WOULD BE A SORT OF I THINK I TRY
PART RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN SOME
OF THESE PHYSICAL SITES AT IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. AND
THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF THE
CONTEST CAN TO STATION COMES
INTO PLAY BUT WHICH SITES IN
WHO'S GONNA CONTROL WHAT.
BUT IN REALITY AGAIN IT'S THE
THE RICH LEGACY OF THE AREA AND
WE WNT TO MAKE THAT AGAIN AT A
REGIONAL RESOURCE. SURE SURE
SURE SURE ON THEIR SIGNIFICANCE
TO THE DATES YOU CHOSE FORTY
SEVEN IN. A REALLY KIND OF
LOOKING AT THE POST WAR NOT
WORLD WAR TWO BUT REALLY THE
POST DUST BOWL ON A
TRANSFORMATION THAT HAPPENED IN
TERMS OF RIGID RESIDENTIAL
SEGREGATION.
AND LOOKING AT THE THE RISE OF
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
BEYOND THE FIELDS THROUGH THE
REAGAN ADMINISTRATION.
IN THIS SORT OF DECLINE IF YOU
WILL OF MULTIRACIAL COALITION.
NINE.
NEW MUSIC HISTORY THERE TO.
THE VISUALS OUTCOME THAT COMES
INTO PLAY I I I USE SOME OF THE
LYRICS OF MERLE HAGGARD ABOUT
CODES IN MY OWN WORK TO KIND OF.
HOW HE CAPTURED A CONSERVATIVE
SENSIBILITY BUT THEY'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT THE EVOLUTION OF OF
BOTH ARTISTS AND WHAT THEY MEAN
LOCALLY AND HALF THE INFUSION OF
SPANISH MUSIC AS WELL SO?
THERE'S A LOT OF MULTI
CULTURALISM INDIVIDUAL SOUNDS I
DO PLAY UPON THAT BUT THERE'S
THERE'S OTHER FOLKS DOING THAT
RESEARCH. NOT MYSELF AND ALSO A
LOT OF SYMPATHY FOR INCARCERATED
FOLKS WE HAD THIS DEFINITELY
ABSOLUTELY WHICH IS ALWAYS
INTERESTING.
.
A I WAS. THE ONE NIGHT WHEN SOME
OF MY COLLEAGUES TO.
YOU KNOW OUR A A LITTLE HARDER
EDGED ON ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM ROSS A BIG MERLE HAGGARD
FANS YEAH. YEAH YOU LISTEN TO
THE LYRICS.
ALRIGHT. THAT'S OKAY SO SO I'M
VERY VERY COOL I MISS I MEAN CAN
YOU TELL US A LITTLE ABOUT THE
YOUR BOOKS I MEAN I IF YOU'RE
YOU KNOW PARTICIPATORY MUSEUM
ART OF RELEVANCE IS THIS. ALONG
THE LINES OF WHAT YOU WERE
DESCRIBING TRYING TO MAKE
MUSEUMS IN THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY MORE RELEVANT TO BROADER
SOCIETAL EDUCATIONAL NEEDS
PEDAGOGICAL NEEDS ETCETERA YEAH
SO GLOBALLY THERE ARE A LOT OF
MUSEUMS AS WELL AS THEATERS
LIBRARIES PARKS THAT ARE.
WORKING ON HOW THEY CAN INVITE
PEOPLE TO NOT JUST BE CONSUMERS
BUT CO CREATORS OF THE
PARTICIPATORY MUSEUM IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN WAS REALLY FOCUSED
ON THAT HAPPENING IN MUSEUMS.
THE ART OF RELEVANCE.
WHICH CAME OUT JUST A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO I HAD TAKES A MUCH
BROADER VIEW AND ACTUALLY LEADS
WITH A STORY FROM ANZ IN OUR.
ABOUT A MAN WHO CAME OUT THERE
TOO HE DIDN'T HAVE ANY BIRTH
RECORDS AND HE.
HAD AN EXPERIENCE OF GOING AND
ENGAGING WITH A GRADUATE STUDENT
ARQUEBUS THERE WHO IS ABLE TO
FIND WITHIN THE CAMP NEWSPAPER
THE VERY FIRST. TIME HE'D EVER
SEEN ANY RECOGNITION. THAT HE
KIND OF SPUR STARTED TO EXIST IN
PRINT AND JAM BUT ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT THAT STORY LEADS
THE BOOK IS FRANKLY A LOT OF
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS ARE DYING
BECAUSE THERE'S A PERCEPTION
THAT WHAT'S HAPPENING BEHIND THE
SCENES IN THE ARCHIVE. ISN'T
RELEVANT TO EVERYBODY AND I
THINK AS WE'RE HEARING FROM ALL
OF THIS TESTIMONY TODAY. IT IS
RELEVANT BUT IT TAKES THESE
BRIDGE BUILDING AN AMPLIFICATION
PROJECTS TO CHANGE THE SENSE OF
IT DUSTY BOOKS IN A ROOM
SOMEWHERE TO THIS IS LIVING
HISTORY THAT'S IT ONCE IN THE
WAY WE CONNECT WITH EACH OTHER
AND THE DECISIONS WE MAKE
POLITICALLY. SO THE ART OF
RELEVANCE IS REALLY ABOUT HOW
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS CAN MATTER
MORE TO MORE PEOPLE SO THAT WE
CAN BUILD THE COMMUNITIES AND
THAT. ENVISION THAT FUTURE THAT
WE WANT TO SEE. MISS I THIS OF
COURSE YOU KNOW WHAT THEY WORK
THE JOHNS DURING IT. WEDS.
THE TO THE DUSTY BOOKS WITH THE
WITH. CONTEMPT RELEVANCE AND
SUCH SPECIAL WEB MUSEUM SO
LIBRARIES ARE TAKING ON THIS
KIND OF FASCINATING QUASI MUSEUM
ROLE THAT LET YOU THERE'S A LOT
OF EXHIBITS THAT. YOU KNOW AND
AND I I A IS THAT A IS THAT A IS
THAT A RELATIVELY NEW THING
HISTORICALLY OR OR IS IT.
YOU KNOW FLOWERING IN A IN A
MUCH MORE PROFOUND WAY NOW IT.
WELL I THINK YOU KNOW LIGHT
LIBER LIBRARIES OF ALWAYS YOU
KNOW TRY TO DO ALL THAT THEY
COULD.
TO CERTAINLY HIGHLIGHT
COLLECTIONS AND AND.
GIVE THE COMMUNITY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TO EXHIBIT ART
AND SO FORTH BUT I THINK
LIBRARIES.
AND I THINK THE DIGITAL AGE IS
CERTAINLY BROUGHT THIS ARE THINK
OF THEMSELVES NOT JUST AS BOOK
INSTITUTIONS OR EVEN EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS I THINK OF THE LOS
ANGELES PUBLIC LIBRARY IS AN
ARTS ORGANIZATION A HUMANITIES
ORGANIZATION. AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ORGANIZATIONAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATION SO. IT'S.
AND THEY'RE SUCH OPPORTUNITY
AND IT'S BECAUSE.
WE SERVE ABSOLUTELY EVERYONE.
.
THE POOREST IN OUR COMMUNITY
THOSE WITH HOMES WITHOUT HOMES
DOCUMENTED UNDOCUMENTED WEALTHY
PEOPLE MAKE USE OF OUR
LIBRARIES.
AND.
AND IT'S CONSTANTLY THINKING
ABOUT WHO ARE WE NOT SERVING AND
THE EXHIBITIONS THAT COME. IN
BRANCH LIBRARIES IN CENTRAL
LIBRARIES AND RURAL LIBRARIES
SUBURBAN AND URBAN LIBRARIES.
ARE ALL AN EFFORT TO GIVE VOICE
TO TO PARTS OF OUR COMMUNITY AND
ALSO TO SERVICE OUR OWN
COLLECTIONS I MEAN WE HAVE THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION PHOTOGRAPHS
IN THE ONLY PUBLIC LIBRARY
COLLECTION PART OF OUR
RESPONSIBILITY OF.
OF BEING STEWARDS OF THAT ARE
KIND IS NOT JUST TO PROTECT THEM
AND MAKE CERTAIN THERE ARE SAFE
AND OKAY IN A LOCKED CASE
SOMEWHERE BUT TO. TO ALLOW THEM
TO TELL THEIR STORIES AND WHICH
ARE THE STORIES OF ANGELENOS AND
CALIFORNIANS.
RE YOU RUN A AN EXTRAORDINARILY
LARGE AND COMPLEX INSTITUTION
YOU KNOW SEVENTY TWO BRANCHES A
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET WHAT WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE.
IS THERE A PARTICULAR.
BAD LOGISTICAL OR BUREAUCRATIC
CHALLENGED TO RUNNING
INSTITUTION OF THAT SIZE AND
COMPLEXITY THAT MAY NOT BE
IMMEDIATELY OBVIOUS TO. POLICY
MAKERS WELL IT'S SOME IT'S GOOD
CONSTANTLY FOCUSED ON AND MAKING
CERTAIN THAT WE DON'T RUN A
COOKIE CUTTER LIBRARY SYSTEM.
HOW HOW DIFFERENT NEIGHBORHOODS
AND COMMUNITIES AT WHAT THEY
NEED FROM US IS DIFFERENT?
BUT WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
MAKING CERTAIN THAT THE SERVICES
MAY LOOK DIFFERENT ACROSS THE
CITY.
THAT THEY'RE EQUITABLE AND AND
AND MAKING CERTAIN THAT OUR
STAKE HOLDERS BE ELECTED
OFFICIALS OR.
THE THE PHILANTHROPIC COMMUNITY
AND AND OTHERS.
AND AND THE RESIDENTS OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
YOU KNOW UNDERSTAND AND HAVE A
GOOD FAITH THAT WERE EXPANDING
THOSE RESOURCES EQUITABLY AND.
AND AND TELLING THAT STORY
REGULARLY AND CONSTANTLY IS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT SO THAT WE CAN
SPEAK THAT POWER SERVING PEOPLE
IN WATSON PROCLAIM AND PACIFIC
PALISADES IN EAST LA. ME TO WHAT
EXTENT YOU GUYS NOW BEING ASKED
TO TAKE ON. A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
SHARE OF THE CITY'S SOCIAL
SERVICES.
PARDON IN IN A BIG WAY AND AND
IN MANY CASES WE'RE NOT WE'RE
DOING IT BEFORE WE'RE BEING
ASKED YEAH. AND.
WE HAVE HIV TESTING IN OUR
LIBRARIES I HAVE A CHILDREN'S
DENTAL VAN A VISITING BRANCH
LIBRARIES WE SERVE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND LUNCHES LAST SUMMER.
AND PEOPLE OFTEN ASK ME A BURDEN
AT ALL THERE ARE
FAMILIES THAT WILL COME IN FOR
THAT FREE LUNCH.
THAT OUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
AS WELL AS VOLUNTEERS AND SPRING
VOLUNTEERS IN OUR LIBRARY WHO
LEARN ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE MATERIALS IN ARMENIA AND
AND TAGALOG AND SPANISH. THAT
THEY DIDN'T REALIZE WE HAD OR
THAT YOU CAN TAKE YOUR FIRST
STEP ON THE PATH TO CITIZENSHIP
AT THE LIBRARY.
AND.
SO IT'S.
IT'S SO IT'S A ROLE WE EMBRACE
BUT YES THERE IS AN INCREASED
DEMAND AND WORK WITH BECAUSE. WE
REACH POPULATIONS AND WERE
PHYSICALLY AND SO MANY
NEIGHBORHOODS OF THE CITY WHERE
THOSE ISSUES EXIST WE MAKE A
BEAUTIFUL PARTNER TO TO DO THAT
WORK YEAH. I MEAN LOOK OBVIOUSLY
THE THE.
THE TERM I MEAN IT'S THE. WHAT
IF THERE'S THERE'S THERE'S
THERE'S THER'S THIS EXTRA COST
AND AND LOGISTICAL CHALLENGE
ASSOCIATED WITH? WITH THESE
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT I'M SURE
THAT A LOT OF FOLKS HAVE NO
CLUE.
THE STEP LIVELY SYSTEM IS
TAKING ON TO THE EXTENT THAT IT
IS TRUE AND AND COORDINATING IT
IS CERTAINLY CAN BE CHALLENGING.
BUT WE RELY A GREAT DEAL ON
COMMUNITY PARTNERS.
AND AND LOS ANGELES RESIDENTS
PASSAGE OF MEASURE ELLEN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN QUITE HONESTLY
GIVES US THE ABILITY TO DO TO DO
MUCH OF THIS WORK AND TO BE.
INNOVATIVE IN TO TAKE RISKS THAT
THAT SOME OTHER COMMUNITIES
MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT WE'RE THANKFUL
FOR IT AND EVERY TIME I'M IN
FRONT OF AN ANGEL AND I SAY
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. OKAY FINALLY TO TO
YOU PROFESSOR SOFTWARE WEARS A
GREAT SO IN IN. WHAT WAY IS THAT
IF THE THE THE PLACE IN IN IN
BAKERSFIELD WHERE WHERE?
PEOPLE COME TOGETHER TO REALLY
DISCUSS THE. HISTORY OF THE AREA
AND AND HAVE IT ON DISPLAY IT
YOU KNOW WHAT WILL.
WHAT WERE YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN
WHEN YOU'RE BUT TURNS INTO A
MUSEUM EXCEPT IF IT WERE
SECONDLY? YOU KNOW I I THINK
BIGGER SOLD AND REALLY ACROSS
THE CENTER VALLEY THERE'S A LOT
OF LIKE AGAIN LIKE SAID DIVIDED
COMMUNITIES ISLAND COMMUNITIES
WHETHER CERTAIN CONSTITUENTS
THAT DO KNOW THEIR STORY THEY
HAVE THESE KIND OF PUBLIC VENUES
IN PUBLIC SPACES. BUT THEN
THERE'S THESE OTHER COMMUNITIES
THE KIND OF MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES THAT I LOOK AT
MOSTLY THAT THAT. OFTEN DON'T
INTERSECT WITH THE PUBLIC AND SO
AGAIN THE FUNDING THAT I'VE BEEN
A PART OF THROUGH HUMANITIES IS
TRYING TO AGAIN BRIDGE THOSE TWO
WORLDS AND THE SITE THAT I'VE
BEEN DOING IS THROUGH
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS WHETHER
IT'S. INVITING
AT PUBLIC TALKS IN SPANISH AT
THE DELANO CAMPUS OR IS GETTING
CC BIGGER SCHOOL FACULTY TO GO
TO THE RURAL COMMUNITIES I MEAN
THAT THAT'S WHERE TO ME THE
MAGIC HAPPENS WHEN YOU AGAIN CAN
CONNECT THE. TRADITIONAL
RESOURCES THAT HAVE ACCESS TO
THE FUNDS ARE SPACES SO STORIES
WITH THE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN ON THE PERIPHERY FOR FOR SO
LONG.
WE SAY THEY DON'T HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT THE F. W. ACTUALLY ON HAVE
A BIGGER FOR COLLEGE HAD A
CALLING OF CAMPUS IT WAS
ACTUALLY FOUNDED AS A RESULT OF
THE FARM WORKER MOVEMENT BECAUSE
OF THE ATTENTION. THE NEGATIVE
ATTENTION PRIMARILY IT WAS
COMING TO DELANO SOME OF THE THE
FARMERS AND THAT THEY CAN
COMMUNICATE ALL JUST GOT
TOGETHER TO BUILD A CAMPUS THERE
TO EDUCATE THE CHILDREN. A FARM
WORKER SINCE THERE IS AGAIN A
STRONG KIND OF A CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE FARMER CAN MOVE AND
EDUCATION. AND AND YOU'RE YOU
GUYS ARE YOU'RE PART OF THE KEY
BECAUSE SYSTEMS THAT'S THAT'S
CORRECT AND AND IN THE DISTRICT
INCLUDES TELLING OF
GEOGRAPHICALLY YEAH ACTUALLY
CLOSER CLOSER COLLEGE UP IN THE
HIGH DESERT.
PORTABLE COLLEGE AND IN BIGGER
COLLEGE WHICH HAS A MAIN CAMPUS
AND BIGGEST ON THE CAMPUS AND
DELANO AND WE JUST PASSED A FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION BOND TO EXPAND
OUR OUR CAMPUS IN THE SOUTH
KERN.
ARE YOU ALSO HAVE THE LARGEST
PRISON EDUCATION SYSTEM IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AT THE
COMMITTEE COUCHES ARE.
AND WE WERE NOT TOO GRAPHIC RICH
HE ABSOLUTELY YEAH.
INTERESTING OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU. REFERS TO.
ALRIGHT SO. YOU KNOW THE NEXT
PANEL OF THE QUESTION PERHAPS
HAS ALREADY BEEN ANSWERED STATED
HUMANITIES DO THEY MATTER.
BUT WE HAVE SOME REALLY
FANTASTIC PEOPLE TO REFLECT ON.
SOME OF THE PREVIOUS TESTIMONY
AND THAT THAT VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTION KATRINA WOULD WORTH
USE.
THIS YEAR PRINCIPAL RESEARCHERS
SR I EDUCATION.
AND THEN YOU HAVE BARHAM.
THIS COMMUNITY AND GAZE
RECORDING OR TOUGHER HUMANITIES
AND WE ALSO HAVE CHILI FRIES. OF
COURSE IS OUR PRESIDENT CEO OF
CAL FOR HUMANITIES AND WE
WELCOME. THE THREE OF YOU TO.
.
TO PROVIDE YOUR TESTIMONY WILL
START WITH THEM MIX WELL WITH.
THANK. YOU.
THIS IS SOMEONE CONTROLLING THE
POWER POINT YEAH FROM AFAR OKAY.
BUT I CAN JUST START OFF I'M SO
SO I WORK AT A STAR I
INTERNATIONAL IN THE BAY AREA
WHERE A NONPROFIT RESEARCH
ORGANIZATION. AND WE WERE
COMMISSIONED BY CALIFORNIA
HUMANITIES TO DO A STUDY LOOKING
AT THAT ACCESS STUDENT ACCESS TO
IT AND HUMANITIES COURSE WORK IN
THE PUBLIC CABLE SYSTEM. SO WHAT
WE DID WAS WE IS PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE DATA FOR STUDENT
ENROLLMENT. AND THEN.
COURSE AT TO LOOK AT WHAT
COURSES WERE OFFERED IN AND I'M
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AND THEN
WHAT.
COURSES STUDENTS ENROLLED IN AND
WE MERGE THAT DATA WITH SOME
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA ON SCHOOLS SO
THAT WE CAN. LOOK AT SCHOOL
POVERTY RATES IN PARTICULAR.
SO WITH THE PURPOSE OF
UNDERSTANDING WHETHER THEIR
EQUITY ISSUES IN PARTICULAR
RELATING TO ACCESS TO HUMANITIES
COURSE WORK.
WE CAN GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE.
SO THIS IS A FAIRLY OBVIOUS
SLOT.
FINDING BUT THAT THAT'S THAT
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
HIGH SCHOOLS OFFER MORE VARIETY
OF HUMANITIES COURSES THAN THE
SMALLEST HIGH SCHOOLS SO YOU CAN
SEE IF YOU LOOK AT THE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE ARTS WE DIVIDED THE
SCHOOLS INTO. INTO COURT TRIALS
BY SIZE SO THE LITTLEST SCHOOLS
ARE IN BLUE AND THE LARGEST
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOLS
ARE IN YELLOW. SO YOU CAN SEE
THAT THE LARGEST HIGH SCHOOLS
OFFER FOR MORE. ENGLISH LANGUAGE
ARTS COURSES THAN THE SMALLEST
HIGH SCHOOL THEN AND THAT'S NOT
SURPRISING IS SOMETHING THAT WE
KNOW WHEN WE DEBATE SCHOOL SIZE
AND THAT. YOU CAN HAVE MORE
VARIETY OF COURSE WORK BUT IT IS
A QUESTION THAT WE GOT SO I
WANTED TO PUT THAT OUT IN FRONT
THAT. YES IN FACT THERE'S MORE
VARIETY IN THEM THOUGH THAT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY SPEAK THE
QUALITY AND CALIBER NO NO NO NO
IT'S JUST THAT THERE'S JUST MORE
VARIETY OF COURSE. OFFERINGS
YET.
SO HERE IS REALLY THE MAIN
FINDING WHAT WE ENDED UP DOING
SO HUMANITIES COURSES INCLUDE
ENGLISH HISTORY FOREIGN LANGUAGE
AND THEN THE STUDY AND THEORY OF
THE ART SO WE INCLUDED MUSIC
THEORY ART HISTORY COURSES LIKE
THAT. AND BECAUSE ALL STUDENTS
TAKE ENGLISH IN HIGH SCHOOL AND
ALL STUDENTS TAKE HISTORY IN
HIGH SCHOOL WE DECIDED TO LOOK
AT ADVANCED PARTICIPATION
ADVANCED COURSES AND AN ADVANCED
COURSE OFFERINGS. AND SO WHAT
THIS GRAPH TELLS US IS THAT
SCHOOLS THAT ARE IN THAT THAT.
LOWEST POVERTY QUARTILE SO THE
BLUE ARE MUCH MORE LIKELY TO
OFFER PARTICULAR. ADVANCED
COURSES LIKE AP ENGLISH AP US
HISTORY AND THIS IS TRUE IF YOU
LOOK AT ID COURSES AND IT'S TRUE
IF YOU LOOK AT FOREIGN LANGUAGE
COURSES THAT ARE ABOVE THE
MINIMUM REQUIREMENT. SO YOU CAN
SEE THE SIGNIFICANT DISPARITIES
THE ONE EXCEPTION IS EIGHTY
LANGUAGE M. EIGHTY SPANISH
LANGUAGE AND THAT'S THAT'S TRUE.
.
THAT'S IT OFFERED ACROSS THAT
POVERTY LEVELS ARE SCHOOLS.
BUT IN TERMS OF ALL THE OTHER
SUBJECTS IF YOU INTEND TO
SCHOOLS SERVING MORE AFFLUENT
COMMUNITY YOU'RE MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE ACCESS TO ADVANCED
COURSEWORK IN HUMANITY'S MOST
DRAMATIC. GOD. DISPARITIES IN
FRENCH YES YES YEAH THE FOREIGN
LANGUAGES OTHER THAN SPANISH ARE
RARELY OFFERED AT THAT MANY OF
OUR HIGHEST POVERTY SCHOOLS.
I'M THIS FINDING TURNED OUR
ATTENTION TO MIDDLE SCHOOL AND
IT GOES IT'S ALSO A FOREIGN
LANGUAGE RELATED FINDING SO
CALIFORNIA MIDDLE SCHOOLS THAT
ARE SERVING HIGH POVERTY
COMMUNITIES ARE VERY UNLIKELY TO
OFFER FOREIGN LANGUAGE SO YOU'LL
SEE. I THINK THAT NUMBER IS
TWENTY EIGHT.
THAT ONLY TWENTY EIGHT PERCENT
OF THE MIDDLE SCHOOLS THE AT THE
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF MIDDLE
SCHOOLS THAT SERVE OUR. HIGHEST
POVERTY COMMUNITIES EVEN OFFER
FOREIGN LANGUAGE VERSUS STUDENTS
THAT ARE IN ARE MORE AFFLUENT
SCHOOL SEVENTY TWO PERCENT OF
THOSE SCHOOLS ARE OFFERING
FOREIGN LANGUAGE COURSES. IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL SO THAT WAS
ANOTHER BIG.
GAP AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
SEE IN OUR HIGH POVERTY
COMMUNITIES THEY JUST DON'T HAVE
THOSE KINDS OF CORPORATE COURSE
OFFERINGS AT THE MIDDLE SCHOOL
LEVEL.
HIGH SCHOOLS OF COURSE ARE
REQUIRED OFTEN LANGUAGE LANGUAGE
BECAUSE OF A THIRTY
REQUIREMENTS.
SO THIS GRAPH IS FOCUSED ON
STUDENT ENROLLMENT AND OF COURSE
ONLY A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF
STUDENTS.
BEAT AND AN ENROLLMENT IN IT IN
ADVANCED COURSES IN PARTICULAR
SO WHAT YOU CAN SEE ALTHOUGH THE
NUMBERS ARE LOW ACROSS THE BOARD
IN TERMS OF THE PERCENTAGE OF
STUDENTS THAT. THAT ENROLL IN AN
ADVANCED COURSES YOU CAN STILL
SEE SIGNIFICANT GAPS YOU KNOW
TWENTY PERCENT NEARLY TWENTY
PERCENT OF STUDENTS IN.
HI PART IN AND LOW POVERTY MORE
AFFLUENT HIGH SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ENROLLED IN AN
ADVANCED HISTORY OR SOCIAL
SCIENCE COURSE VERSUS ONLY TEN
PERCENT AND OUR HIGHER PROPERT
COMMUNITY. YOU SEE THE SAME GAP
IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE. AND YOU SEE
SOMEONE OF A GAP IN ENGLISH
ELEVEN PERCENT VERSUS EIGHT
PERCENT.
AND THEN FINALLY WE LOOKED AT
GENDER ISSUES IN TERMS OF
PARTICIPATION AND ADVANCED
HUMANITIES COURSE AND WE SEE
THAT THE MAJORITY OF STUDENTS
THAT ARE ENROLLED IN ADVANCE
HUMANITIES. COURSES IN HIGH
SCHOOL OUR GIRLS YOUNG WOMEN SO
IT'S ABOUT SIXTY FORTY IN TERMS
OF THAT PARTICIPATION IN THESE
ADVANCED HUMANITIES COURSES. SO
I IMAGINE IF WE HAD A SLIDE
LOOKING AT STEM COURSES IT MIGHT
LOOK IT MIGHT LOOK GOOD.
DIFFERENT.
WE DIDN'T LOOK AT THAT BUT.
WE WERE SOMEWHAT SURPRISED TO
SEE THAT GENDER DISPARITY THERE.
AND I THINK THAT'S ALL I HAVE.
NOW I'M NOT I MEAN YOU'RE YOU'RE
AT WHERE YOU THAT'S A PRICEY
DINNERS FOR.
.
WELL I HAVEN'T I HAVEN'T STUDIED
GENDER ISSUES IN EDUCATION
PERSONALLY THAT MUCH WE DO A LOT
OF OUR COOKING IN THE POVERTY
ISSUE SO. NOW THINKING ABOUT IT
I GUESS IT'S NOT TOO SURPRISING
BUT.
I DO WONDER IF WE WOULD SEE THE
SAME KIND OF DIFFERENCE IF
ELECTED STEM COURSES.
SLIP AWAY HAS A.
YEAH I DON'T KNOW.
OKAY THANK YOU FIGURE MATURING
VERY AS FACT BUT BUT. BUT
DISTURBING I TERMS OF THE.
THE THE SUCH ECONOMIC DISPARITY
ASPECTS OF THIS.
OKAY ONE NEXT YEAR FROM MISTER
BAHRAM. BORROW A VERY WELCOME.
SAID THANK YOU SO MUCH ANGOLA.
ANTEATERS YEAH YEAH. SIDES A.
SO MY NAME IS A HUMBLE AROUND
WHEN THEY COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
COORDINATOR AT CALIFORNIA
HUMANITIES AND ALSO THE CURATOR
FOR IN THE ART OF STORYTELLING
WHICH IS. OUR ROTATING ART
EXHIBIT IN OUR OAKLAND
HEADQUARTERS.
OUR EXHIBITS HIGHLIGHT
CALIFORNIA ARTISTS TO BOLDLY
EXPLORED THEMES THAT SPARK
CURIOSITY.
AND THE SEEMINGLY UNFAMILIAR AND
ENCOURAGE EMPATHY BY ACTING AS A
MATTER OF OUR OWN IDENTITIES.
WE VALUE AFFORDABLE ACCESS TO
ART EDUCATION OUTSIDE OF THE
CLASSROOM. AND SEEK TO ENHANCE
THE VIEWER'S EXPERIENCE BY
NURTURING COMMUNITY DIALOGUE
WITH THE ARTISTS HISTORICAL
EXPERTS AND CULTURE BEARS THAT
FREE PUBLIC FEELINGS.
WE'VE BROUGHT THE SALINAS VALLEY
TO THE BAY AREA WITH RECENTLY
AND EARTH THIRTY FIVE MILLIMETER
PHOTOS OF CESAR CHAVEZ AND THE
UNITED FARM WORKER MEMBERS.
THESE PHOTOS OF THE LESSER KNOWN
BUT HISTORICALLY CRUCIAL MARCH
IN THE SUMMER OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE WERE TAKEN BY ME ME
PLUMB.
WITH HISTORICAL CONTEXT PROVIDED
BY MARION PAUL WHO YOU HEARD
FROM EARLIER.
WE'VE OPENED UP OUR SPACE TO
RICHMOND BASED TEENS FROM THE
RICE CENTER TO SHARE THEIR OFTEN
IGNORED BUT INCREDIBLY
COMPELLING STORIES.
EXPRESS TO THEIR ART AND POETRY.
WE'VE ADORN OUR WALLS WITH
VIBRANT QUILTS MADE BY THE
MEMBERS OF THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
QUILT GUILD OF OAKLAND'S.
PLEASE USE THE TRADITION OF
QUILTING TO PRESERVE THE PRIDE.
HISTORY AND HARDSHIPS IN DORT OF
THE BLACK COMMUNITY.
AND WE'VE AMPLIFIED THE VOICES
OF THE INMATES AT LANCASTER
PRISON WHO ARE CURRENTLY SERVING
LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE SENTENCES BY
DISPLAYING THEIR ARTWORK. HAND
WRITTEN AUTOBIOGRAPHIES AND
LARGER THAN LIFE SIX FOOT TALL
LARGER THAN LIFE PHOTOS THAT'S
THE THE PRESENT WE DESERVE IT
RIGHT YES. I'M SO WE DISPAY
THOSE AND ACTUALLY THE EXHIBIT
IS LAUNCHING IN OUR OAKLAND
OFFICE NOT IN LA TOMORROW. SO
YOU'RE OAKLAND OFFICE PROVIDES A
CAN A CURATORIAL SPACE AS WELL
YES AND SOMETHING TAT WE
STARTED BACK IN AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN. I'M DOWNTOWN OAKLAND
YES. OLD OAKLAND BUT YES
DOWNTOWN GREAT.
AND SO EACH OF THESE EXHIBITS
SOME OF THEM ARE EXHIBITS THAT
COME DRESSED THE PROJECTS THAT
WE FIND IT FOR EXAMPLE THE MIMI
PALM PHOTOS AND DEMOCRACY IN THE
FEELS DOCTOR ROY IS.
PROJECT RIGHT AND CAGE BUT
SUMMER OR FROM ARTISTS THAT
AREN'T FUNDED PREVIOUSLY BY US
LIKE THE RICE CENTER.
OR EVEN THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
QUILT GUILD OF PLANS AND THEN%
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH THE ARTIST
ON THE COVER OF OUR PROGRAM
TODAY FIVE YARD FREE GAS. ON
WHO'S ALSO FEATURED AS A PART OF
EXHIBIT SO IT'S FAIRLY NEW. AND
OUR HOPE IS TO BRING.
NEW PEOPLE NEW AUDIENCES TO OUR
SPACE TO LEARN ABOUT US AND FOR
US TO LEARN ABOUT. THEM.
SO IN MY CONCLUSION I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT THE ART OF
STORYTELLING IS A TRUE MARRIAGE
OF THE ARTS AND HUMANITIES.
IT PROVIDES ARTISTS WITH A VALUE
TO REACH AND EDUCATE NEW
AUDIENCES WHILE GIVING HOW FRAIL
HUMANITY IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONVENE MEMBERS OF OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY.
THE MONEY'S OFFER CULTURAL
CONTACTS HISTORY AND LITERATURE.
THAT ENHANCE OUR EXPERIENCE WITH
THE ARTS AND BUILD BRIDGES OF
UNDERSTANDING ACROSS COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOU SO
MUCH PRESERVE.
AND I SUPPOSE MS FRIES YOUR
BOSSES AND YES SHE IS OUR MASS
IN FEARLESS LEADER AREN'T
FEARLESS LEADER. THANK YOU. AND
THANK YOU TO THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE AND I'M REALLY PROUD
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF CALIFORNIA
HUMANITIES. AND I AM PLAYING THE
GOOD CABOOSE IN TODAY'S
HUMANITIES TRAIN WEARING RED.
THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT AND IS
THE YOUNGEST OF FIVE KIDS MY
SIBLINGS WOULD SAY THAT'S THE
ROLE THAT I WAS BORN TO PLAY.
AND EVERY GOOD CABOOSE KNOWS
THAT WHEN THE OTHER TRAIN CARS
AND I'M JUST GONNA KEEP USING
THIS A ANALOGY WHEN THE TRAIN
CAR LOOK TRAIN CARS DO THE HEAVY
LIFTING YOU JUST LET THEM DO THE
HEAVY LIFTING I THINK THEY'VE
DONE A WONDERFUL JOB TODAY.
SHARING THE IMPACT OF THE
HUMANITIES AND SO MANY DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES IN SO MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS.
SO I'M JUST GOING TO SAY.
WHAT WE HOPE THAT YOU'LL
REMEMBER FROM TODAY'S HEARING?
WE HOPE THAT YOU'LL KNOW THAT
THE COMMUNITY THAT THE
HUMANITIES ARE ALIVE AND WELL IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE HOPE YOU REMEMBER THAT
THERE'S AN ECOSYSTEM OF
ORGANIZATIONS AND PEOPLE WORKING
TO FOSTER THEM AND MAKE THEM
ACCESSIBLE TO EVERY CORNER OF
THE STATE IN CALIFORNIA MANATEES
IS SO PROUD TO BE PART OF THAT
ECOSYSTEM. AS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION OF FORTY THREE
YEARS OLD WE'RE NOT A STATE
AGENCY BUT WE GET A PARTNER WITH
STATE AGENCIES LIKE THE ARTS
COUNCIL AND THE STATE LIBRARY.
AND WE HOPE THAT YOU REMEMBER
THAT CALIFORNIA STRONG NOT JUST
BECAUSE WE ARE THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD. BUT
BECAUSE OF OUR DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES AND CULTURAL ASSETS
THAT BLOOM THERE.
WE KNOW THAT THE ARTS AND
HUMANITIES ARE AT THE CORE AND
THAT THEY ALWAYS NEED MORE
SUPPORT.
I'D LIKE TO FINISH WITH A SHORT
VIDEO ABOUT CALIFORNIA
HUMANITIES NARRATED BY THE
FORMER U. S. POET LAUREATE JUAN
FELIPE THEY HAD AT A. HE WAS
ALSO CALIFORNIA MANATEES BOARD
MEMBER BACK IN THE DAY.
AS YOU WATCH INVITE YOU TO THINK
ABOUT YOUR CALIFORNIA STORY.
THE HUMANITIES.
TO ME ART ATTEMPT TO ANSWER TO
DEAL WITH THE MOST IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS IN LIFE.
CALIFORNIA A STATE OF ALMOST
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE.
WITH MILLIONS OF STORIES TO
SHARE.
THE STATE OF WRITERS FILMMAKERS
STORYTELLERS AN ARTIST.
A STATE OF INNOVATORS AND
THINKERS A STATE OF OPEN MINE.
FOR OVER FORTY YEARS CALIFORNIA
HUMANITIES HAS HELPED GIVE VOICE
TO VOICE IS SELDOM HEARD THROUGH
GRANTS AND SPECIAL PROGRAMS THAT
REACH INTO EVERY CORNER OF OUR
STATE. WE HELP TELL THE STORIES
OF CALIFORNIA YOUR SORY.
HUMANITIES ARE CENTRAL TO WHO WE
ARE THEY ENLIGHTEN INSPIRE
EDUCATE PROVOKE THOUGHT AND HELP
US EXCHANGE IDEAS. THEY EXPAND
OUT EMPATHY BY ENCOURAGING US TO
EXPRESS UNIQUE PERSPECTIVES THEY
HELPED MAKE OUR DEMOCRACY
STRONGER. THE HUMANITIES TEACH
CRITICAL THINKING POWER OF
CURIOSITY AND THE JOY OF
DISCOVERY THAT HELP US
UNDERSTAND AND VALUE WHAT WE
HAVE IN COMMON RATHER THAN WHAT
DIVIDES US. CALIFORNIA
HUMANITIES SUPPORTS THE HUMAN
EXPERIENCE THROUGH DOCUMENTARY
FILM ORAL HISTORIES PERFORMANCES
EXHIBITS POGRAMS IN LIBRARIES
AND MUSEUMS AND MUCH MORE.
CONNECT PEOPLE TO IDEAS INTO
EACH OTHER AND HELP OPEN NEW
WORLDS OF LEARNING THAT REFLECT
OUR DIVERSE CULTURES TRADITIONS
AND HISTORY.
TO MANY THIS MATTER BECAUSE IT
IS THE ONLY. WAY. THAT HUMANITY
HAS UNDERSTOOD THE LIFE. IT IS
THE SEARCH FOR UNDERSTANDING AT
CALIFORNIA HUMANITIES WE WORK TO
AMPLIFY THE VOICES THAT HELP US
UNDERSTAND EACH OTHER TO BUILD A
BETTER. CALIFORNIA. IT'S THAT
SIMPLE. AND THAT IMPORTANT.
THOUGHTS AND IDEAS ARE NEVER
COMPLETE THERE'S ALWAYS ROOM FOR
MORE. THE NEXT ONE IS UP TO YOU.
WHAT IS YOUR CALIFORNIA STORY?
WE INVITE YOU TO JOIN US AT CAL
HOME. FOR.
THAT YOU SHOULD TELL US WHO THE
NARRATOR WAS ONE FOR THE BETA.
US POET LAUREATE WHO CAME TO THE
FORE AND SENATE.
WELL THANK YOU I. REALLY CAN'T
CAN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE ABOUT.
ABOUT ABOUT HOW THE CASE WAS
MADE UP COULD COULD YOU JUST
DESCRIBE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT
THE THE STRUCTURES OF CALIFORNIA
AMENITIES AND IT'S DIFFERENT IN
THE ARTS COUNCIL. I'VE WHAT'S
THE RELATIONSHIP WITH THE STATE
GOVERNMENT.
YOU PLAY HIS ACCORDING ROLE
TEAMS AND AND RECIPIENT OF ANY
AGE GRANTS BUT. BUT IT'S A
DIFFERENT KIND OF RELATIONSHIP
AND AND TO TALK ABOUT THE
HISTORY OF THAT RELATIONSHIP
YEAH ABSOLUTELY WHEN WE'RE A
PRIVATE NONPROFIT SO WE ARE NOT
AND NEVER HAVE BEEN A STATE
AGENCY. AND BACK IN THE FORTY
THREE YEARS AGO WHEN THE STATE
ARTS COUNCILS IN THE STATE
HUMANITIES COUNCILS WERE BEING
CREATED ACROSS THE COUNTRY THERE
WAS A DECISION MADE.
THAT THE ARTS COUNCILS WOULD BE
STATE AGENCIES AND THAT THE
HUMANITIES COUNCILS WILL BE
NONPROFIT THIS DECISION WAS MADE
AT WHAT LEVEL OF THIS IS MADE AT
THE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
LEVEL.
WINDS AND SO IT'S IT'S THE SAME
ACROSS IN EVERY STATE WHY WHY IT
WELL THERE'S A REALLY LONG PAPER
ABOUT THAT THAT I CAN SEND
TOYOU. AND AND TO BE HONEST IT'S
IT'S A I THINK AN INTERESTING
CHECKS AND BALANCES.
WITH THE STATE ARTS COUNCIL
FROM STATE HUMANITIES COUNCILS
WE DO HAVE GUBERNATORIAL
APPOINTEES TO OUR BOARD. UP TO
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF OUR BOARD
IS MADE UP OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE
BEEN APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR
AND THE REST. OF THEM A NORMAL
NON PROFIT NOMINATION PROCESS
YOU KNOW AND SO WE WE WE DON'T
RECEIVE STATE FUNDING BUT WE DO
PARTNER WITH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES.
WE'VE DONE PRO PUBLIC PROGRAMS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCILS WE HAVE. DONE SOME
FUNDING PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE
STATE LIBRARY WERE WORKING WITH
UNIVERSITIES AND.
MUNITY COLLEGES ON YOUTH
PROGRAMS.
AND WE BELONG TO SOMETHING
CALLED THE CULTURAL CABINET
WHICH IS.
ALL OF THE THE STATE AGENCIES
THAT ARE INTERESTED IN WORKING
IN THE CULTURE AND HERITAGE AND
WERE ONE OF THE FEW NON PROFIT
MEMBERS ALONG WITH CALIFORNIA
STORE CALLED SOCIETY.
CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE ABOUT YOU
REALLY SHOULD WITHIN EACH.
SO THE AGE IS IS OUR PRIMARY
THUNDER WHEN YOU JUST SAY THAT
UP FRONT AND.
WE WE ARE WHAT IS CALLED ONE OF
THEIR STATE PARTNERS SO THEY'RE
FIFTY SIXTY COUNCILS.
AROUND THE COUNTRY THEY INCLUDE
SOME OF THE THE ISLAND THAT
SECTOR AND WE ALL RECEIVE
FUNDING ACCORDING TO A FORMULA
FROM THE ANY AGE. AND WE
IMPLEMENT PROGRAMS IN OUR OWN
STATE IN THE WAY THAT WE WANT TO
BUT WE REPORT TO THE ANY AGE AND
WE LOOK FOR WAYS OF
COLLABORATING WITH THEM. AND
WHETHER OUR THEIR STATE
COMMUNITY AT COUNCIL PARTNERS.
AND.
.
HOW IS THAT?
?
HOW IS IT REALLY SHOULD EVOLVE
OVER THE LAST TWENTY YEARS AND?
I CAN ONLY SPEAK TO THE LAST
THREE AND A HALF.
YEAH I I WOULD THINK WAS OUR BIG
DESERT.
I HAVE THINGS BEEN KIND OF
PRETTY STEADY WITH THE CHANGING
MINISTRATION ON I MEAN I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IT THE PRESENCE TRY
TO.
ZERO OUT THE BUDGETING BUT TERMS
OF THE MANAGEMENT THE
ORGANIZATION IS REALLY SHIP
WITH.
WITH AN INSTANCE LIKE YOURS HAS
THAT BEEN PRETTY STEADY FROM
BEFORE THE. THE THE CHANGEOVER
TO NOW YEN IN JUST TO PUT SOME
HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE AND IS
WELL THERE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN.
OVERTIME QUESTIONS OF WHETHER TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THESE
CULTURAL AGENCIES AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL THIS ISN'T THE FIRST TIME
THAT THIS HAS HAPPENED. AND SO I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
ALWAYS PREPARED FOR WHICH IS ONE
OF THE REASONS THAT WE'RE ALWAYS
LOOKING FOR OTHER SOURCES OF
FUNDING BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT AT
SOME POINT MAYBE IT WILL HAPPEN.
AND WHAT WE'VE REALLY BEEN PROUD
OF OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM FOR THE
HUMANITIES WE THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO HAVE. A PUBLIC
PRIVATE APPROACH TO THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING IT IN THE
SUPPORT THAT WE RECEIVE AND WE
ARE ARE.
VERY PROUD TO BE PART OF SUCH A
LARGE COALITION.
I THINK THERE'S A CRITICAL MASS
OF HUMANITY'S WORK THAT'S BEEN
DOING BUT HAPPENING AT THE THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND AT THE STATE
LEVEL ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND YOU
KNOW THE FACT THAT SOME. FEDERAL
MONEY COMES TO GRANTEES FROM THE
ANY H. DIRECTLY IS ALSO
SOMETHING THAT WE THINK IS
REALLY WONDERFUL IT'S IT'S
MULTIPLE WAYS OF SUPPORTING
HUMANITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
GRAHAM. DO YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT ABOUT SOME OF THE
PARTITION OPPORTUNITIES THAT YOU
SEE WITH STATE AGENCIES WHAT.
EXISTS CURRENTLY AND WHERE YOU'D
LIKE TO SEE SOME OF RUSSIA'S
CROW.
WE ARE WE LOVE SITTING AT THE
TABLE WITH THE OTHER AT THE
OTHER STATE AGENCIES THE
CULTURAL AGENCIES BECAUSE WE ALL
HAVE A COMMON GOAL TO REALLY
PRESERVE AND HELP.
OUR OUR COMMUNITIES THRIVE AND
WE ALSO WANT TO PARTNER WITH
WITH EDUCATION ORGANIZATIONS
SCHOOLS UNIVERSITIES WE DO THAT
IN A. IN A.
IN MORE INFORMAL WAY AND WE'D
LIKE TO BE MUCH MORE INTENTIONAL
ABOUT THAT WHICH IS WHY WE'VE
WORKED WITH KATIE AND AND ARE
LOOKING AT WHAT REALLY IS
HAPPENING AND NOT HAPPENING AT
THE EDUCATION LEVEL WITH THE
WITH THE HUMANITIES.
IS THERE A PARTICULAR.
PARTNERSHIP THE YOU HAVE IT
THAT.
AND EXEMPLIFIES THAT SPIRIT I
MEAN IT WITH WITH THAT WITH IT
WITH ANOTHER STATE AGENCY. SOME
PROJECT OR YOU KNOW I'VE ALWAYS
FELT THAT. THE WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE WITH THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL HAS BEEN CRITICAL. OF
NOT ONLY HOW WE SHARE.
.
THAT IS THAT THE IDEA THAT THE
ARTS REALLY EXPRESS THE
HUMANITIES RIGHT SO WE REALLY
ARE HAND IN GLOVE IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
THEM BUT ALSO JUST IN
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
ARTS EDUCATION HUMANITIES
EDUCATION I'LL JUST KEEP COMING
BACK TO THAT I THINK THE
CHILDREN OUR FUTURE. AND I THINK
THE THE THE THE ARTS COUNCIL
REALLY SHARES THAT BELIEF WITH
US.
YEAH.
SOME OF US LIKE TO MAKE A SONG
ABOUT WELL YOU KNOW I'VE GOT A
TUNE IN MY HEAD SOMEHOW.
WELL I YOU KNOW AND I WOULD
JUST MENTION A LEARNER MAYBE WE
SHOULD LOOK INTO.
.
CHANGING THE NAME OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT OKAY ARTS AND
HUMANITIES SELLABLE.
AND I MIGHT BE IN THE CITY FOR
I VOTE YES SOME NOT TO WRITE
ABOUT.
HI. SO DID YOU DID YOU DO YOU
KNOW. HOW YOUR DATA COMPARED TO
OTHER STATES AROUND THE COUNTRY?
I DON'T I TRY AND WE AREN'T WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO DO IT NATIONAL
COMPARISON I MEAN THOSE KINDS
EQUITY ISSUES ARE TYPICAL
UNFORTUNATELY HAS THE COUNTRY
SO.
.
I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED THAT
THEY WOULD BE SIMILAR.
CAR AND HAVE YOU HAVE YOU
SPENDING TIME LOOKING AT AND
MAYBE.
ANY OF YOU CAN COMMENT ON THIS
THE EXTENT TO WHICH.
THERE SOME.
REALLY COULD BEST PRACTICES IN
TERMS OF COORDINATION BETWEEN
HUMANITIES INSTITUTIONS AND.
SCHOOLS THAT WE OUGHT TO FIGURE
OUT WAYS TO TRY TO SCALE.
I THINK THERE ARE THINGS LIKE I
THINK OF THE UC OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT HAS OUT REACH TO THE
K. TWELVE PUBLIC SCHOOLS WITH A
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FOR TEACHERS. THERE ARE
CERTAINLY INDIVIDUAL
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
THAT DO OUR RESEARCH IN SCHOOLS.
URGENTLY IF YOU CAN THINK OF
OTHER.
SPECIFIC EXAMPLES.
AND IT'S CERTAINLY WRITTEN IN
THE STATE POLICY THAT ALL
STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO A
HUMANITIES EDUCATION.
.
SO I THINK THAT THE THE
EXEMPLARS WITH THE SORT OF.
ONE OFF LOCAL PARTITIONS MORE SO
AND THEN THOSE SUPPORTED BY THE
UC OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT.
AND.
YEAH PROGRAMS YEAH CREDIT MATTER
PROJECTS.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU TO
THE THREE OF YOU AND AND.
AND THINKS OBVIOUSLY HAD SO
MUCH OF WHAT WAS ON DISPLAY HERE
TODAY IS AS. A RESULT OF YOUR.
HARD WORK IDENTIFYING WHERE THE
PROJECTS AND THEN GETTING THE
FUNDING THEY NEED AND GIVEN THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED AND I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE IT A GREAT
DEAL AND. AND ALSO I JUST WANNA
THINK JULIE AND AND. HOW
EVERYONE FROM CALIFORNIA MATTERS
FOR COORDINATING WITH ARE
FANTASTIC INSULT AND I LEARNED
PEYSER MEANS AND YES OBVIOUSLY
SELF ASSEMBLY SIDE TO? WORK
REALLY HARD TO PULL THIS HIS
HEARING TOGETHER AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE HIGHLIGHTING THESE
KIND OF THESE STORIES
AND-FORTUNE EVERYTHING IS. BEING
RECORDED AND LIVE STREAM AND IT
IS A TOUGH THEY HAVEN'T I'VE
BEEN TRYING TO. GET MY
COLLEAGUES TO COME DOWN ADD TO
TO GET A LITTLE TASTE OF ALL
THIS OUT BUT WE GOT THE RULES
COMMITTEE MEETING BUDGETS AND
MEETING AND. I SAY WELL YOU CAN
STAY IN BUDGET AS LONG AS YOU
FIND THEM ARTS AND HUMANITIES.
SO.
IT'S A THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT A
NUMBER OF MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
THEIR VOICES ARE HEARD AS WELL.
WE'VE GOT.
BOB BENEDETTI. WE HAD TO LEAVE
OKAY AND. GOT.
MICHAEL SHANKLIN FROM KIDS
BASED CHILDREN'S MUSEUM AND.
COME UP FROM.
FROM PASADENA.
NOW OKAY CARLIN AND KNIFE HE MAY
FEEL.
THEY LEFT ARM IS THE THE.
THIS IS A.
YOU KNOW. THERE'S A TRADITION
HERE ATTRITION AND KAREN CAN GO
FROM.
OKAY JONATHAN BUT CHECK OUT BELL
FROM THE KIND OF LA. OTHER IS
OKAY.
CHINA GOT THE LATER FLIGHT.
COULD COME ON UP AND PROVIDE US
WITH YOUR TESTIMONY AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM OUR KIND
OF BELL.
WHO MAY HAVE ALREADY LEFT YOU
KNOW SHE'S A SHE'S DOING OKAY? I
WANT TO COME UP. WILL HAVE A
FAMILY AFFAIR AT THE DICE.
AND WHAT WILL BE WILL START WITH
YOU OF JONATHAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS JONATHAN PAYCHECK
ABOUT.
I'M A RESIDENT OF THE CITY OF
PASADENA SO ON THAT NOTE I WANT
TO SAY SHUT OUT TO SENATOR
PORTEND TINO. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN HE LIKE YOU EVERY
OTHER BOTH AND BUDGET COMMITTEE
SO WE KNOW THEY'RE BUSY AND
THEY'RE TAKING CARE OF US ALL
SHOUT OUT TO THOSE TWO
REPRESENTATIVES FROM OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT.
I'M AN URBAN PLANNER AT THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND I WORK
EXCLUSIVELY IN THE
UNINCORPORATED AREAS OF SOUTH
CENTRAL LOS ANGELES.
THE HUMANITIES ARE CRUCIALLY
IMPORTANT TO THE PEOPLE I SERVE.
THE HUMANITIES TEACHERS TO
REFLECT.
TWO QUESTION.
TO DEBATE.
TO CONFRONT.
AND TO ENJOY OUR HUMAN CONDITION
AND ALL ITS COMPLEXITIES.
HUMANITIES EDUCATION EMPOWERS
OUR STAKEHOLDERS TO INTERROGATE
AND RESIST THE OPPRESSIVE POWER
STRUCTURES THAT ARE PART OF
DAILY LIFE. IN SOUTH CENTRAL LOS
ANGELES.
YOUR CONSTITUENTS INCLUDE MANY
CALIFORNIANS INCARCERATED.
IN OUR STATES PRISONS.
FAR TOO MANY FOLKS OF THE
WORKING CLASS. AND FAR TOO MANY
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
THERE ARE NEIGHBORS.
THERE ARE FRIENDS. AND THERE ARE
FAMILY MEMBERS.
INCARCERATION DOES NOT ARREST
THE HUMAN NEED TO READ.
TO WRITE.
TO SPEAK.
WORDS ON CAGED OFFERS THEM A
SPACE TO ENGAGE IN CRITICAL
DIALOGUE AND REFLECTION. THAT
ENRICHES THE TIME SPENT BEHIND
BARS.
AND PREPARES SOME FOR
REINTEGRATION INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES IN SOUTH CENTRAL.
WORDS ON CAGE REMINDS US THAT
THE TWO.
OUR HUMAN.
DOCTOR ROY WAS KIND ENOUGH TO
COME DOWN TO THE COMMUNITY OF
FLORENCE FIRESTONE THE
UNINCORPORATED AREA JUST NORTH
OF WHAT'S IN PRISON IN WORDS AND
CAGE TO OUR. COMMUNITY LEADERS
GROUP AND GOT ONE HUNDRED
ERCENT SUPPORT FOR THE PROJECT
SO DOCTOR ROY IS THE REAL DEAL.
SO SENATORS AND COMMITTEE FOR
THESE REASONS I ASK YOU.
TO SUPPORT THE HUMANITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. AND TO CERTAINLY
EXPAND WORDS AND CAGED STATEWIDE
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
MR. MAY I AM MY NAME IS L.
HUNDRED BELL I AM ONE OF DOCTOR
ALWAYS FROM A GRADUATE STUDENT
AND I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE TO SEE
THAT. THE HUMANITIES ARE ALIVE
AND WELL IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT
THE FIGHT STILL ON SO THAT WE
KEEP IT GOING.
DOCTOR VOICE WORK AND THE MAN IN
LINE CASTERS SERVICE AN EXAMPLE
OF HOW THE HUMANITIES HELP WAS
RESISTANT AS MENTAL STEREOTYPES.
AND SYSTEM OF OPPRESSION. THAT.
PERPETRATE THESE STEREOTYPES.
WHAT'S ON CAGE BUILT A BRIDGE
BETWEEN PRISON AND UNIVERSITY
STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF THIS
COLLABORATION PRODUCES ENGAGE IN
DIALOGUE AND YOU NARRATIVES ALL
NARRATIVES.
THAT EXPAND OUR EDUCATION AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THE HUMAN AND
HUMANITIES. HUMANITIES AND MY
WORK WITH WORDS AND CAGE
STRENGTH MY COMMITMENT TO LISTEN
AND INCLUDE MARGINALIZED VOICES
INTO OUR CONVERSATION.
CONVERSATIONS ESPECIALLY THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THAT SHE POLICY
WHICH OF THEM BACK ULTIMATELY
AFFECT OUR EVERYDAY LIFE.
THANK YOU.
AND YOU'RE AND YOU'RE A GRADUATE
IN THERE IT WOULD YEAH I
GRADUATED LAST YEAR. ITHOUT
WHAT DID YOU STUDY ENGLISH WITH
DOCTOR ROY. YEAH FANTASTIC YEAH
GREATER GREAT.
WELL.
WE. I WANT TO WELCOME OUR OUR WE
LITERALLY SISTER HIS REPUBLIC OF
IT RICHARD BLUM.
WONDERFUL THAT MIGHT ACTUALLY
MY COUNTERPART IN THAT IN THE
STATE ASSEMBLY MY MY FAMILY
MEMBER.
BUT WE'VE WE'VE HEARD FROM SOME
FANTASTIC AS SPEAKERS TODAY.
A RICHARD ALSO IS ONE OF OUR
BUDGET SUB CHAIRS AND I KNOW AS
A WORKING HARD ON OUR BUDGET BUT
THERE'S THE CASE HAS BEEN MADE
VERY LOUD AND CLEAR FOR. FOR
FUNDING FOR THE HUMANITIES.
THROUGH SOME WONDERFUL PROJECTS.
I'M ALL FOR IT I APOLOGIZE FOR.
MISSING TODAY'S HEARING.
CLINTON'S BEEN ONE CRAZY DAY IN
SACRAMENTO NO.
THE ISSUES I DID LOOK AT THE
AGENDA AND TO. YOU CLEARLY HAD A
LOT ON YOUR PLATE IN THIS.
HEARING BUT THERE'S A LOT GOING
ON IN THE ARTS. IT'S.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT WE
FIND WAYS TO CONTINUE TO. BE
SUPPORTIVE ADS WILL BE LOOKING
AT THAT AND THE. IDEA WILL BE
FULLY BRIEFED BY MISTER ALLEN'S
GETS TOGETHER SO WELL WILL MAKE
SO EVERYTHING HAS BEEN
VIDEOTAPING I KNOW YOUR STUFF
AND FOLLOWING IT THERE'S A
LITTLE BOOKLET HERE WHICH WOULD
GIVE SOME OF THE GOOD STORY IS
GONNA MAKE YOU PERSONALLY GIVE
ME THE RUNDOWN AS WELL. AND I
SAY THERE IS A BUDGET REQUEST
STUFF FOR CAL HUMANITIES THAT I
I WILL CERTAINLY DISCUSS VIEW
AND TO MAKE SURE. WE GET IN
SOME.
AND IT'S A IT'S WORTH ITS WEIGHT
IN GOLD CERTAINLY A MODEST
REQUEST BUT I THINK WHEN THAT WE
OUGHT TO.
STRONGLY CONSIDER SOLON SO I
JUST WANT TO PERSONALLY THANK
EVERYBODY FOR BEING OUT FOR
BEING HERE I WANT TO I WANT TO
THANK THE HARD WORK OF OUR STAFF
ARE WORKING. TO HELP PULL THIS
TOGETHER AND AND DONE YOU KNOW A
LARGE COMPANY TO HELP IT
PARTICULARLY SPEAR HEADING IN
COMING FROM LOS ANGELES. OUT WE
WE HEARD SOME FANTASTIC VOICES
AND AND I.
.
REALLY GOT A GOOD SENSE OF HOW
LIVES ARE BEING CHANGED IN IN
ALL SORTS OF GOOD WAYS LARGE AND
SMALL. THROUGH THE WORK OF OF.
OF OUR OF OUR HUMANITIES
LEADERS AND SO I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE IT AND THANK EVERYONE
FOR THEIR TESTIMONY TODAY WITH
THAT. ARE HEARING IS HEREBY
ADJOURNING